IN ABOUT THIRTY SECONDS WE
APPRECIATE ALL OF YOU BEING
HERE TODAY WILL CONVENE HERE IN
ABOUT THIRTY SECONDS. THANK
YOU. TESTING GOOD AFTERNOON AND
WELCOME TO THIS JOINT HEARING
OF THE SENATE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE IN THE
ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE. WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
GENTLEMAN TO MY RIGHT. WE ARE
SO GRATEFUL TO BE A PARTNER
WITH CHAIRMAN FRAZIER FROM THE
ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE ON THIS. IMPORTANT
ISSUE OF SHARED MOBILITY
DEVICES I WANT TAKE MOMENT SAY
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR HIS
COMEDIAN AMAZING COMMITTEE TEAM
FOR ALL THE WORK THAT WENT INTO
TODAY THANK YOU SO MUCH. I ALSO
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU THE
GENTLEMAN TO MY LEFT- ANTON
FROM GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE FOR
ALL THE WORK THAT WENT INTO THE
PREPARATION FOR TODAY'S HEARING
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND TIME.
WE'RE ALSO HONORED TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
SENATE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
HERE TODAY THAT SENATOR BAIL-
IN THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
SENATOR FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
TODAY'S HEARING STAYING IN
THEIR LANE HOW SHOULD THE STATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS REGULATE
NEW MOBILITY OPTIONS IN
ASSURING ECONOMY. WILL BE FOCUS
IT'S GOING TO BE FOCUSED ON THE
POTENTIAL LOCAL AND STATE
REGULATIONS ASSOCIATE WITH THE
BIKES SCOOTERS AND OTHER
DEVICES. WE WANTED HAVE A
SERIES OF HEARINGS PRIOR TO
LEGISLATION BEING ADVANCE WHICH
WILL THEN ALLOW THE STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS REALLY TO DO
ITS DUE DILIGENCE. AND TAKE A
DATA DRIVEN APPROACH TO THIS
ISSUE RATHER THAN A ONE BILL AT
A TIME STRATEGY. A CANDIDLY WE
BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO HAVE A
COMPREHENSIVE LOOK. IN THE
SHORT TIME THAT DID THEY HAVE
BEEN ON OUR STREETS AND ROADS
SHARED MOBILITY DEVICES SUCH AS
THE SCOOTERS AND BIKES. HAVE
SOARED IN POPULARITY. NOT SINCE
THE INTRODUCTION OF RIDESHARING
SERVICES SUCH AS UBER AND LEFT
HAVE WE SEEN SUCH A NEW MODE OF
TRANSPORTATION BECOME SO WIDELY
ADOPTED IN SUCH A SHORT. PERIOD
OF TIME. IF DONE RIGHT SCOOTER
AND BOUGHT YOUR PROGRAM. HELP
CALIFORNIA ADDRESS MANY OF OUR
TRANSPORTATION CHALLENGES
INCLUDING REDUCING GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS AND- GETTING MORE
PEOPLE AND OTHER FORMS OF MASS
TRANSIT IN. URGING MORE ACTIVE
FORMS OF TRANSPORTATION.
HOWEVER WE ALSO KNOW THAT THESE
DEVICES COME WITH SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES. PARTICULARLY FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT ARE ON
THE FRONT LINES REGULATING THIS
FLEDGLING INDUSTRY. BUILDING
EMAILS AND PHONE CALLS FROM
RESIDENTS THAT FIND THEMSELVES
DODGING SCOOTERS- TRYING TO
AVOID INJURY OUR EYES SIDEWALK
THAT IS BLOCKED. ENSURING THAT
HE BIKES AND SCOOTERS ARE
DEPLOYED EVENLY ACROSS THE
CITY. IS ANOTHER ISSUE ENSURING
THAT EQUAL ACCESS FOR ALL
NEIGHBORHOODS AS A PRIORITY.
IT'S A MAJOR CONCERN FOR MANY
MUNICIPALITIES AS WELL. LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE TASKED WITH
MAKING SURE THAT ALL
TRANSPORTATION YOU USERS.
PEDESTRIANS AND CYCLISTS
SCOOTERS AND OTHERS CAN SIMPLY
USE THE PUBLIC RIGHT AWAY.
BASED ON LOCAL NEEDS IN
CIRCUMSTANCES. WE'VE CONVENE
THIS JOINT HEARING. TO
UNDERSTAND THE NUANCES OF
REGULATING THE SHARED MICRO
ABILITY INDUSTRY. INTO A FORM
THE LEGISLATURE'S WE CONSIDER
WHERE STATE STANDARDS. OR
REQUIREMENTS ARE OR ARE NOT
NEEDED. EIGHT FULL THAT WE HAVE
ONE OF THE AUTHORS AND I KNOW
THAT ASSEMBLYMEMBER TO CHEESE
ON HIS WAY- THE LARGEST SHARED
MOBILITY DEVICE BILLS HERE WITH
US TODAY WE'RE HONORED THAT IS
IN THE WOMAN FRIEDMAN IS
JOINING US WE WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR WORK. AND YOUR
PARTNERSHIP AS WELL WE'RE
GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE HERE TODAY.
WE'RE FIRST GOING TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THE STATE'S LAST
EXPERIMENT A MOBILITY CHANGES
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK.
COMPANIES AND TO SEE WHERE AND
WHAT WE CAN APPLY FROM THAT
EXPERIENCE A SHARED SCOOTERS
AND BIKES. WE WILL THEN HEAR
FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THE
SCOOTER INDUSTRY AND CONSUMER
ADVOCATES ON THE CHALLENGES.
THEY ALL FACES THEY CONTEND
WITH REGULATION OF THESE NEW
TRANSPORTATION TECHNOLOGIES.
AGAIN TODAY'S HEARING IS FOCUS
ON THE POTENTIAL FOR LOCAL AND
STATEWIDE REGULATION. A
SECONDARY HEARING WILL HAPPEN
AFTER THE FIRST OF THE YEAR ON
DATA SHARING THAT'S THE OTHER.
BIG ISSUE THAT HAS RISEN FROM
THE INDUSTRY. NOW I'M GONNA
TURN IT OVER TO OUR PARTNER
HE'S STILL A MEMBER FROM
DISAGREED PAY FOR HIS
INTRODUCTORY REMARKS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR MCGUIRE IS A
WILL MOVE ON TO SMARTPHONES
HAVE REVEL IN IT REVOLUTIONIZED
THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR.
BELOW IS TO HILL SOMEONE
DRIVING THEIR PERSONAL VEHICLES
TO CATCH A RIDE. THEY HAVE
ENABLE COMPANIES TO RENTAL
BICYCLES AND SCOOTERS WITHOUT A
TACORI STORE. ALLOW FREE EASY
ACCESS TO NAVIGATION OUR IN OUR
CARS. AND ONE DAY THEY WILL
ALLOW US TO HAIL A DRIVERLESS
VEHICLES TO PICK US UP. THE
WORLD OF TRANSPORTATION IS
RAPIDLY CHANGING. AND
GOVERNMENT HAS STRUGGLED TO
KEEP UP WITH THESE. AND HOW TO
RE REGULATE THE EMERGING
TECHNOLOGIES. THESE CHANGES
HAVE BEEN JOLTING FOR SOME AND
SO MANY. SOME HAVE USED
SCOOTERS AS A GREAT FIRST AND
LAST MILE SOLUTION FOR PUBLIC
TRANSIT A FUN WAY TO TOUR A NEW
CITY OR EVEN SOMETHING TO
EXPAND OUR LUNCH OPTIONS DURING
WORK HOURS. FOR OTHERS THE
SCOOTERS HAVE BEEN IT BLIGHT.
THE BLOCK SIDEWALKS BACK IN THE
BLACK ACCESS FOR THE DISABILITY
COMMUNITY. TAKE WAY PARKING
SPOTS FOR CARS AND BIKES AND
MAKE OUR SIDE WITH LOOK LIKE A
CLUTTERED MESS. DESPITE IT
BEING ILLEGAL TO RIDE SCOOTERS
ON A SIDEWALK WRITERS OFTEN
MISUSE THEM AND MAKE
PEDESTRIANS FEEL LESS SAFE BY
ZOOMING PAST THEM GOING TEN
MILES PER HOUR. THE INCLUDED BY
CLEANS ON OUR BEACHES TAKING
AWAY THE ENJOYMENT OF A
LEISURELY BIKE RIDE. BECAUSE
THESE DEVICES USE OUR PUBLIC
STREETS INSTEAD OF A BRICK AND
MORTAR STORE OR A DOG. THEY
OFTEN HAVE TO RELY ON CHEAP
LABOR TO PICK THEM UP. AND TO
CHARGE THEM. SOME HERALD THESE
DEVICES A REPLACEMENT FOR CARS.
OTHERS HAVE QUESTIONED HOW A
DEVICE THAT NEEDS TO BE CHARGED
EVERY FIFTEEN MILES CAN TRULY
REPLACE CAR TRIPS. ESPECIALLY
IN TODAY'S ENVIRONMENT WERE
POWER OUTAGES ARE STARTING TO
FEEL LIKE THE NEW NORMAL.
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS ARE
RAPIDLY CHANGING TODAY YOU HAVE
TO FIND A BIKE OR SCOOTER TO
RIDE ONE. IN A FEW YEARS AN
AUTOMATED BIKE OR SCOOTER MAY
COME TO YOU. AS THESE NEW
TECHNOLOGIES CONTINUE TO EMERGE
THERE WILL BE A RUSH OF
LEGISLATION TO ADDRESS THE
CHALLENGES THAT THEY WILL POSE.
COMPANIES WHO FEAR REGULATION
WOULD OFTEN PREFER TO HAVE TO
DEAL WITH THESE THE PUT THE
STATE OVER EACH OF OUR FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES ARE HUNDREDS.
AND HUNDREDS OF CITIES. BUT
SOMETIMES ARE LOCALS ARE BETTER
EQUIPPED TO REGULATE BUSINESSES
ESPECIALLY ONES THAT HEAVILY
RELY ON PUBLIC SPACE TOP. THE
PURPOSE OF THIS HEARING TODAY
IS TO TAKE A DEE BREATH AND
CONSIDER WHAT OUR ROLE AS
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE AND WHAT WE SHOULD
BE IN DEVELOPING COMPLY JUST
LISTEN TO ADDRESS THESE
EMERGING TECHNOLOGIES. THIS
pOPPORTUNITY HERE FROM THE
CITIES ON THE GROUND HAVE
ALREADY TAKEN COMPREHENSIVE
STEPS TO REGULATE SHARED
MOBILITY DEVICES. WE WILL HAVE
WE WILL ALSO HEAR FROM OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS ON WHAT THEY
BELIEVE IS THE APPROPRIATE ROLE
FOR THE STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND REGULATING
SHARED MOBILITY DEVICES. I LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING FROM OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND THE
STAKEHOLDERS IN THIS BRAVE NEW
WORLD OF TRANSPORTATION POLICY.
WITH THAT SENATOR. WITH A TEAM
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
THE PARTNERSHIP- WOULD LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO SEE IF THE CHAIR
FROM. SENATE TRANSPORTATION
WOULD LIKE TO SAY IN THE
OPENING WORDS OR ANY MEMBERS
INCLUDING SOMEONE FRIEDMAN. WHO
IS ONE OF THE AUTHORS OF THE
BIG BILLS THAT HAVE BEEN
MOVING. ANY OPENING COMMENTS
PLEASE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND THANK YOU FOR HOLDING THIS
HEARING IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT I
THINK TO GET EVERYONE TOGETHER
TO HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS HE
WOULD CITIES ARE DOING IN HERE
FROM THE STAKEHOLDERS DIRECTLY
ALL TO SAY THAT I REPRESENT
PARTS OF LOS ANGELES- IT'S AN
AREA THAT IS DEALING WITH
TRAFFIC CONGESTION AND TRYING
TO FIND A WAY TO GET PEOPLE ON
TO PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION IN A
DEAL WITH THE GROWING
POPULATION YOU KNOW WHEN A WITH
THE REALIZATION THAT WE ALL
CAN'T BE DRIVING CARS
EVERYWHERE WE NEVER. HAVE ANY
SPACE TO GET ANYWHERE AND WE
SEE WHAT. OUR CULTURE HAS DONE
TO LAND USE- AND TO GROWTH IN
OUR- COMMUNITY AND TO OUR
QUALITY OF LIFE IN OUR HEALTH.
MY GOAL IS TO TRY TO FIND A WAY
TO ALLOW CITIES TO CONTINUE TO
PLAN TO GET PEOPLE OUT OF CARS.
TO GET PEOPLE ON THE TRANSIT.
OF SCOOTERS AND OTHER MICHAEL
MOBILITY HAVE A GREAT.
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP WITH THE
FIRST MILE LAST MILE PROBLEM-
BUT WE ALSO SEE THIS HUGE
BACKLASH- TO THEM- YOU KNOW
I'LL BE. HONEST I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE UTILIZE THESE
FORMS OF TRANSPORTATION AND
FIND A WAY TO INTEGRATE THEM-
QUICKLY AND SAFELY INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES AND THAT WAS THE
GOAL OF MY LEGISLATION- AND.
LOOKING FOR THE CONVERSATION
TODAY SO THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH THE MOMENT SOMEONE
WELCOME. WANT TO SEE IF YOU IS
THE TWO OF YOU BEEN FOR THE
FOCUSING IN IN THIS SPACE TWO
DIFFERENT SUBJECTS RELATED TO
THE SHURE MOBILITY DEVICE
MARKET. MR SALOON YOU LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO OFFER ANY OPENING
REMARKS YES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MISTER SHERMAN AND MR
SHERMAN FOR THIS HEARING I. I
BELIEVE A WORD. YOU KNOW-
BASICALLY ON THE SAME PAGE AND
THAT WE ALL RECOGNIZE THAT-
WHILE THERE. IS GOOD REASON
OTHER SHARED MOBILITY DEVICES
CAN BE FUND AFFORDABLE. AND ECO
FRIENDLY WAYS TO GET AROUND-
LIKE ANY NEW INNOVATION E NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S SAFE-
BOTH FOR USERS AND FOR
PEDESTRIANS AND THE GENERAL
PUBLIC. WITH BASIC CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS. THAT'S WHY I
INTRODUCED ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
EIGHTY SIX. TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS OF THESE SERVICES AS
WELL AS THE GENERAL PUBLIC. BY
REQUIRING CITIES AND COUNTIES
TO DOT BASIC SAFETY RULES. AS
WELL AS PROVIDING FOR CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS THAT WOULD PROTECT
USERS. AND THIRD PARTIES IN AND
BACK EVENT OF AN INJURY- IF I.
RECOGNIZE SO MISTER CHAIRMAN I
HEARD YOU- AS IT WAS COMING
OVER HERE ABOUT THE NEED TO
HAVE- THE BIG PICTURE IN MIND
AND SO I LOOK FOR IN THE
CONVERSATION TODAY. THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND- BEFORE I TURN OVER
TO THE CHAIRMAN I JUST WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO BOTH ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
BE TO WORK WITH YOU TO THE
COMMITTEES- IN TAKING A BIG
PICTURE LOOK AT THIS- AND
HOLISTIC LOOK. AT THIS ARE
MERGING ISSUE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE- BOTH HERE IN CALIFORNIA
THIS IS EMERGING ISSUE
THROUGHOUT OUR COUNTRY AS WELL.
SO WITHOUT FURTHER ADO IF-
ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO SAY IN THE OPENING
REMARKS. I DO ON A WALK IN THE
VICE CHAIR FROM GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE CENTER MORE LUCK WITH
YOUR TO DO THINK SO MUCH HERS
GOOD TO SEE YOU. WITHOUT
FURTHER DO ALTERNATE OVER THE
CHAIR TO INTRODUCE OUR FIRST
PANEL. SIR FIRST PANELS- BLOOM
TO THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF UCLA
INSTITUTE OF TRANSPORTATION
STUDES WELCOME. THANK YOU FOR
COMING ALL THIS WAY OF HIS
HEARING. WHEN YOU'RE PREPARED
PLEASE STRUCTURE PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME MISTER
CHAIRMAN MISTER CHAIRMAN- MY
NAME IS ONE WAY TO TâM THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE UCLA
INSTITUTE OF TRANSPORTATION
STUDIES TODAY TO INTRODUCED
THIS TOPIC I'LL BE SPEAKING
ABOUT- WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT
SHARED MOBILITY DEVICES AND
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK
COMPANIES AND AS IMPORTANTLY
WHEN WE KNEW IT- WHAT OTHER
STATES ARE DOING TO REGULATE
SHARED MOBILITY DEVICES AND
WHAT CALIFORNIA CITIES ARE
DOING TO REGULATE SHARED
MOBILITY FIVE DEVICES. SO WHAT
DO WE KNOW ABOUT SHARED
MOBILITY DEVICES ANTEON SEES
WELL I WOULD SAY THAT WE KNOW
MORE ABOUT SHARED MOBILITY
DEVICES SOONER IN THEIR
EVOLUTION THAN WE DID FOURTEEN
AND SEES BECAUSE OF HOW THE
REGULATORY STRUCTURE AFFECTS
DATA COLLECTION AND DATA
SHARING. SO RIGHT NOW CITIES
REQUIRE PUBLIC RELEASE OF
DEVICE POSITION DATA OF AND
PRIVATE SHARING OF OPERATIONAL
DATA- SHOULD MOBILITY PROVIDERS
ALSO SHARE- PUBLIC THE- DEVICE
POSITION DATA AS A- MARKETING
TOOL TO SHOW THEIR CONSUMERS
WHERE THESE DEVICES MIGHT BE.
AND CITIES ARE ALSO REQUIRING
SHARED MOBILITY PROVIDERS TO-
FIELD SURVEYS AND TO PROVIDE
THE RESULTS OF THE SURVEY IS TO
THE CITIES. IN CONTRAST TNC IS
WERE NOT REQUIRED TO RELEASE
DATA PUBLICLY AND I'VE ONLY
SHARE DATA PRIVATELY WITH THE
CPUC AND AIRPORTS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND SO AS A CONSEQUENCE OF
THAT- WHAT THE RESEARCH
COMMUNITY KNEW ABOUT TNC LAGS
EFFICIENTLY WHAT THE RESEARCH
COMMUNITY NOW KNOWS ABOUT
SHARED MOBILITY DEVICES. SO THE
FIRST STUDY THAT ACTUALLY USE
DATA ON TMZ'S WAS A TWENTY
FIFTEEN CONFERENCE PAPER SO
THAT'S THREE YEARS AFTER THE
LAUNCH IN SAN FRANCISCO. OF
UBER ACCENT AND THE LIVE
SERVICE AND WHAT THEY DID IS
THEY CREATED FORTY THREE COPIES
OF THE UBER APP TO COLLECT DATA
BECAUSE IT WASN'T SURE IT
WASN'T PUBLICLY AVAILABLE. AND
EVEN THAT STUDY ONLY PROVIDED
INSIGHT INTO CONGESTION PRICING
ALGORITHMS. OR SEARCH PRICING
ALGORITHMS RATHER AND THAT
PAPER WAS IN PEER REVIEWED YOU
HAVE TO GO FORTY EIGHT PLUS
MONTHS AFTER THESE SERVICES
LAUNCH THE TNC SERVICES LUNCH
TO HAVE THE FIRST REVIEWED
PAPER- THAT WAS INDEPENDENT.
AND THEN ANALYTICAL- AND THAT
WAS BASED ON- THE WORK OF AN
EARLY BRAZIL AND DAVID KIRK AND
IT BASICALLY LOOKED AT. NOT
OVER DATA NOT LIFTED UP BUTTON
IT SAID TRAFFIC FATALITY DATA
AND LOOKED AT THE INTRODUCTION
OF UBER INTO A MARKET PLACE.
AND SEE IF THAT AFFECTED
TRAFFIC FATALITIES AT ALL AND
THEY FOUND IT DIDN'T SO FOUR
YEARS AFTER. THAT STUDY WAS THE
FIRST FOUR YEARS AFTER THE
LAUNCH WAS THE FIRST REVIEWED
STUDY. FURTHER MORE AT THE
FIRST- CITY STUDY OR CITY
COUNTY STUDY IN THIS CASE WAS
BY THE SAN FRANCISCO COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY TO TRY
TO MAKE SENSE OF. THESE
VEHICLES IN THEIR DISTRICT AND
THAT WAS FIVE YEARS AFTER THEIR
LAUNCH- SO IN CONTRAST WE KNOW
A LOT TWENTY SIX MONTHS AFTER.
THE INTRODUCTION OF THESE
DEVICES INTO- THE. CITY OF
SANTA MONICA AND OTHER
LOCATIONS IN CALIFORNIA. ONE OF
THE THINGS WE KNOW ABOUT HIS
INJURIES- SO THERE HAVE BEEN
THREE MAJOR STUDIES OF
INJURIES- THAT HAVE BEEN
RELEASED IN THE PAST YEAR. WHEN
IT UCLA- ONE IN PORTLAND AND
ANOTHER IN AUSTIN AND ALL OF
THE STUDIES USED ITS DATA
COLLECTED IN EMERGENCY ROOMS TO
DESCRIBE INJURIES TO SCOOTER
USERS. BY THE MOST COMMON
INJURIES WERE TO THE UPPER
EXTREMITIES SO THE LIMBS- ARMS
BROKEN ARMS.ABOUT 15% OF
INJURIES. THAT WERE REPORTED
RESULTED IN A TRAUMATIC BRAIN
INJURY. THAT'S PARTIALLY
BECAUSE HELMET USE WAS REPORTED
TO BE UNDER 10% FOR THE INJURED
PARTIES. 8290% OF INCIDENTS
DEPENDING ON THE STUDY AREA
WERE SINGLE PARTY INCIDENTS
MEANING THEY DIDN'T INVOLVE
ANOTHER PERSON OR VEHICLE. SOME
USERS IN THOSE STUDIES WERE
INTOXICATED- 5% IN LA 16%
IMPORTANT PORTLAND AUSTIN
ACTUALLY FOLLOWED UP WITH
PEOPLE WHO HAD CRASHED AND
REPORTED TO THE EMERGENCY ROOMS
AND FOUND THAT 50% OF INJURED
PARTIES BELIEVE THAT ROADWAY
CONDITIONS CONTRIBUTED TO THEIR
CRASH OR THE SEVERITY OF THEIR
INJURIES AND- FOUND THAT THIRTY
PER 3% OF THOSE WHO WERE
INJURED WERE INJURED DRING
THEIR FIRST RIDE- AND 63% OF
THOSE REPORTING INJURIES- HAD
WRITTEN FEWER THAN NINE TIME
SUGGESTING THAT RATES COULD GO
DOWN OVER TIME. SO WHAT ARE
THOSE RATES AND HOW DO THEY
COMPARE WITH OTHER MODES OF
TRANSPORTATION- THE AUSTIN IN
PORTLAND STUDIES ESTIMATE RATES
INJURIES OF TWENTY TO TWENTY
FIVE INJURIES THAT REPORT TO AN
EMERGENCY ROOM PER HUNDRED
THOUSAND TRIPS- THE AUSTIN
STUDY NOTED THAT THIS WASN'T A
CAUSE FOR ALARM ALTHOUGH IT'S
HARD TO COMPARE THIS WITH OTHER
MODES OF TRANSPORTATION BECAUSE
WE JUST HAVE DATA ON INJURIES
WERE SOMEBODY REPORTED TO AN
EMERGENCY ROOM SO AS MORE
STUDY. HAPPENS IN THE FUTURE WE
EXPECT MARK. INFORMATION ON
THAT SAN FRANCISCO REPORTED
SIXTEEN COLLISIONS PER HUNDRED
THOUSAND A SKIP TRIPS. SO IN
GENERAL TO SIR MY- SUMMARIZE
THE INJURY DATA IT WOULD SEEM
THAT THERE'S- POTENTIALLY
HIGHER RISK AT NIGHT AND HIGHER
RISK WHEN IF SOMEBODY'S FIRST
FEW TIMES ON A SCOOTER- LOOK AT
UNC AND- UNVERIFIED BUT
INDEPENDENTLY COLLECTED DATA BY
AN INDUSTRY ANALYSTS. SUGGEST
THAT- ABOUT- TWENTY SIX OF
FORTY FOR COUNTIES TRACKED
OCCURRED AT NIGHT. SO WHAT DO
WE KNOW ABOUT SHARED MOBILITY
DEVICES AND TRAVEL BEHAVIOR. A
LOT OF WHAT WE KNOW COMES FROM
THE CITY SURVEYS THAT ARE
LAUNCHED AS A CONDITION OF THE
PERMITTING PROCESS. SO IN SAN
FRANCISCO 70% OF TRIPS WERE
UNDER TWO MILES. OF 41% OF
SCOOTER USERS OR MOBILITY
DEVICE USERS WOULD HAVE USED
CAR FOR THEIR MOST RECENT TRIP.
31% WOULD OF WALKED 11% WOULD
HAVE USE PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
AND 34% ACTUALLY USE THE DEVICE
TO GET TO PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
MUNIR PART. IN THIS CASE- SAN
FRANCISCO SANTA MONICA FOUND
HIGHER RATES OF DIVERSION FROM
CARS ABOUT FIFTY PERCENT- BUT
ALSO ONLY THAT 4% OF USERS
SURVEYED WERE GOING TO AND FROM
TRANSIT SO THE RESULTS FOR THE
LAST MILE. THAT MIGHT VARY
BASED ON LOCAL CONTEXT-
PORTLAND SOUND FOUND SIMILAR
FIGURES ONLY 6% USING THE-
DEVICES TO GET TO FROM TRANSIT.
SO IT SEEMS THAT THE AUTO TRIPS
THAT THESE SERVICES ARE
PRIMARILY DISPLACING ARE THEY
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK COMPANY-
TYPE TRIPS AND THAT WAS THE
CASE IN SAN FRANCISCO SANTA
MONICA. AND PORTLAND. THE END
THAT DIVERSION FROM CAR TRIPS
IS IMPORTANT TO ACHIEVING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS SO THERE WAS A PEER
REVIEWED STUDY EARLIER THIS
YEAR THAT LOOKED AT- THE
GREENHOUSE GASES FROM THE
MANUFACTURE OF THESE FACES
TRANSPORTATION ACROSS THE-
PACIFIC- DEPLOYMENT MAINTENANCE
ETCETERA. AND FOUND THAT A LOT
OF PEOPLE JUST FOCUS ON THE-
THE MILE TRAVELED YOU KNOW THE
ZERO EMISSION MILE TRAVELED BUT
ACTUALLY CLOSE 290% OF THE
EMISSIONS. WERE ASSOCIATED WITH
THE CONSTRUCTION OF THESE
DEVICES AND THE RELATIVELY
SHORT LIFESPAN. AND THE
REBALANCING ACTIVITY THAT TAKES
PLACE- WITH THESE DEVICES AND
SO THE EMISSIONS FROM RE
BALANCING CAN DEFERRED PENDING
ON THE OPERATING MODEL EMPLOYED
SOME EMPLOYEE A GIG BASS
PIECEMEAL MODEL IN SUMMER MORE
CENTRALIZED AND MORE EFFICIENT
IN TERMS OF THE MODEL THAT THE
COMPANY USES TO COLLECT
SCOOTERS. THE RESEARCHERS AT
SAN JOSE SOME- STATES MINETA
INSTITUTE DID A STUDY AND FOUND
THAT 90% OF SCOOTER SAMPLED IN
SAN JOSE. DIDN'T DISRUPT
PEDESTRIAN TRAFFIC COURSE THAT
MEANS THAT 10% DID. SO WHAT ARE
OTHER STATES DOING WELL
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL
CONFERENCE OF STATE
LEGISLATURES BUT TWENTY TWO
STATES HAVE ENACTED STATUTES
ADDRESSING SHARED MOBILITY
DEVICE BUSINESS MODELS FOR
DEVICE TYPES. CALIFORNIA
INCLUDED LAST YEAR FLORES AB
TWENTY NINE EIGHTY NINE. SO
WHAT THIS LEGISLATION IS DOING
AS PRIMARILY SETTING INSURANCE
REQUIREMENTS PER FOR PROVIDERS
SETTING THE RULES OF THE ROAD
FOR OPERATORS FOR EXAMPLE USE A
BICYCLE LANE WHEN PRESIDENT
YIELD TO PEDESTRIANS.
CALIFORNIA AND OREGON ARE THE
ONLY TWO STATES THAT RECALL-
PROHIBIT THESE USERS FROM USING
THE SIDEWALK. SETTING DEVICE
REQUIREMENTS SOME OF THIS
LEGISLATION SETS MAXIMUM
STATEWIDE SPEED OR
SPECIFICATION FOR THE SAFETY
FEATURES. CALIFORNIA IS ALSO
THE ONLY STATE TO REQUIRE A
DRIVER'S LICENSE FOR THEIR
OPERATION. SOME OF THESE BILLS
ESTABLISH AUTHORITY FOR LOCALS
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO ASSESS
FINES AND PENALTIES ON SHARED
MOBILITY DEVICE CENTER
OPERATORS. SEVEN OF THE TWENTY
TWO STATES EXPRESSLY ALLOW
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO PROHIBIT
THE OPERATIONS OF THESE AND
FIVE OF THE TWENTY TWO. STRICT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FROM APPLYING
ANY MORE RESTRICTIVE-
REGULATION ON THE IS THAT HOW
THEY WOULD REGULATE BICYCLES.
SOME OF THIS LEGISLATION DOES
DEAL WITH THE SHARING OF DATA
WITH LOCAL REGULATORS THREE
STATES AUTHORIZED LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO REQUIRE SCOOTER
DATA SHARING INCLUDING RIGHT
ACTIVITY DATA THAT'S- IS ON A
NEVADA AND UTAH. AND THESE LAWS
OFTEN SET PARAMETERS FOR HOW
THE LOCAL AUTHORITY USES THE
DATA WHETHER OR NOT IT SUBJECT
TO PUBLIC RECORDS REQUEST AND
THE DATA SECURITY FOR PUBLICLY
PERSONALLY IDENTIFIABLE
INFORMATION. IT DOESN'T APPEAR
THAT ANY STATE PROHIBITS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS FROM REQUIRING
ABILITY DATA SHARING. SO WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE CITY SO- THIS
IS BEEN A BIT OF A STUDY IN
CONTRASTS- BECAUSE OF TNC IS
WITH THE STATE PREEMPTION-
THERE WAS A UNIFORM STATEWIDE
APPROACH TO TNC INTEGRATION-
WITH SHARED MOBILITY DEVICES
IT'S A REALLY A CASE OF- AND
THE WORDS OF- LOUIS BRANDEIS
LABORATORIES OF DEMOCRACY
EXPERIMENTATION WITH DIFFERENT
MODELS. SO AS EVIDENCE OF THESE
CONTRAST SOME CALIFORNIA CITIES
PROHIBITS YOUR MOBILITY DEVICES
WITHIN THEIR JURISDICTIONS SO
THESE INCLUDE BEVERLY HILLS
GOAL LEADER. IN THE CITY OF
SANTA CRUZ. OTHERS HAVE KIND OF
TAKEN A OF. THE BACK OFFICE
SENSUALLY TACIT APPROVAL-
WITHOUT A FORMAL PERMIT
PROGRAMS OF SAN DIEGO WITH THE
LARGEST OF THE CITY'S UNTIL
THEY- LAUNCHED A FORMAL PERMIT
PROGRAM IN JANUARY- IN JULY OF
THIS YEAR. AND THEN MANY
CALIFORNIA CITIES TO HAVE
PERMIT PROGRAMS AND THIS
INCLUDES MANY OF THE CITY STILL
HERE FROM FUTURE PANEL TODAY-
BUT ALSO CITIES IS DIVERSE
SOUTH LAKE TAHOE. THE CITY OF
LONG BEACH. SO IN THESE
PERMITTING PROGRAMS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT REQUIREMENT
FOR SAFETY BUSINESS RULES
PROGRAM EVALUATION. AND SOCIAL
GOALS THAT THE HELP THESE
PROGRAMS THAT THESE OPERATORS
WILL HELP THEM ACHIEVE. TO THE
SAFETY RULES INCLUDE HOURS OF
OPERATION. RESTRICTED SPEED OR-
RESTRICTED OPERATING AREAS AND
WRITER EDUCATION AND HOW MAY
GIVE AWAYS. THE BUSINESS RULES
INCLUDE TYPICALLY INSURANCE-
BONDS AND FEES. AND JENNIFER
CATION REQUIREMENTS POINT OF
CONTACT TO LEVEL OF SERVICE FOR
CITY OR PUBLIC REQUESTS. FOR
SERVICES THE NUMBER OF DEVICES
THAT ARE PERMITTED AND THE
LOCATIONS WHERE THEY CAN BE
PLACED AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
DAY. AND THEN ANOTHER WEEK WILK
REQUIREMENT IS FOR DATA SHARING
TO ASSIST IN PROGRAM EVALUATION.
THE DIVERSITY OF THESE
PERMITTING PROGRAMS CAN HELP
IDENTIFY REGULATORY MODELS THAT
MAY BE MORE SUCCESSFUL IN
ACHIEVING SOME OF THESE LOCAL
GOALS- THE MOST FLEXIBLE THESE
PERMIT PERMITTING PROGRAMS HAVE
BEEN ADOPTED BY LOCAL ORDINANCE
THAT REFERS TO ADMINISTRATIVE
REGULATIONS. AND CAN BE UPDATED
AS NEW INFORMATION IS KNOWN
ABOUT THIS INVOLVING BUSINESS
MODEL BUT THE DOWNSIDE OF THIS
ENVIRONMENT APPROACH AND
REGULATORY FLEXIBILITY HAS BEEN
A PATCHWORK THEY CAN BE
CONFUSING TO USERS IN THE
COMPANIES. SO BE HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE. THANK
YOU FOR THAT. DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE ANY OTHER
MEMBERS WITH MORE. THANK YOU
MISTER ARE YOU SPEND A LOT OF
TIME. DISCUSSING THE RELEASE OF
POSITION DATA. I JUST DON'T
KNOW WHY WOULD A MUNICIPALITY
WANT THAT DATA WHAT KIND OF
DEEP DIVING ARE THEY DOING WITH
IT. SO THERE IS THE POSITION OF
A VEHICLE AVAILABLE FOR RENT
AND SO THOSE ARE OFTEN RELEASED
PUBLICLY BY THE PROVIDER SO IT
SAYS THERE IS A DEVICE RIGHT
HERE AT TEN TO NOW. THAT YOU
CAN GET AND SCAN AND RENT AND
THAT'S A MARKETING FUNCTION.
THE VEHICLE POSITION OR THE
TRIP POSITION DATA- IS CAN BE
USED FOR A VARIETY OF MEANS SO
SOME OF IT IS TRUST BUT VERIFY.
TO MAKE SURE IF YOU DO HAVE A
CAP ON THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
DEVICES IN YOUR CITY- THAT THE
FULL SUITE OF THE DATA REFLECTS
THAT THE- OPERATOR IS- IT
HEARING TO THAT CAP I SOME OF
THAT IS LOOKING AT THE NUMBER
OF TRIPS THROUGHOUT THE CITY
WHERE THEY'RE GOING TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT SEEMS. LIKE HONEST
DATA OTHERS JUST ASSISTING
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING-
THINKING ABOUT OF SAFETY FOR
ALL ROAD USERS BY CLEANS IT
CETERA UNDERSTANDING A LITTLE
BIT BETTER- INSTEAD OF DOING
MANUAL COUNTS WHERE PEOPLE ARE
USING BIKES OTHER TYPES OF
DEVICES SO THIS IS A- KIND OF A
BIG DATA APPROACH TO ASSIST
WITH SOME OF THE OTHER. AREAS
OF TRANSPORTATION MANAGEMENT
SAFETY FOR ROAD USERS. WOULD
THAT BE. OBVIOUS IMAGES TO OVER
ON YOUR TOWN YOU'D SEE WHAT
KIND OF ACTIVITIES GOING ON
WITH THE SCOOTERS. IT IT CAN BE
BUT THAT TO DO THAT IN A
SCIENTIFIC WAY- REQUIRE CERTAIN
PROCEDURES OFTEN HIRING.
AFRICAN JIM HEARING FROM DOING
A SCREEN LINE COUNT FOR A
PERIOD OF AN HOUR JUST TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT'S NOT MANIC TOTAL
TREND THAT'S BEING OBSERVED AND
THEN YOU MISS WHATEVER COUNTY
YOU HAVE THAT ARE OUTSIDE OF.
THE AREA THAT YOU'RE LOOKING AT
SO THIS TYPE OF DATA AND THIS
ISN'T THE ONLY THING THAT
THEY'RE USING IT FOR- CAN BE
QUITE HELPFUL IN IN. VALIDATING
WHETHER OR NOT THERE WAS
JUSTIFICATION FOR INVESTMENT IN
A BIKE LANE- LOOKING IF THE
BIKE LANE IS POTENTIALLY. PLAN
TO BE IN THE RIGHT AREA OR A
LOT OF PEOPLE ARE DOING OTHER
TYPES OF CUT THREE TRIPS- SO.
THEN I GET A AND ONE OTHER
QUESTION WOULD BE. AS HAS ANY
MUNICIPALITY FIGURE OUT HOW TO
FOR. FIND A FAIR SERVICE FEE OR
USE IT AS A REVENUE SOURCE JUST
LIKE THEY WOULD WITH TAXI
COMPANIES AND OTHER. RENTAL
ACTIVITIES. I DON'T KNOW IF ANY
ANY COMPANY OR ANY CITY HAS
FOUND SOMETHING THAT THE
PROVIDERS ARE HAPPY WITH- I
THINK IT'S YOU KNOW INVOLVING
MODEL SO THERE MIGHT BE SUBJECT
TO NEGOTIATION AND EVERY
MARKETS GOING TO BE DIFFERENT
AND SO CITIES HAVE DIFFERENT
PROPENSITIES TO HAVE PEOPLE
USING THESE DEVICES PEOPLE IN
CITIES HAVE DIFFERENT ABILITIES
AND WILLINGNESS TO PAY FOR THE
STOCK TYPE DEVICES SO THE. FEE
MAY DIFFER AND PIANIST
DIFFERENT THIS- RIALTO IS FROM-
SANTA MONICA. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN. WHEN
ASKING QUESTIONS YOU MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO ANSWER HI I KNOW THIS
ISN'T YOUR DATA IT'S THE THAT
YOU'RE YOU'VE COMPILED. SO YOU
MENTIONED THAT THERE WERE OTHER
STATES THAT ALLOW A SCOOTERS TO
BE ON SIDEWALKS THAT WERE ONE
OF A FEW THAT PROHIBITS THAT
STATEWIDE. IS THERE ANY
COMPARISON IN THE INJURY DATA
FROM OUR SCOOTERS THAT ARE
FORCED INTO THE STREET VERSUS
STATES THAT ALLOW SCOOTERS ON
SIDEWALKS. IS THERE ANY
COMPARISON AT ALL TO SEE IF
THAT REDUCES CERTAIN TYPES OF
INJURIES I AM I'M NOT AWARE OF
AN ANALYSIS THAT THAN THAT IS
DONE EXACTLY THAT AND THEN DID
YOU ALSO HAVE IT I'M SORRY IF I
MISLED YOU HAVE STATISTIC ABOUT
HOW MANY PEDESTRIANS ARE BADLY
INJURED BY SCOOTERS IT WAS- FOR
THE I DID NOT CITED- BUT FROM
THE STUDIES I REVIEWED IT WAS.
THE MID SINGLE DIGITS TO THE
HIGH SINGLE DIGITS FROM THOSE
VARIOUS CASES AND AUSTIN
PORTLAND AND IN AUSTIN AND
PORTLAND. OKAY THAT'S ALL I
HAVE THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MESSAGE. THANK YOU SO IN YOUR
SURVEY OF LAWS AND REGULATIONS.
IN DIFFERENT CITIES AS WELL AS
DIFFERENT STATES IT DO YOU HAVE
AN OPINION AS TO THE PROS AND
CONS OF ALLOWING- LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO ADOPT THEIR
OWN- PUBLIC SAFETY RULES VERSUS
HAVING US A MINIMUM. STATEWIDE
STANDARDS. DO I HAVE OPINIONS-
IF YOU DID IT IT SEEMS LIKE
THERE WOULD BE A MIX RIGHT WE
DON'T ALLOW THAT FOR. OF
VEHICLES WE HAVE A UNIFORM CODE
OF VEHICLES SIGNALS- RULES OF
THE ROAD STATEWIDE AND THEN
ALLOW LOCALS TO USE CERTAIN
TOOLS IN THE TOOL KIT TO SAY
OKAY YOU CAN'T GO HERE YOU
CAN'T PARK HERE. AND SO IT
COULD BE SOMETHING LIKE THAT
THAT IS THE RIGHT BALANCE WE
HAVE A- LOT OF DIFFERENT.
CIRCUMSTANCES IN THE STATE SO
IT'S HARD TO THINK OF ONE
UNIFORM STATEWIDE RULE OF THE
ROAD WITHOUT ANY. LOCAL
TWEAKING DESIGNATE CERTAIN
AREAS THAT'S PERMISSIVE- X.
EXCLUSIVE- WORKING WELL. DID
YOU SEE ANY EXAMPLES WHERE IT
MADE SENSE TO HAVE TO ALLOW US
CITIES TO HAVE. YOU KNOW THEIR
THEIR OWN. SAFETY RULES THAT
MAY APPLY TO THEIR THEIR OWN
LOCAL SEARCH A UNIQUE LOCAL
CIRCUMSTANCES- THEY MAY ARGUE
AGAINST HAVING A STATEWIDE
STANDARDS. SO YOU KNOW YOU
WOULD THINK CERTAIN THINGS LIKE
HOURS OF OPERATION MY- DEPEND.
EXTENDING SIR ALCOHOL SERVICE
HOURS IN CERTAIN AREAS SOME
AREAS MAY BE MORE POPULAR FOR
THAT TYPE OF ACTIVITY AND YOU
WOULD. PERHAPS ONE HAVE SME
LOCAL FLEXIBILITY AND WHEN-
THE- THE HOURS OF OPERATION
WERE CUT OFF BECAUSE OF KIND OF
THAT LOCAL DIVERSITY BUT. YEAH
LUCKILY IT'S NOT MY JOB TO
FIGURE THIS OUT IT'S ALL OF
YOUR TH- AND I AM NOT AWARE OF
A MODEL THAT- AT THIS POINT IS
FINDING THAT RIGHT BALANCE.
THANK YOU JERRY MCGUIRE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR JUST
ONE OBSERVATION AND THEN NOT
ONE QUESTION QUESTION FIRST IS
ANYTHING THAT YOU'RE SEEN IN
OTHER STATES THAT CALIFORNIA'S
NOT TOUCHED OR ARE GETTING
RIGHT. THAT WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT. WHEN I WHEN I WAS
READING THROUGH SOME OF THIS
LEGISLATION I WHAT IS. DID
STRIKE ME THAT THOSE THREE
STATES THAT AUTHORIZED LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO REQUIRE.
STUDENTS SCOOTER DATA SHARING-
BUT SET A RESTRICTIONS ON HOW
THAT DATA WAS COLLECTED. DATA
PRIVACY- CONFIDENTIALITY
TECHNICAL SECURITY ETCETERA.
THE TEAM TO BE A GOOD BALANCE
VERSUS RIGHT NOW HAVING IT
COMPLETELY UP TO LOCAL
PERMITTING PROCESSES- BECAUSE I
DO RECOGNIZE THE VALUE OF THAT
DATA. AS A RESEARCHER BUT ALSO
FOR THOSE OF. THOSE IN THE
AUDIENCE WHO HAVE TO REGULATE-
THESE TYPES OF VICES AND
WHATEVER MAY COME NEXT- IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT EFFICIENTLY- WITH AS
MUCH INFORMATION AS POSSIBLE
AND- THOSE THAT. THE REGULATION
ABOUT- HOW DATA WOULD BE
COLLECTED DID SEEM TO BE IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. YOU HAD MENTIONED
CONDITIONS IS ONE OF THE OF
PROBLEMS WITH THE INJURY- WAS
THERE ANY KIND OF SPECIFIC DATA
COLLECTED THAT WOULD ACTUALLY
IDENTIFY THE COULD BE USEFUL TO
BE ABLE TO TRANSMIT THE CITIES
THAT IT WAS THIS THAT OCCURRED
AND TO BE THE YOU KNOW TO LOOK
OUT FOR THIS KIND OF STUFF THAT
WE CAN ACTUALLY. UTILIZE I
THINK. TECHNICALLY THAT COULD
BE POSSIBLE WITH THE SENSORS
THAT ARE ON THE DEVICE IN THE
INFORMATION THAT SHARED- I'M
NOT AWARE OF ANY-
IMPLEMENTATION THAT'S DOING
THAT NOW LOOKING AT. CERTAIN
JOBS TO DEVICES AND REPORTING
THAT THERE MIGHT BE A POTHOLE
AT THAT LOCATION. THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO DID YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS. WELL IT IS A LITTLE
BIT ALONG THE LINE SAYS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LAURA FRIEDMAN I
KNOW SHIELDS FOR DAD I'M
THINKING OF FIVE PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES YOU KNOW BEING
INJURED AS WELL BECAUSE I JUST
WONDER WHAT GOES UNDER REPORTED
YOU KNOW WHEN WE HAVE A LOT OF
PEOPLE- I HAD THE THIRD ARE.
VISUALLY IMPAIRED PEOPLE IN
WHEELCHAIRS WORK. I GUESS I'M
CURIOUS IF YOU HAVE ANY
INFORMATION ON THAT AND. SO I.
AM WORRIED ABOUT THE UNDER
REPORTING BIAS OF EMERGENCY
ROOM VISITS AND THE SO THAT'S
WHY I. WASN'T ABLE TO COMPARE
THIS MODE OF TRANSPORTATION
WITH OTHERS- AND SO THE AN
INSTANCE WHERE SOMEBODY'S PATH
OF TRAVEL ON A SIDEWALK IT'S
BLOCKED BY. ONE OF THESE
DEVICES AYE BUT NOT IN A
WHEELCHAIR BUT I PUSH A
STROLLER OFTEN AND I'VE HAD
THIS- SITUATION HAPPEN TO ME-
IT'S- NOT SOMETHING THAT IS
TYPICALLY REPORTED SO THERE I
THINK COULD BE AN UNDER
REPORTING BIAS WITH WITH SOME
OF THESE. ENGINE WITH THE-
EIGHTY A ACCESS AND OTHER
ASPECTS. THE QUEST CENTER. I'M
I'M JUST CURIOUS DO YOU HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THESE DEVICES
BEING JUST DUMPED IN REMOTE
AREAS PARKS WHERE- THEY'RE NOT
EASILY ACCESSIBLE BY THE PUBLIC
IN YOU THEN YOU'D FIND THAT
THEY'RE JUST SORT OF LAYING
AROUND LIKE ABANDONED SHOPPING
CARTS AND THAT SOMEBODY FROM
THE COMPANY HAS TO GO AND
RETRIEVE THEM MORE IS THAT IN A
PROBLEM- SO SOME OF THE-
LITERATURE. TO HAS CITED SOME
OF THESE DEVICES BEING PULLED
OUT OF LIKE MERIT IN OAKLAND
OUT OF THE PACIFIC OCEAN DURING
BEACH CLEAN UP SO THAT IS A
PROBLEM IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT
CITIES WANT TO HAPPEN AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT THE COMPANIES I
THINK ARE MOTIVATED FOR
ECONOMIC MEANS TO TRY TO AVOID
HAPPENING BUT IT THIS LOSS OF-
DEVICES DUE TO THESE MECHANICAL
PROBLEMS VANDALISED SOME OR-
JUST- HIDING DAMAGE THEFT IS.
BEEN SOMETHING THAT I THINK
IT'S PLAGUED THE LONGEVITY OF
THE FIRST FEW GENERATIONS OF
DEVICES THAT WERE DEPLOYED IN
CALIFORNIA THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY I'M JUST WONDERING IF
IT'S IF IT'S A LOSS OF THE
DEVICE TO NOT JUST BECAUSE OF
THEFT VANDALISM BUT AT. A ONE
WAY TRIP TO TAKE IN AND IT'S
JUST LEFT SOMEWHERE WHERE IT'S
NOT AND IT PLACE FOR SOMEBODY
WOULD READILY BE WANTING TO USE
IT PER SE IF AND IT MAY NOT BE
AN ISSUE FOR THE COMPANIES TO
EMPLOY- WAR CONTRACT WITH
PEOPLE TO RE BALANCE SO TO
COLLECT FROM. THESE TYPES OF
AREAS TO BRING BACK WITHIN A
SERVICE HERE AT TO CHARGEOVERNIGHT TO MAINTAIN- BUT
CHALLENGE BEING THAT IF. THE
DEVICE MALFUNCTIONS AND NO
LONGER REPORTS ITS LOCATION.
THEY CAN'T FIND IT SO- BUT IN
GENERAL THERE IS HOPE A
MECHANISM FOR THAT OKAY THANK
YOU. OKAY. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OF THE COMMITTEE CENTER NEAR
SACRAMENTO THANK YOU SO MUCH DO
APPRECIATE YOUR TAKING TIME
THANK YOU AND THANKS FOR
TRAVELING YOUR SACRAMENTO AS
WELL IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU AND
WE SHOULD TIME YOU PEND ON THE
PHONE AS WELL PERFECT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH WELCOME THANK YOU
SIR. PLEASE IN GERMAN.THANK
YOU SO MUCH VISITS HERE WERE
NOT TO BE MOVING ON TO THE
SECOND PANEL THE SECOND PANELS
CAN BE LESSONS LEARNED FROM THE
PAST THE BENEFITS AND
DRAWBACKS. OF STATEWIDE
REGULATION TRANSPORTATION
NETWORK COMPANIES AND WHAT WE
CAN LEARN GOING FORWARD
ESPECIALLY RICHARD MOBILITY
DEVICES. ORGAN IN BY JARVIS UP
HE'S WITH- FOR PAUL FOR HIGHER
POLICY IN ENFORCEMENT. HE'S A
MINISTRY- WITHIN THE LOS
ANGELES DEPARTMENT
TRANSPORTATION. WE'RE GRATEFUL
THAT HE'S HERE TODAY AND WE'RE
ALSO APPRECIATIVE THAT KATE IS
HERE. KATE IS THE DIRECTOR OF
TAXIS AND ACCESSIBLE SERVICES
FOR SAN FRANCISCO MUNICIPAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY. THEY'RE
GONNA BE SHOWING ENSURING THEIR
PERSPECTIVE COME ON UP HERE AND
YOU ALL DON'T MIND JUST JOINING
US HERE AT THE TABLE. THEY'RE
GOING T BE- TALKING ABOUT ALL
ISSUES IN REGARDS TO WHAT THEY
SEE ON THE GROUND. BOTH IN A
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PERSPECTIVE. WE ARE
GRATEFUL FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP.
WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE HERE
TODAY- GONNA LOOK TO BOTH OF
YOU WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO. KICK US OFF IF YOU DON'T
MIND ALSO FORMALLY INTRODUCING
YOURSELVES ONE LAST TIME. HI
YOU HAVE. FIVE MINUTES AND I'LL
GIVE YOU THIRTY SECOND WARNING
WHO'D LIKE TO KICK US OFF.
PLEASE THE FORESHORES YOUR FIVE
MINUTES AND WELCOME THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS KATE TORRENT
AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF TAXIS%
AND ACCESSIBLE SERVICES AT THE
SAN FRANCISCO MUNICIPAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY I'M
PLEASED TO BE HERE TODAY TO
TALK ABOUT LESSONS WE'VE
LEARNED IN SAN FRANCISCO FROM
THE OPERATION OF TNC IS ON OUR
CITY STREETS. AND PROVIDE SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS MOVING FORWARD
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION AND THANK YOU FOR
HOLDING THIS HEARING. THE MTA
HAS BEEN AN ACTIVE PARTICIPANT
IN THE C. P. UC'S TNC RULE
MAKING PROCESS WHICH BEGAN IN
TWENTY TWELVE AND IS STILL ON
GOING. TO DATE WE'VE SUBMITTED
ABOUT FIFTY SETS OF COMMENTS
OUTLINING OUR POLICY CONCERNS
AND RECOMMENDATIONS RELATED TO
TNC HE'S- SHARED CITY AND STATE
GOALS. MTA SHARES THE STATE'S
AMBITIOUS GOALS RELATED TO
IMPROVING SAFETY REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
REDUCING VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
AND PROVIDING TRANSPORTATION
SERVICES TO COMMUNITIES OF
CONCERN AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. I'LL DISCUSS THE
IMPACT OF TEEN SEASON SAN
FRANCISCO THROUGH THE LENS OF
THE SHARED PRIORITIES. WHAT WE
KNOW ABOUT TEEN SEASON SAN
FRANCISCO. AS A LOCAL ENTITY
MTA DOES NOT HAVE REGULATORY
AUTHORITY OVER TNC EASE OR
ACCESS TO CONSISTENT DATA ABOUT
HOW THEY OPERATE ON OUR CITY
STREETS. THIS IS BEEN A
CHALLENGE BUT ARE RESOURCEFUL
COLLEAGUES AT THE SAN FRANCISCO
COUNTY CONGESTION MANAGEMENT
AGENCY ANALYZE TNC TRIPS THAT
BEGAN AND ENDED WITHIN SAN
FRANCISCO DURING FALL TWENTY
SIXTEEN. WELL NOT INCLUSIVE OF
ALL TNC TRIPS IMPACTING SAN
FRANCISCO THE RESULTS WERE
STILL QUITE SHOCKING THE
IMPACTS ARE VERY REAL ON OUR
CITY STREETS FOR EXAMPLE ON A
TYPICAL WEEK DAY 15% OF ALL
TRIPS THAT START IN AND WITHIN
THE CITY BONDARIES WERE MADE
BY T. AND SEES. WHICH IS ABOUT
TWELVE TIMES A NUMBER OF TAXI
TRIPS. TEEN SEES ACCOUNTED TNC
TRIPS ACCOUNTED 450% OF THE
INCREASE IN CONGESTION BETWEEN
TWENTY TEN AND TWENTY SIXTEEN.
IN A MORE RECENT STUDY USING
DATA FROM SEPTEMBER TWENTY
EIGHTEEN FERRON PEERS FOUND
THAT TNC IS ACCOUNT 413% OF
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED IN THE
CORE OF SAN FRANCISCO. WHY IT
MATTERS. TNC OPERATIONS CAN
CREATE SAFETY HAZARDS FOR ALL
ROAD USERS. TNC OPERATIONS
OFTEN RESULT IN RISKY TRAVEL
AND DRIVING BEHAVIOR INCLUDING
PICK UPS AND DROP OFFS ANDNON
DESIGNATED. DESIGNATED ZONES
WHICH OFTEN RESULT IN CONFLICTS
WITH OTHER ROAD USERS. SAN
FRANCISCO POLICE DEPARTMENT
DATA FROM TWENTY SEVENTEEN
INDICATES THAT TNC IS COMPRISED
64% OF MOVING VIOLATIONS IN SAN
FRANCISCO'S DOWNTOWN CORE.
THESE DANGEROUS PICK UP AND
DROP OFF BEHAVIORS LEAD TO
HAZARDS IN INJURIES TO CYCLISTS
AND PEDESTRIANS AND ALSO
SIGNIFICANTLY INTERFERE WITH
TRANSIT VEHICLES. MORE TNC
VEHICLES ON THE STREETS CAN
LEAD TO MORE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. AS NOTED IN THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN PROGRESS REPORT
ON CALIFORNIA'S SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES IN CLIMATE
PROTECTION ACT CALIFORNIA IS
NOT ON TRACK TO MEET ITS
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION
REDUCTION GOALS THE REPORT
NOTES THAT PASSENGER MILES
TRAVELED ARE GOING IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION. IN INCREASE IN TNC
PRIVATE VEHICLE ACTIVITY IS
DIRECTLY AT ODDS WITH THE
STATE'S FORWARD THINKING
TRANSPORTATION GOALS EMBEDDED
IN POLICIES AND GRANT PROGRAMS
SUCH AS REDUCING TRIPS TAKEN IN
SINGLE OCCUPANCY VEHICLES.
DOUBLING TRANSIT RIDERSHIP AND
TRIPLING BICYCLE USE. MASS
TRANSIT REMAINS THE MOST
EFFICIENT AND SUSTAINABLE FORM
OF TRANSPORTATION. IT HAS BEEN
OUR LONG STANDING GOAL TO MAKE
TRANSIT THE MOST APPEALING
TRAVEL CHOICE AND SHIFT PEOPLE
TO OUR MUNY SYSTEM WHICH IS
EVEN MORE CRITICAL NOW GIVEN
SAN FRANCISCO'S GROWING
POPULATION AND LIMITED RIGHT OF
WAY. AND OF COURSE OUR CLIMATE
GOALS. PNC'S PARKING AND BUS
OWNS OUR BUS ONLY LANES
ABSTRACT TRANSIT SLOWING DOWN
UP TO EIGHTY OR MORE PEOPLE ON
THE BUS. MOREOVER THE INCREASE
CONGESTION CAUSED BY T. AND
SEES FLOWS DOWN BUSES THAT
SHARE THE RIGHT OF WAY WHICH IS
WHY IN TA HAS INVESTED MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS AND BUS ONLY LANES
AND BUS RAPID TRANSIT. TNC IS
HAVE STATED THAT ONE OF THEIR
GOALS IS TO PROVIDE FIRST AND
LAST MILE CONNECTIONS TO
TRANSIT THAT'S A WORTHY GOAL
BUT IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO MEASURE
PROGRESS WITHOUT SUPPORTING
INFORMATION. TNC SERVICE IS NOT
ACCESSIBLE TO ALL. EQUITY
CONSIDERATIONS ARE SIGNIFICANT
FACTORS IN PUBLIC TRANSIT
PLANNING AND OPERATIONS AT THE
MTA. TNC IS ARE NOT CURRENTLY
ACCESSIBLE TO EVERYONE
INCLUDING PEOPLE USING
WHEELCHAIRS AND THOSE WITHOUT
SMARTPHONES CREDIT CARDS OR
BANK ACCOUNTS. WE'RE PLEASED TO
SEE PROGRESS ON TNC PROVISION
OF ACCESSIBLE SERVICES WITH THE
PASSAGE OF SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY
SIX. WHICH REQUIRES A PER TRIP
FEE TO FIND ACCESSIBLE TNC
SERVICES AN MTA IS ACTIVELY
INVOLVED IN THE ONGOING
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
LEGISLATION. TNC SERVICES HAVE
SEVERELY IMPACTED THE TAXI
INDUSTRY. THE RISE OF TEEN SEES
AND THE REGULATORY FRAMEWORK
ESTABLISHED BY THE CPC AS WELL
AS WHAT APPEARS TO BE MINIMAL
ENFORCEMENT HAVE SEVERELY
IMPACTED TAXI SERVICES THE TAXI
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK IS A LONG
STANDING THE STATE HAS BROAD
TAXI HAS SET BROAD TAXI
REQUIREMENTS AND ALLOWS LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO ESTABLISH
ADDITIONAL REGULATIONS. THERE'S
NOT A QUOTE LEVEL PLAYING FIELD
IN TERMS OF TAXI AND TNC
REGULATIONS IF ABOUT ONE MINUTE
OKAY WOW. I HAVE A LOT TO SAY.
THANK YOU SO I'M JUST GOING TO
CUT TO THE CHASE AND I'M GOING
TO MENTION- ARE THREE BROAD
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THEN I'LL
BE HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS-
REGULATION OF PRIVATE
TRANSPORTATION SERVICES SHOULD
BE DRIVEN BY STATE WHY
TRANSPORTATION GOALS. TO
REGULATIONS OF PRIVATE
TRANSPORTATION SERVICE MUST BE
TAILORED TO THE DYNAMICS OF
DIFFERENT MARKETS AND THE STATE
SHOULD ALLOW A CITY OR COUNTY
TO ADOPT ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS FOURTEEN AND SEES
TO OPERATE IN ITS JURISDICTION.
THANK YOU AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE IN IT AND OBVIOUSLY A LOT
MORE TO SAY ON THIS TOPIC SO.
THAT'S THE MYSTERY NAY IN VERY
GRATEFUL SO WELL IF IT'S OKAY
WITH YOU- WILL HAVE YET TO
PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL
BACKGROUND. AS QUESTIONS COME
UP OF THAT WORKS FOR YOU I'M
HAPPY TO. TO WHATEVER WORKS FOR
THE COMMITTEE I DON'T THINK YOU
SO MUCH IT REALLY MEANS A LOT
YOU'RE HEARING THANK YOU FOR
BRING YOUR EXPERTISE TO THE
COMMUNITY. THEY WERE VERY
GRATEFUL. NOW CAN WE TURN IT
OVER TO OUR SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
PERSPECTIVE MR MURRAY. AND I'M
SORRY THE FLOOR SHORTS YOU
DON'T MIND REDUCING YOURSELF
WE'RE GRATEFUL YOU'RE HERE
THANK YOU FOR TRAVELLING NORTH
TODAY. THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
AND THANK YOU FOR HAVING US
HERE. AND THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING OUR COMMENTS HERE
TODAY IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO
US. MY NAME IS JARVIS MURRAY I
AM THE FOR HIRE POLICY
ENFORCEMENT ADMINISTRATOR FOR.
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES AND IN
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES- MUCH
LIKE THIS TORRENT HERE WE
REGULATE TAXICABS. AS WELL AS
AMBULANCES NON EMERGENCY
MEDICAL TRANSPORTATION. AND
SHUTTLES AND ALSO- MICRO
TRANSIT TO A CERTAIN DEGREE SO.
IN LOS ANGELES WE REGULATE
QUITE A BIT IN TERMS OF THE FOR
HIRE VEHICLE SPACE. MUCH I
FRANKLY AGREE WITH A LOT OF
WHAT MR AND IS ALREADY STATED
HERE. AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT I
THINK THE COMMITTEE UNDERSTANDS
THAT. BECAUSE WE HAVE A TWO
TIERED SYSTEM AND WE'RE UNABLE
TO HAVE ANY DATA FROM THE TNC
EASE. WE HAVE A HODGE PODGE OF
REGULATION NOW BETWEEN THE FOR
HIRE VEHICLES THAT CURRENTLY
THERE ARE REGULATED BY CITIES.
FOR HARD VEHICLES ARE REGULATED
THROUGH THE STATE. IN LOS
ANGELES AND I THINK THIS IS
TRUE ALSO IN SAN FRANCISCO. OUR
GOALS ARE ARE RELATIVELY SIMPLE
IN TERMS OF WE LOOK FOR THE FOR
HIRE SPACE AND WE'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE SAFETY. EQUITY
ACCESSIBILITY AND
SUSTAINABILITY. AGAIN THESE ARE
THINGS THAT WE FOCUS ON HEAVILY
WITH ARE REGULATED SPACE SUCH
AS TAXICABS AND AMBULANCES AND
NON EMERGENCY MEDICAL BUT WE
HAVE NO CONTROL OVER THIS AS IT
RELATES TO UBER AND LIFT OR ANY
OTHER TNC MODEL. SO FOR EXAMPLE
IN THE SAFETY SPACE DRIVERS IN
TAXICABS THIS IS TRUE ALSO IN
SAN FRANCISCO ARE FINGERPRINTED
FOR BACKGROUNDS AS WELL AS DRUG
TESTED. TAXICABS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA FOR OUR ACCESS
PROGRAM WHICH ARE ELDERLY AND
DISABLED PROGRAM. 65% OF THOSE
TRIPS ARE SUBCONTRACTED THROUGH
OUR TAXI CAB PROVIDERS AND ONE
OF THE MAIN REASONS THEY'RE
ABLE TO DO THAT THROUGH THIS
FEDERAL PROGRAMS BECAUSE- A
PRINTED. AND DRUG TESTED. IT'S
AN IMPORTANT FUNCTION FOR CITY
AS AN IMPORTANT FUNCTION FOR
RESIDENTS. IN TERMS OF SAFETY
IT'S A TNC DRIVER. LET'S SAY-
FOR ANY TNC A TEENSY DRIVER AND
DOES SOMETHING THAT ON TOWARD
TOWARD THE PASSENGER UNLESS IT
RISES TO THE LEVEL OF AN ARREST
WE'RE NOT GOING TO HEAR ABOUT
IT. IF ANYTHING LIKE THAT
HAPPENS IN THE TAXICABS SPACE
OR EVEN MY NOT EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SPACE WE HEAR ABOUT IT
FIRST AND WE MANAGE IT AND WE
HANDLE IT WHETHER IT'S A
COMPLAINT. WHETHER IT'S AN
ARREST. OUR CITIES REGULATE
THOSE ISSUES. FOR NEWER DRIVERS
ARRESTED OR SOMETHING HAPPENS
BE MAY BE DEACTIVATED IMPROPER
FORM. WE MAY WE DON'T WE DON'T
ACTUALLY KNOW IF THAT'S
HAPPENING. BUT EVEN IF THEY
ARE. THERE'S NOTHING THAT
NECESSARILY PREVENTS THEM FROM
CONTINUING TO DRIVE FOR LIFT
AND AS MANY OF YOU ALREADY
LIKELY SEE. MANY DRIVERS HAVE
AN UBER AND LIFT STICKER. SO
SOMETHING HAPPENS ON ONE
PLATFORM IT'S UNCLEAR WHAT
HAPENS TO THEM ON THE OTHER
PLATFORM. IF SOMETHING HAPPENS
WITH OUR DRIVERS IN THE TAXI
CAB SPACE. IF I HAVE A YELLOW
CAB DRIVER THAT DOES SOMETHING
ON TOUR TO A PASSENGER WE
REMOVE THEM. THEY CAN GO TO
ANOTHER CAP COMPANY ANYWHERE IN
LOS ANGELES WHY BECAUSE WE
MANAGE THEIR PERMIT. WE'RE THE
ONES WHO KNOW WHAT GOES ON WE
KNOW EVERY SINGLE DRIVER THAT
OPERATES IN OUR CITY. WE DON'T
KNOW ANYTHING THAT HAPPENS WITH
THE DRIVERS AND TEA AND SEES.
IN TERMS OF EQUITY WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT REDLINING.
WE'RE VERY LARGE CITY. POWER
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED SQUARE MILES.
BETWEEN FOUR FIVE MILLION IN
POPULATION THAT'S JUST FOR THE
CITY OUR COUNTY IS CLOSE TO
FOUR THOUSAND SQUARE MILES WITH
A POPULATION OF ABOUT TEN
MILLION PEOPLE. AND WITH THAT
IT'S IMPORTANT TO US THAT
SERVICES ON THE WEST SIDE. ARE
JUST AS GOOD AS SERVICES ON THE
EAST SIDE OR THE SOUTH RIM THE
NORTH PART OF THE CITY. WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
EQUIVALENT SERVICE THROUGHOUT
THE CITY AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE FIGHT HARD FOR OUR
TAXICABS SPACE. AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT AGAIN WE HAVE NO
CONTROL OVER AND THE TNC
SPACES. ACCESSIBILITY MYSTERON
MENTION. WHEELCHAIR
ACCESSIBILITY IS SOMETHING THAT
ALL TAXICABS WE FOCUS ON
HAPPILY WE REQUIRE PERCENTAGE
OF OUR FLEET TO BE WHEELCHAIR
ACCESSIBLE. THE SAN FRANCISCO
FLEET IN THE EXACT SAME THING.
CURRENTLY TNC FOR THE MOST
PART. ARE NOT WHEELCHAIR
ACCESSIBLE. I DON'T THINK
ANYONE THERE YOU KNOW AND I
THINK THEY MAY BE HERE TODAY
THEY CAN TALK ABOUT THAT
THEMSELVES WITH WE'LL HAVE
WE'LL CHECK SENSIBILITY IN THE
TNC SPACES. MAY MAY BE ABLE TO
CONTRACT NOW WITH OTHER.
OUTSIDE ENTITIES BUT AGAIN AS A
CITY THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO US FOR OUR
CUSTOMERS AND WE DO A OF THE
PRETTY HARD JOB TRYING TO PUT
THAT TOGETHER MAKE SURE THAT
THAT HAPPENS FOR THEM. AND THEN
FINALLY WHAT SUSTAINABILITY.
WE'RE PUSHING OUR PROGRAM TO
MOVE MORE TOWARDS AN EEVEE
FUTURE AND TWO IS MORE CLEAN
AIR FUTURE. THAT'S BECAUSE WE
KNOW EXACTLY WHAT VEHICLES ARE
IN OUR FLEETS AND AGAIN MISTER
RANKIN ALSO PROBABLY TELL YOU
ALL TAXI CAB VEHICLES IN OUR
FLEET SECOND TELL YOU WHICH
SHUTTLES WE HAVE WHICH
AMBULANCES WE HAVE THEIR MAKE
THEIR MODEL THEIR YEAR. AND AS
WE MOVE FORWARD INTO THE FUTURE
WE'RE TRYING TO MOVE THEM
TOWARDS A CLEANER AND CLEANER
AND CLEANER MODEL TO. ALLEVIATE
AND MEET ALL OF OUR GREENHOUSE
GREENHOUSE GASKELL'S. BUT ONE
MINUTE. AND SO AGAIN THESE ARE
THINGS BECAUSE WE HAVE NO DATA
NO INFORMATION ON TNC DRIVERS
OF INFORMATION I TNC VEHICLES.
OF NO CONTROL OVER THEM WE ARE
UNABLE TO USE. THAT FOR HIGHER
SERVICE TO HELP ASSIST US IN
MEETING THESE GOALS WE'RE NOT
ABLE TO USE AND HELP ASSISTANCE
WHEELCHAIR ACCESSIBLE GOALS WE
CAN USE IN TEXAS AS WITH OUR
CONGESTION GOALS- WERE ABLE TO
HELP THEM IN TERMS OF PRICING.
EVEN IN TERMS OF RACE FOR THE
DRIVERS WE CAN'T DO ANYTHING TO
HELP THEIR DRIVERS WHO MAY BE
SUFFERING FROM THEIR RATES WERE
AS TAXI CAB DRIVERS WE MANAGE
THEIR RATES AS WELL. IN LA WE
ARE CREATING A FRAMEWORK THAT
CAN ACCOMMODATE A OF A HOST OF
FOR HIGHER VEHICLE OPTIONS AND
BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF DATA AND
INFORMATION OF THE LACK OF
CONTROL OVER TEA AND SEES. WE
FRANKLY ARE UNABLE TO PLUG THEM
INTO THAT SYSTEM THAT WILL
ALLOW US TO ACTUALLY SERVE OUR
CITIZENS AND THE PEOPLE OF LOS
ANGELES MUCH ETTER- THANK YOU
AND IF YOU HAVE ANY.ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS WE'RE HERE FOR THAT
DON'T THINK YOU SO MUCH SO-
EXTRAPOLATING WHAT YOU HAD.
SEEN THE TEEN SEES. AND PUT IT
OVER TOWARD SO SHARED MOBILITY
DEVICES. SO ONE OF THE THINGS
I'VE HEARD IS. NEED TO BE A
FOCUS I KNOW THAT IT'S NOT THE-
FOCUS OF THIS HEARING WE'RE
GONNA HEARING IN EARLY TWENTY
TWENTY AND THE ISSUE OF DATA.
BY DATE IS IMPORTANT FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. I AND IF YOU WERE
TO START OVER. WOULD LOOK AT
SOME TYPE OF STANDARD FOR DATA.
WOULD THAT BE- CORRECT I DON'T
WANNA PROJECT ON TO EACH OF YOU
SO EARLY SOME FOR US THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT AND JUST SO
YOU'RE AWARE WE- BECAUSE WE'RE
SUCH A BIG STATE BECAUSE MANY
OF THESE COMPANIES START HERE
FIRST IN CALIFORNIA. MANY
OTHERS JURISDICTIONS ACTUALLY
CALL US TO LOOK TO US AND SAY
WHAT ARE YOU GUYS DOING AND- AT
THIS POINT YOU KNOW THE CITY OF
NEW YORK AND CHICAGO AND
TORONTO. IN PORTLAND SEATTLE
THEY'RE LOOKING AT OUR MISTAKES
BECAUSE THIS IS SEEN THROUGHOUT
THE INDUSTRY AS A MAJOR MISTAKE
THAT. THE CITIES IN CALIFORNIA
ARE UNABLE TO COLLECT ANY DATA
RELATED TNC TRIPS. AND THEM I
DON'T KNOW YEAH I CONCUR WITH
WHAT MR MURRAY SAID IN THAT IT
IS A REALLY IMPORTANT ASPECT TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S HAPPENING ON
OUR CITY STREETS ND AGAIN TO
UNDERSTAND ARE WE MEETING OUR
GOALS. YOU HAVE THESE VERY-
IMPORTANT STATE GOALS AND IT'S
HARD TO ASSESS IT FOR MEETING
THEM IF WE CAN'T UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S HAPPENING ON OUR
STREETS. IN ANYTHING ELSE
BESIDES DATA THAT YOU WERE SAY
OKAY WE START OVER. ESPECIALLY
AS WE LOOK AT AGAIN THAT'S WHY
WE HIT CANADA THE WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY WITH THESE TWO
FANTASTIC AUTHORS. PAS BUT
MAYBE TO SEE. WHAT WE NEED AS
DECEMBER INDUSTRY EMERGES.
ANYTHING ELSE THAT YOU WOULD
GET EXTRAPOLATE FOURTEEN SEIZE.
OVERTURN SCOOTERS NEW BIKES
THAT. YOU SEE. AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. THE FIRST. WELL SOME
OF THE OTHER THINGS THAT ARE IN
OUR INTEREST TO US THAT IF WE
WERE TO START OVER AND IN THE
TNC SPACES IF WE WERE TO START
OVER WE WOULD ABSOLUTELY LOOK
AT WE WANT TO KNOW WHO THE
DRIVERS WHERE WE WANT TO KNOW-
WHAT THEY'RE DOING FOR
ACCESSIBILITY BECAUSE AGAIN
WHEN EVERYONE STARTS THESE
THINGS THE NEW INNOVATIVE
FRAMEWORKS THEY TALK A LOT
ABOUT HOW FUN AND EXCITING IT
IS AND HOW NEW IT IS BUT
EVERYONE FORGETS ABOUT- THE
PEOPLE WHO CAN AFFORD IT
PERHAPS WITH AREAS THAT MAY NOT
GET THIS THING FIRST. OR EVEN
OUR OUR DISABLE CLIENTELE- WE
THINK ABOUT WHO'S ON THE STREET
WHO HAS TO USE OUR STREETS ARE
WHEELCHAIR USERS ARE THOSE WHO
ARE- VISION IMPAIRED THOSE WHO
ARE HEARING IMPAIRED THESE ARE
THINGS WE BE CONCERNED ABOUT
AND EVEN IN TERMS OF IF WE WERE
TO MOVE THIS TO THE MICRO
MOBILITY SPACE THE QUESTION
WOULD ALSO BE FOR US WHAT WE DO
FOR A WHEELCHAIR CUSTOMERS WHO
HAVE TO STILL USE THE SIDEWALK
AND THEY'RE STILL ON THEIR LINE
DOWN THE SIDEWALK. FOR THE
VISION IMPAIRED PERSON IS USED
TO STICK IN FEES WITH THE WHITE
CAME THAT THERE'S SOMETHING IN
COMPETING THEIR WAY YOU KNOW
HOW DO WE MANAGE REMOVAL OF
THAT YOU KNOW THOSE ARE THINGS
THAT WE AS A LOCALITY WE WANT
TO BE ABLE TO UNDERSTAND AND WE
WANT TO UNDERSTAND NUMEROUS
THOSE THINGS IN THE TNC SPACE
WE'D WANT TO STAND WITH THE
ROUTE WHAT DRIVERS AROUND. WE
WANT TO KNOW WHAT TYPE OF
VEHICLE THAT. CAME UP WE WANT
TO KNOW WHAT. RESULT AND SO
THAT WE. PLAY FOR THE SAKE OF
REGULATING. FOR THE SAKE OF
ENSURING THE SAFETY GOALS ARE
MET ENSURING THAT OUR EQUITY
GOALS ARE MET IN ASSURING THAT
I WILL CHECK SENSIBLE GOALS ARE
MET THANK YOU YEAH I WOULD
CONCUR AN AD THAT- BECAUSE THAT
IMPACTS ARE FELT MOST ACUTELY
LOCALLY THAT IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO HAVE LOCAL ABILITY
TO REGULATE MANAGE AND
ADMINISTER A PROGRAM WHAT WE
FOUND IN SAN FRANCISCO ONE WE
WERE ABLE TO REGULATE THE-
SCOOTERS FOR EXAMPLE AN AND NO
THIS IS A TOPIC OF THE NEXT
PANEL BUT- WE WENT FROM.
THOUSANDS OF COMPLAINTS AND
CONSUMER CONCERNS AND SCOOTERS
ALL OVER AND BLOCKING SIDEWALKS
AND BLOCKING THE ACCESSIBLE
PATH OF TRAVEL TO HAVING A
PERMIT PROGRAM WHERE NOW WE
REQUIRE THE SCOOTERS TO BE
LOCKED SO THEY'RE OUT OF THE
WAY OF THE ACCESSIBLE PATH OF
TRAVEL WE'VE MANAGE THE- THE
COMPLAINTS WE HAVE A STRUCTURE
PROCESS TO BE RESPONSIVE AND
WERE ALLOWED TO FORCE LOCALLY-
NOT A MOVING VIOLATION FOR
OPERATING ON THE SIDEWALK.
RELATED TO THE PERMIT
CONDITIONS AND SO THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO BE ABLE TO
REGULATE MANAGE WHAT HAPPENS ON
THE CITY STREETS CITY SIDEWALKS
SO I THINK THEY'RE A LOT OF
LESSONS LEARNED FROM THE TNC
INTO A WHILE I THINK A AS MR
MATUTE A. SAID A- HYBRID MODEL
WHERE THE STATE SET SOME BROAD
GENERAL REQUIREMENTS AND THEN
THERE'S LOCAL BILLET TO SET
ADDITIONAL- PERMIT CONDITIONS
OTHER REQUIREMENTS. OKAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND TURN OVER THE
CHAIRMAN WILL GO TO THE VICE
CHAIR. PLEASE THANK YOU FOR
THAT MISTER. WHAT INFORMATION
ARE YOU LACKING FROM THE CPUC.
AS YOU TALK ABOUT IS THE
INABILITY IN PAIRS WITH IS
KNOWN INDIVIDUAL PLAN TO SEE
THE ACTUAL REGULATES SO- ANY
DATA THAT THE TNC IS PROVIDE TO
THE CBC IS NOT MADE AVAILABLE
PUBLICLY IT'S ALL PROVIDED
UNDER SEAL SO NUMBER OF TRIPS-
GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY SIX IN TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHEELCHAIR
ACCESSIBLE SERVICES IN THE NEED
FOR THOSE SERVICES. THE CPUC
POSE THE QUESTION BACK TO THE
PARTIES- HOW MANY ACCESSIBLE
TRANSPORTATION TRIPS ARE
HAPPENING AND THERE WAS NO
ABILITY AS A PUBLIC AGENCY TO
ANSWER THAT OR UNDERSTAND THAT
THEY'RE ALSO FEES THAT THE CPC
COLLECTS FROM- TEEN SEES THEY
WERE REDUCED A COUPLE YEARS
AGO- WE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WERE
VERY CURIOUS HOW MUCH HAS BEEN
COLLECTED IN WHAT HAS IT BEEN
SPENT ON. AND WHY REDUCE WE
HAVE SOME IDEAS ON WHERE THAT
MONEY COULD BE SPENT IT COULD
BE SPENT TO SUPPORT LOCAL
ENFORCEMENT DISABILITY ACCESS
THIS BEFORE THIRTEEN SEVENTY
SIX- BUT THOSE ARE IN BUT WE
DIDN'T KNOW WE DIDN'T KNOW
WHERE HOW MUCH IS COLLECTED
WHERE IT WENT WHAT TYPE OF IN
FORCE AND HAPPENING THERE IS A
STATE LAW THAT- TEEN.
COMMERCIAL DRIVERS CAN ONLY DO
HAVE CERTAIN- ON OF CONSECUTIVE
HOURS ALSO THERE'S THAT STATE
LAW ON THE BOOKS BUT WE'RE NOT
SURE IS IT BEING ENFORCED OR.
NOT SO THOSE ARE SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS WE HAVE. JUST FOLLOW
THAT UP WITH A IT DID YOU WANT
TO ADD ON TO THAT I'M SORRY I'M
NO THAT'S WORK EXPERIENCE IN
THE EXACT SAME THING LOS
ANGELES WE ARE UNABLE TO OBTAIN
ANY DATA AND- EVEN IN TERMS OF
ENFORCEMENT WE'RE FRANKLY. I'M
SURE OF THE CDC HAS THE
RESOURCES TO ENFORCE IN THE
CITY CRITICALLY OF OUR SIZE
WHERE FOR EXAMPLE WE HAD A
POINT NINE MILLION TNC TRIPS
COME OUT OF LAX- LAST YEAR. AND
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE I DON'T KNOW
HOW LARGE THE PCS BUT I'M
CERTAIN THEIR ENFORCEMENT
CANNOT COVER. EVEN JUST AND
THAT'S JUST THE NUMBERS WE
KNOW- FROM LA X. IT WAS AND
TELL US I MEAN DRIVERS WE HAVE-
AND THAT'S JUST FOR. THAT
AIRPORT SO THOSE NUMBERS ALONE
SHOULD TELL YOU WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT LOS ANGELES APART
LOOKING AT. HUNDREDS MAYBE OF
OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DRIVERS. AND
AGAIN. WE HAVE NO INFORMATION
ON IF THAT'S ACTUALLY ACCURATE.
OR NOT WE HAVE NO INFORMATION.
THAT MIGHT BE A HEARING IN ITS
OWN. ONE OTHER QUESTION- TO
BOTH YOU AS OF- JANUARY FIRST-
AB FIVE WILL BE. PUT INTO LAW
WHICH WILL MAKE TNC OPERATORS
EMPLOYEES. AT THISPOINT- DO
YOU FEEL THAT THERE WILL BE AN
ABILITY TO WORK WITH HI DATA
COLLECTION ON AS A WHOLE AS AN
EMPLOYER VERSES INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS HAVING TO. DO YOU
FEEL WHAT HE FEELS GOING ON
THERE IS MOVING THE BALL AS FAR
AS- RESPONSIBILITY AND- OF
REPORTING. I THINK THAT'S A
GREAT QUESTION THAT'S REALLY
INTERESTING I HAVE NOT. HEARD
THOSE TWO TOPICS PAIRED LIKE
THAT AND SO I THINK THAT'S
INSIGHTFUL- FOR US TO FOLLOW UP
ON- BUT AS IT STANDS WITH THE
CPC AT THIS POINT THERE IS NO
ABILITY TO ACCESS ANY OF THAT
DATA SO I'M NOT SURE IF THE
EMPLOYMENT STATUS IS GOING TO
ALLOW SOME TYPE OF ENTREE. BUT
CERTAINLY WORTH PURSUING IN
ASKING THOSE QUESTIONS. AND I
AGREE WITH MR WITH MISS TO OUR
AND I THINK THE ISSUE WITH THAT
IS SIMPLY. FOR EXAMPLE OF NEW
YORK CITY HAS A REQUIREMENT
THAT TNC DRIVERS HAVE TO MAKE A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF MONEY IN THIS
SPACE UT I UTILIZATION. BUT
THEY'RE ABLE TO DO THAT BECAUSE
THEY HAVE ALL THE DATA THEY
KNOW WHO THE DRIVERS ARE THEY
KNOW HOW MANY DRIVERS THERE
THERE ARE AND THEY CAN SEE WHAT
THE UTILIZATION THIS SO THAT
THE- MAN THEY ARE ABLE TO
DETERMINE. HOW MUCH HAS TO BE
PUT IN TO ENSURE THAT THE
DRIVER EARNS ENOUGH MONEY TO
KEEP WORKING. FOUR GUYS OF THE
CHANGED AB FIVE IF WE DON'T
HAVE ANY OF THAT DATA. IT'S
UNKNOWN TO US WHETHER THEY'RE
GONNA BE MAKING THE IN THE
REQUISITE AMOUNT OF MONEY THEY
NEED TO SURVIVE IN LOS ANGELES
OR NOT SO. AGAIN DATA IS REALLY
THE KEY. ON THOSE ISSUES AND IF
WE DON'T HAVE THAT DATA. THEN
IT'S UNCLEAR TO US WHAT. YOU
KNOW WHAT CHANGES COULD OCCUR
WITH AB FIVE. IT HAS SOLD HIS.
HOME WHAT I'M- TAKING IN. FROM
YOUR STATEMENTS BUT SEE IF YOU
SEE THAT THEY MAY BE
OVERWHELMED. OF NOT ONLY IN
FIRE SITUATIONS BUT- IN THE
TRANSPORTATION NETWORKS ALSO IN
THAT WE MAY HAVE TO BIFURCATE
THIS AGENCIES SO IT.
RESPONSIBILITY ACTUALLY CAN BE
EFFECTIVE- TO MANAGE AND ALSO
AID LOCAL JURISDICTIONS IN
THEIR EFFORTS. WELL WE'RE
CERTAINLY HERE TO BE A PARTNER
WITH- AND FORCING AND HELPING
TO MANAGE TNC OPERATIONS. RIGHT
WE WANT TO BE A PART OF THE
ECOSYSTEM AND THEY'VE DONE A
GOOD SERVICE SO FAR I MEAN IN
TERMS OF THAT BUT IN ORDER TO
HELP US. MOVE FORWARD IN THE
FUTURE WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE SOME SAY IN WHAT GOES ON.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU. MR
VICE CHAIR WE'RE GONNA GO TO.
SENATOR BELL A CHEESY BREAD GO
TO THE VICE CHAIR I APOLOGIZE
SENATOR BAIL. AND THEN TO
ASSEMBLY WOMAN FRIEDMAN. AND
THEN ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE TO.
SPEAK PLEASE VICE CHAIR THE
FORESHORES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MR MURRAY YOU'RE HERE ON
AN- AUSPICIOUS DAY YOU I'VE-
MADE IT TO THE FRONT. PAGE OF
THE CALIFORNIA SECTION OF THE
LA TIMES. WHERE THE CITY IS
PULLED. HOOVER'S PERMIT. AND SO
IF I IF I COULD JUST READ A
PARAGRAPH FOUR I'M STILL TRYING
TO. GET MY ARMS AROUND IT SAYS
THE SUSPENSION FOLLOWS MONTHS
OF TENSION AND FAILED ATTEMPTS.
AT COMPROMISE BETWEEN UBER IN
THE CITY OVER A DATA SHARING
RULE. AND ALWAYS WHEN YOUR
PILOT PERMIT PROGRAM. COMPANIES
MUST SHARE REAL TIMEDATA ON
ALL TRIPS MADE WITHIN THE CITY.
INCLUDING THE START POINT. IN
POINT AND TRAVEL TIME. AND I'M
STILL TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHY
THAT'S SO CRITICAL SO MAYBE THE
FIRST QUESTION I HAVE IS. DO WE
REQUIRE THAT FOR TAXI DRIVERS.
THAT YELLOW CAB TO IT TO ALL
PROVIDED TO THE CITY. YES WE DO
AND ACTUALLY WHAT WE'RE GONNA
DO IN TERMS OF- SEE LOS ANGELES
IS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE THAT TO
REAL TIME DATA. BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW TECHNOLOGICALLY TAXICABS
HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO KEEP UP.
WITH THE TIMES WE KNOW THE
TECHNOLOGY EXISTS. SO THEY
PROVIDE DATA TO US MONTHLY ON
WHETHER TRIPS ARE HOW MANY
TRIPS- BUT- APPARENTLY IT'S
SOMEONE WHO'S BRING IN THAT
INFORMATION IN A FORMAT THAT'S
NOT REALLY USABLE FOR US IN.
ANYMORE AND SO AND WE'RE GONNA
BE MOVING THEM ONTO A PLATFORM
MUCH LIKE WE DO WITH OTHER
SCOOTERS IN LOS ANGELES. THAT
ALLOWS US TO SEE WHAT GOES ON
AND WHERE THE CHIPS ARE WITH
THE TAXICABS. AND WE'RE GONNA
BE MOVING THIS TO ALL OF OUR
FOR HIGHER VEHICLES ARE
SHUTTLES AS WELL AS OUR NON
EMERGENCY MEDICAL- EVENTUALLY
THROUGHOUT. THE NEXT YEAR. TO
INTEREST TO SEE WHAT'S GOING ON
WITH OUR VEHICLES AT. YOU KNOW
AT ALL TIMES THAT WE CAN
BETTER. SERVE THE PUBLIC
INTEREST CREATING ZONES- SEEING
WHERE THE CHIPS ARE AND-
PREVENTING THE RED LINING
ISSUES SO. THE TECHNOLOGY
CURRENTLY EXIST. WE'RE MOVING
THEM INTO THAT FRAMEWORK. AND
WE EXPECT EVERYONE TO BE
FOLLOWING. THAT FRAMEWORK
WITHIN THE NEXT YEAR SO. THAT'S
FOR. HELPFUL TO ME- THANK YOU
FOR THAT RESPONSE BECAUSE I'M
A- NO BETTER NO WORSE KIND OF
PERSON IF. TAXI COME TO RE
DOING IT THEN TNC IS. SHOULD BE
DOING LIKE I OKAY I APPRECIATE
THAT SO WITH THE DATA FROM THE
TAXI COMPANIES- IN BOTH CITIES
BOTH THEIR AREAS- ARE WE ARE WE
SEEING MORE PEOPLE THAN USING.
SOME FORM OF TRANSPORTATION
THAT THEY'RE COMPENSATING
SOMEONE FOR OR OR TAXIS
DECLINING ANTEON SEES.
INCREASING ABOUT THE AVERAGE IS
STILL THE SAME. WELL I THINK
THE PIE HAS GROWN I THINK THE
STUDIES SHOW THAT MORE PEOPLE
ARE USING MORE FOR HIGHER
SERVICES AND- THERE BEEN MANY
STUDIES ON THIS AND THERE'S
EVEN A LOOK AT A PUBLIC TRANSIT
AND IN MANY AREAS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY PUBLIC TRANSIT
RIDERSHIP IS DECLINING WHILE
TNC TRIPS ARE GOING UP AND
TYPICALLY OVER THE PAST. EIGHT
TEN YEARS TAXI TRIPS HAVE BEEN
DECLINING SO- BUT I THINK THERE
WAS A LOT OF WEIGHT AND DEMAND
THERE'S A LOT OF FACTORS THAT
HAVE BEEN GOING ON RELATED TO
THE VARIOUS TRIP LEVELS- IN
ANOTHER POINT ON THE DATA NOT
SURE IF THIS IS HELPFUL AS WELL
BUT- THERE ARE- AGAIN THE STATE
REQUIREMENTS AND GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSION REDUCTIONS WE HAVE OUR
CONGESTION MANAGEMENT AGENCIES
CHARGED WITH TRACKING AND- IN.
OF YOU KNOW TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THE DECLINE IN ARE
WE MEETING OUR GOALS AND-
WITHOUT ANY TNC DATA THIS IS
OUR FASTEST GROWING-
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR FRANK AND-WITHOUT ANY DATA THE- THE
CONGESTION MANAGEMENT AGENCIES
ARE NOT ABLE TO EASILY ANSWER
THOSE QESTIONS AND SO THEY'RE
GOING OUT AND HAVING A SURVEY
OR TRYING TO FIGURE OUT A WORK
AROUND. HOW CAN WE TRY TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
THE SECTOR AND YET THAT DATA IS
BEING PROVIDED TO THE CPC IT'S
JUST NOT A SHARED WITH OTHER
PUBLIC AT. EASE. SO MUCH OF THE
TOTAL ANOTHER EXAMPLE BECAUSE
IT IT IF YOU WHEN YOU JUST DROP
INTO THE SUBJECT AND YOU DON'T
HAVE A LOT OF THE BACKGROUND
YOU KNOW I DID AS MUCH READING
AS I COULD- BUT THE SO THAT'S
REAL HELPFUL BUT MR MURRAY
MAYBE YOU COULD EXPLAIN. LA
ACTS AGAIN- THE TNC IS HAD A
WHALE OF A TIME LAST NIGHT
ACCORDING TO. NEWS REPORTS AND
SO YOU'RE MOVING THEM IN A YEAR
YOU'RE PROBABLY NOT IN CONTROL
OF THE AIRPORT BUT- BUT THEY'RE
MAKING SOME MOVES THAT SEEMS TO
BE FRUSTRATING A LOT OF.
TRAVELERS SILAS SPECIALLY LAST
NIGHT DID YOU ANY ANY FIVE
COMMENTS. INTO THROUGH QUIPS
REYES FOR MAKE SURE FOLKS ON
THE SHARED MOBILITY DEVICES I
UNDERSTAND THAT WE HAVE SOME
BREAKING NEWS IN REGARDS TO-
THE CHALLENGES SO- SIMMERING AB
PROCEED WITH THAT BUT JUST. AS
WE'RE LOOKING AT IS THOSE
LESSONS LEARNED FROM TEENSY
RIGHT AND TAKE A LOOK AT THE
SHIRT MOBILITY DEVICES PLEASE.
CONTINUE. ON WITH THE ANSWER UP
TO THE VICE YEAR THANK YOU
MISTER. THANK YOU AND YOU'RE
CORRECT- THE BILL A DOT THE
AGENCY THAT I'M A PART OF WE DO
NOT HAVE CONTROL OVER LA ACTS
SO THAT MOVE WAS MADE. BY THE
AIRPORT PROPER. BUT WHAT WE YOU
HAVE WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IN TERMS
OF THE NUMBER OF TRIPS IS THAT
OBVIOUSLY TEENS TEACHERS HAVE
INCREASED EXPONENTIALLY IN THAT
AREA. AND TAXI CHIPS- DECLINED
TO A CERTAIN DEGREE- AT THE
PEAK FOR TAXI TRIPS IS ABOUT
ONE POINT SIX MILLION-
ANNUALLY. AND NOW IT'S THE
CLIENT OR POSSIBLY ONE POINT
TWO MILLION- GIVE OR TAKE SO.
WELL THE DECLINE HAS BEEN A
RELATIVELY STEEP IT'S SOMEWHAT
PLATEAU TO A CERTAIN DEGREE.
BUT TNC TRIPS- ROSE
EXPONENTIALLY SO TO KIND OF
ANSWER YOUR PREVIOUS QUESTION I
THINK WHAT KATE MENTION WAS
THAT. THERE'S A BIGGER PIECE OF
THE PIE NOW. AND THAT'S VERY
MUCH TRUE SO. YOU KNOW WHAT
WE'RE SEEING IN TERMS OF LA
ACTS AGAIN. WE IN LOS ANGELES
WE CAN MANAGER TAXICABS. SO THE
CONGESTION LA ACTS YOU KNOW
IT'S NOT MISS. FROM TAXIS
BECAUSE- WE ACTUALLY HAVE A
RULE LA. WHERE TAXICABS CAN
ONLY SERVICE THE AIRPORT ONE
OUT OF THREE FIVE DAYS ONLY 20%
OF OUR TO. CAP THE- NBA PLAYER.
AT A GIVEN TIME. THAT IS SO
IT'S NOT A SUPER COMPLICATED
SYSTEM JUST TO GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE. OF IT. LET'S SAY THE
DATE ON THE MONEY. WE'LL BE
LIKE DAVE D. SCREEN. VEHICLE
AND THEN THE LETTER AND THE
NUMBERS THREE OR SIX CAN
SERVICE THE AIRPORT TODAY ALL
THE OTHER VEHICLES CANNOT. DO
THAT TO MANAGE CONGESTION AT
THE AIRPORT TO INSERT TO ENSURE
THAT WE DON'T HAVE. THREE HOUR
WAIT FOR TAXI CAB SITTING AT
OUR AIRPORT AND JUST WAITING
THERE WE HAVE BUT WE'RE ABLE TO
DO THAT BECAUSE WE HAVE AN
INFORMATION WERE ABLE TO DO
THAT. WE DO NOT HAVE THAT
AUTHORITY OVER TNC SO WE DON'T
HAVE THE LUXURY TO BE ABLE TO
SAY. HEY IT'S INCREDIBLY
CROWDED. LET'S SEE WHAT WE CAN
DO TO. STYMIE SOME OF THAT
CONGESTION WE DON'T HAVE THAT
KIND OF AUTHORITY CURRENTLY SO-
THAT IS IT AN ISSUE FOR US
AGAIN. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER. THANKS SO MUCH WITH MY
CHILDREN GO TO CENTER BOUND IN
THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN CENTER.
ATTENDED A RECENT CONFERENCE
WERE THE TALK ABOUT MICHAEL
MOORE BILL THE AND THEY TALKED
ABOUT THE- MIKE REMOTE MOBILITY.
PRIVATE COMPANIES FORMING
PARTNERSHIPS WITH PUBLIC
TRANSIT AGENCIES OTHER OTHER
KINDS OF. A PUBLIC MOBILITY
ORGANIZATIONS AND. ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS I HAD IF THAT'S GOT
USED DO YOU THINK THAT'S GOING
TO BE A TREND IN THE FUTURE FOR
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION OR
TRANSPORTATION GENERAL AND THEN
THE SECOND QUESTION IS WHEN WE-
THEFEDERAL GOVERNMENT STATE
GOVERNMENT GIVES GRANTS AND
FUNDING TO- TRANSPORTATION. ONE
OF THE STANDARD FOR NO NONSENSE
REQUIREMENTS YOU HAVE TO
OBSERVE THE CIVIL RIGHTS LAWS
AMERICAN DISABILITY ACT. YOU
HAVE TO SHOW THAT YOUR-
AFFIRMATIVE LEE AND FORCING OUT
SO. CAN YOU TALK ABOUT- WHETHER
OR NOT YOU THINK THAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN AND IF SO. IN TERMS
OF LOOKING AHEAD TO THE FUTURE.
LIKE WE ARE WE SHOULD. HOW WILL
THE- AMERICAN DISABILITY- ACTS-
AND EQUAL ACCESS- EQUAL ACCESS
TO ME MEANS LIKE NOT REDLINING
BASED ON RACE CREED COLOR OTHER
KINDS OF FACTORS. HOW CAN WE
ENFORCE THE LAW. OF THAT WE'RE
SUPPOSED TO ENFORCE WERE FIRMLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR. CAN YOU CAN
YOU ADDRESS THAT ISSUE PLEASE.
SURE WELL IN TERMS OF THE
BUSINESS MODELS IN THE PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS I THINK. I
THINK THE JURY'S STILL OUT ON
THAT IT'S SUCH A NEW INDUSTRY
AND- AT THIS POINT I THINK
THERE'S STILL A LOT OF SETTLING
IN TO HAPPEN SO I'M NOT SURE I
SEE A CLEAR PATH FOR THAT MAYBE
MR MURRAY SEES MORE THAN I SEE
THERE BUT I THINK THAT THE-
THAT WE DON'T KNOW YET I THINK
IT'S STILL EARLY ON- IN TERMS
OF THE AMERICANS WITH
DISABILITIES. BILL IT HE'S ACT
AND EQUAL ACCESS EQUITY THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR US AND-
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT PART OF OUR
SCOOTER PERMIT PROGRAM AS IT
STANDS NOW ON OUR BIKE SHARE
PROGRAMS. THAT WE HAVE ADOPTIVE
BIKESHARE REQUIREMENTS AND WE
HAVE ADOPTED SCOOTER
REQUIREMENTS- AND SO IT'S UP TO
THE SCOOTER COMPANIES TO WORK
WITH A DISABILITY COMMUNITIES
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT WILL
LOOK LIKE AND THAT THE- PART OF
OUR KEEPING SCOOTERS IN THESE
OTHER DEVICES OFFTHE SIDEWALKS
IS TO KEEP THEM OUT OF THE
ACCESSIBLE PATH OF TRAVEL TO
MAKE SURE THAT. PEOPLE CAN GET
TO WHERE THEY NEED TO GO TO SO
THAT'S A PIECE OF IT AS WELL SO
WE HAVE STRUCTURED PARKING
GUIDELINES THAT WE WORK THROUGH
WITH OUR DISABILITY COUNCIL TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT WAS GOING TO
MEET THEIR NEEDS. MAN IF THEY
RECEIVE PUBLIC FUNDS YOU KNOW
SOME NOW. WHICH. HAPPEN YOU
KNOW. HOW DO WE MANAGE THE. HE
THE CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS OF
SOMEBODY TO HAVE EQUAL ACCESS
AND NOT BE DISCOURAGED AGAINST
BECAUSE OF THEIR DISABILITY I
MEAN THAT'S- TWENTY KIND OF A.
YOU KNOW IT'S A IT'S NOT IT'S
NOT RELATED TO OUR STATE LAWS
IS TO SURVIVE. OVER ARCHING
KIND OF REQUIREMENTS. AT ONE
POINT I US THE ONE OF THE
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK
COMPANIES AT A HEARING. WHAT
ARE NOT. THEY OBSERVED THE
DISABILITY RIGHTS ACT AND. THE
EQUAL ACCESS PROVISIONS AND
THEY SAID THEY DID. BUT I
CONSTANTLY HEARING FROM PEOPLE.
THAT THEY GET PASSED BY BY
DRIVERS THAT THERE'S VARIOUS
ELEMENTS OF KIND OF.
DISCRIMINATION AND- TO ME IT
MEANS OKAY WE SHOULD DEVELOP.
SOMEWHERE WITH DEALING WITH
THAT NOW HOW HOW WOULD YOU
SUGGEST WE DO THAT. IS THERE.
SOME WAY WE CAN DO THAT OR WHAT
WHAT ARE STEPS WE NEED TO TAKE.
WELL WITH UP TO BRING IT BACK
TO TAXIS AND THEN GO BACK TO
THE MIKE REMOTE BILLION ARE
TAXI PROGRAM WE'VE HAD TAXIS IS
PART OF OUR PARA TRANSIT
PROGRAM SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY
ONE. AND WE'VE HAD WHEELCHAIR
ACCESSIBLE TAXIS SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR SO THIS IS A LONG
STANDING COMMITMENT. OF THE MTA
AND- AND IT'S DISABILITY ACCESS
IS ONE OF OUR OVER ARCHING
GUIDING PRINCIPLES AS AN AGENCY
THAT'S A BOARD ADOPTED SET OF
PRINCIPLES ON HOW TO ENGAGE
WITH EMERGING MOBILITY
COMPANIES. AND TO BRING IT BACK
TO THE SCOOTERS THAT AGAIN PART
OF OUR PERMIT CONDITIONS
REQUIRE AN ADOPTIVE SCOOTER
PROGRAM WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE IS
STILL YET TO BE DETERMINED PART
OF THE JURY IS STILL OUT- IS
THAT THERE'S- I DON'T THINK
THERE'S AN EASY. VEHICLE TYPE
THAT WE CAN POINT TO SAY THIS
IS AN ACCESSIBLE SCOOTER BUT
THE REQUIREMENT IS FOR THE
SCOOTER COMPANIES TO WORK WITH
THE DISABILITY COMMUNITY AND
TRY TO MEET THE NEEDS OF THE
COMMUNITY WE ALSO HAVE AN
ADOPTIVE. SHARE PROGRAM IN SAN
FRANCISCO AS WELL AND WORKING
TO. MEET THE NEEDS OF THE
DISABILITY COMMUNITIES. SERVICE.
THANK YOU AND I THINK AS A
CITY. WE'RE ALWAYS OPEN TO
ENGAGEMENT AND I THINK WE SPENT
A LOT OF TIME. AND ENERGY
ENGAGING WITH OUR PRIVATE
INDUSTRY IN TERMS OF TRYING TO
MAKE THE CITY BETTER SO BUT YOU
KNOW THE JURY'S OUT IN TERMS OF
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS
BECAUSE A LOT OF THAT HAS TO DO
WITH HOW YOU'RE GOING TO AGREE.
ON WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO BE
DOING BUT I DON'T THINK THE
ANSWER IS SELF REGULATION. I
THINK- WITH THE WAY THE- TNC
SEVEN REGULATED CURRENTLY IT'S
ESSENTIALLY SELF REGULATION AND
I THINK AS WE MOVE FORWARD WITH
MICHAEL MOBILITY. IF THE ANSWER
IF THE INTEL IF THE ANSWER IS
THE TERM AND THAT WILL WILL
ALLOW THEM TO SELF REGULATE AND
JUST PROMISED US YOU'LL DO THE
RIGHT THING. I DON'T THINK THAT
THAT'S THE WAY TO GO I THINK
IT'S MUCH MORE IMPORTANT- TO
SAY THAT THERE'S A PARTNERSHIP.
BETWEEN THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
AS WELL AS A PRIVATE ENTITIES
AND FRANKLY EVEN A PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE STATE OR REGIONALLY
THERE SHOULD BE SOME LOCAL. A
JURISDICTIONAL CONTROL SO THAT
THERE WE THE INPUT AND SAY IN
WHAT HAPPENS. AS MANY OF THESE
THINGS WILL AFFECT OUR CITIES.
MOST WELCOME WE HIRE SOMEBODY
TO DO ANYTHING IN THIS BUILDING
OR ANY OTHER GOVERNMENT. THEY
HAVE TO SIGN ON THE DOTTED LINE
ABOUT. THEIR REQUIREMENTS ABOUT.
YOU KNOW CIVIL RIGHTS AND
AMERICAN DISABILITY ACT THEY
HAVE TO SIGN. THEY'RE GONNA
FOLLOW THOSE LAWS. AND I INSIST.
THAT THAT BE DONE. IT HAS TO BE
DONE YOU CAN'T IGNORE A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT OF
SOMEBODY. THE AMERICAN
DISABILITIES ACT AS A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT. IT
THERE'S NO LAW THAT I CAN
IMAGINE THE STATE WOULD PASS
THAT WOULD SUPERSEDE AMERICAN
DISABILITY ARE. I THANK THE
CHAIR FRAZIER AYE BOTH TO GO
ALONG CONCURRENT ON THE SUBJECT.
SO WE MUST BE HERE WE HAVE TO
KIND OF FIGURE OUT. A WAY WERE.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD. ON THESE
KINDS OF TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS
THAT THAT QUESTION IS ADDRESSED
IN APPROPRIATE MANNER WITH THE
INVOLVEMENT OF THE PEOPLE ALL
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT SUBJECT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH CENTER BY WITH A TO BE
ABLE TO KEEP MOVING HERE THAT
TO TURN OVER A TURN THE FLOOR
OVER TO THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN.
SOMEONE FRIEDMAN JUST VERY
QUICKLY SO- LAST YEAR I DID A
BILL IS USEFUL FOR SUMMIT I
WANT TO COMMEND BOTH OF YOU FOR
BEING HERE BUT ALSO FOR BEING
FROM CITIES BETTER TAKING THESE
QUESTIONS VERY SERIOUSLY AND
REALLY WORKING ON THE FOREFRONT
OF MAKING POLICIES AROUND TNC
IS AND MICROBIOLOGY ARE YOU
BOTH OR- YOU KNOW REPRESENTING
CITIES AND INVOLVED IN WORK
THAT IS GOING TO SET THE STAGE
FOR WHAT COMES NEXT FOR A LOT
OF OTHER CITIES AND FOR THE
STATE'S OF THANK YOU FOR.
BRINGING THAT THOUGHTFULNESS
SIDE TO THE HEARING TODAY AND
FOR SHARING YOUR EXPERIENCES
IT'S VERY HELPFUL JUST A FEW
QUICK COMMENTS- LAST YEAR I DID
A BILL- AB ELEVEN FORTY TWO
THAT WOULD HAVE GIVEN THE
CITIES OF THE RIGHT TO COLLECT
ALL THE DATA THAT YOU
DESPERATELY NEED ABOUT TEN
SEIZE AND IT DID MAKE IT TO THE
ASSEMBLY IT WAS A SHAME THAT
THE BILL ENDED UP DYING INONE
OF OUR COMMITTEES ON THE SENATE
SIDE I THINK IT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT FOR US TO
PROVIDE CITIES WITH THAT
INFORMATION AND- YOU KNOW WE
HAD A VEHICLE TO ALLOW THAT AND
IT DIDN'T GET THROUGH AND THEIR
STOCK NOW TRYING TO PLAN PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION TRYING TO. PLAN
LA ACTS AND EVERYTHING ELSE
WITHOUT HAVING THE DATA THAT
THEY NEED TO INTEGRATE THOSE
SOLUTIONS IN WITH THEIR CITY
AND TO DO THE BASIC KIND OF
REGULATION SO I COMMIT TO KEEP
WORKING TO TRY TO GET YOU THAT
INFORMATION- BUT YOU KNOW ALL
CERTAINLY NEED YOU TO HELP GET
SUPPORT TO GET THIS TO THE
LEGISLATURE BECAUSE ON THE
OTHER SIDE WE HAVE TNC USE THAT
ARE VERY NERVOUS ABOUT YOU KNOW
ALLOWING THAT INFORMATION TO BE.
PROVIDED AND I THINK THAT PEAS.
YOU SEE REALLY NEEDS ARE. TO
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT THIS IS YOU
KNOW IMPORTANT INFORMATION. BUT
NOW TO SAY IN TERMS OF YOUR WAS
INTERESTED IN HEARING YOUR
COMMENTS ABOUT CABS IN HEARING
SO MUCH DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
BENEFITS OF TRADITIONAL CABS
AND I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT. YOU KNOW THE CAP
CERTAINLY DO A LOT OF BENEFITS
AND THEY'RE EASIER FOR CITIES
TO REGULATE BUT THE REASON THAT
CABS ARE ARE NOT THE PREFERRED
MODE OF TRAVEL IS VERY OBVIOUS
TO THOSE OF US WHO HAVE TAKEN
CABS AND TAKEN. RIDE SHARES THE
LAST TIME I TOOK A CAB IN LOS
ANGELES WAS MANY YEARS AGO AND
I REMEMBER HAVING TO TRAVEL
JUST A COUPLE MILES AND TAKING
A CAB BECAUSE I YOU KNOW HAD
BAGS OR SOMETHING AND I THINK
THAT TWO MILE TRIP COST ME
ABOUT EIGHTY DOLLARS- YOU KNOW
THIS WAS BACK BEFORE- UBER AND
LIFT WERE THERE TO DO THAT
COMPETITION AND- OF BEING IN A-
THE EXPERIENCE OF BEING IN A
CAB COMPARED TO BEING IN MOST
RIDE CHER VEHICLES IS PROFOUND.
AND IN TERMS OF REDLINING I
WHEN I USED TO LIVE IN BED STUY
IN BROOKLYN BELIEVE ME THERE'S
A LOT OF REDLINING IN NEW YORK-
EVEN WITH THEIR HIGHLY
REGULATED A CAB COMPANIES
ANYWAY TO TRY TO GET A CAB FROM
MANHATTAN TO BROOKLYN- LATE AT
NIGHT KNOWS THAT IT'S ALL KINDS
OF REDLINING THAT GOES ON ITS
RACIAL AND JUST IN TERMS TO
YOU. AUGUST THIS BILL. YOU KNOW
WHAT WE HAVE DONE. BUT TO THEM
WHEN PEOPLE USE THEIR
POCKETBOOKS TO SHOW THAT THEY
NEED A METHOD OF TRANSPORTATION
THAT IS SEAT THAT THEY FEEL
SAFE THAT'S CONVENIENT AND
THAT'S AFFORDABLE FOR THEM
THAT'S WHEN WE START SEEING
YOUNG PEOPLE DO WHAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT WANTING TO DO FOR
A LONG TIME WHICH IS SAY I
DON'T NEED TO HAVE A CAR. AT
EIGHTEEN OR TWENTY ONE THAT NOW
I'M GONNA ACTUALLY TRUST USING
TNC IS PLUS PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION AND WE HAVE THIS
REALLY GOLDEN OPPORTUNITY WITH
THIS GENERATION TO HARNESS
THAT- BUT ONLY IF WE ALLOW THE
WITH. THE. ASPECTS OF THAT
TRANSPORTATION MODALITY THAT'S
SO ATTRACTIVE TO THEM TO
CONTINUE AND NOT TO TRY TO SET
UP A PARADIGM TO GO YOU KNOW TO
MOVE THAT BACK. TO GET THOSE
THINGS THAT WE HAD WITH CABS
THAT ACTUALLY WAS CAUSING THEM
TO BE OUT OF UNAFFORDABLE FOR A
LOT OF PEOPLE NOT CONVENIENT
AND CERTAINLY NOT PLEASANT- SO
YOU KNOW THAT'S JUST SOMETHING
WE HAVE TO KEEP IN MIND AND YOU
KNOW I GUESS I COULD SAY THIS
AT THE END BUT I'LL SAY IT NOW.
YOU KNOW A LOT OF THE ISSUES
THAT WE TALK ABOUT WHAT'S WITH
MICROBIOLOGY WAS SCOOTERS THAT
WE PUT ON THE BACKS OF THE
SCOOTERS THINGS LIKE SAFETY.
REALLY SHOULDN'T BE ON THEM AND
YES THEY SHOULD HAVE A SAFE A
SAFER VEHICLES POSSIBLE AND
IT'S GREAT WHEN THEY HAVE THE
THREE WHEELED VEHICLES THAT
MORE SENIORS CAN RIDE AND YOU
KNOW I THINK THEY'LL GET THERE.
BUT A LOT OF THE ISSUES THAT WE
HAVE OR ISSUES THAT HAVE TO DO
WITH OUR PLANNING ARE PLANNING
FROM A CITY LEVEL BUT AS
PRIORITIZE AUTOMOBILES OVERALL
ELSE AND ANYTHING ELSE THAT
MOVES INTO THAT SPACE IS AT
RISK. BECAUSE THOSE SCOOTERS
SCOOTERS ARE ALWAYS GOING TO BE
LIGHTER THAN A CAR THE SAME WAY
THAT. YOU KNOW WE HAVE
PEDESTRIANS KILLED EVERY SINGLE
DAY ACROSS THE STATE AND TO.
TURN OF THE HIGH. COST. IS
BEING RUN OVER BY CARS BUT WE
DON'T TALK ABOUT THAT. WHEN
STUDENTS COME WE HAVE. WE JUST
HEARD. COLLISIONS THAT ARE IN
THE SINGLE DIGITS. AND EVERYONE
TALKS ABOUT HOW DANGEROUS THEY
ARE WELL I'M SORRY I'M A LOT
MORE FREE FOR MY SIX YEAR OLD.
ABOUT HER ENCOUNTERING THE CAR
THEN ENCOUNTERING A SCOOTER SO.
WORRIED ABOUT THAT. WE HAVE
ENGINEERING ISSUES THAT WE
SHOULD DO IN TERMS OF OUR
CITIES TO MAKE OUR ROADS SAFER.
AND MAKE IT SAFER FOR PEOPLE TO
BE ABLE TO USE- BUT THE MESSAGE
OF TRANSPORTATION THAT ARE
GOING TO BE YEAH WE CAN DEAL
WITH THE PICKUPS AND MAKE THAT
GREENER AND ALL OF THAT. BUT WE
NEED TO GET PEOPLE OUT OF CARS
IN OUR CITIES. NEW BOTH KNOW
THAT BECAUSE YOU'RE FROM CITIES
THAT ARE. IMPACTED BY THAT. BUT
WE HAVE TO MAKE OUR STREETS
SAFER. AND OUR QUESTION SHOULD
BE HOW DO WE ENGINEER OUR
STREETS TO MAKE THEM SAFER FOR
MICROBIOLOGY. AND NOT HOW DO WE
MAKE MY CHROME MOBILITY. FIT
INTO THIS PARADIGM WHERE IT HAS
TO BE THEM VERSUS A CAR. OR
THEM VERSUS A PEDESTRIAN YOU
KNOW THAT'S KIND OF ON US. AS
PEOPLE WHO ENGINEER CITIES. SO
JUST WANT TO PUT THAT OUT THERE
IS WHERE I'M COMING FROM. AND
YOU KNOW CONTINUE I WOULD LOVE
TO WORK WITH YOU ON THE- DATE
IT. SORRY TO SEE THAT BILL NOT
MAKE IT TO THE LEGISLATURE BUT
I HOPE THAT WE CAN ALL. WORK ON
THAT TOGETHER. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AS THE MEMBER AND I
THINK THAT'S WHY- GRATEFUL FOR
THE- BOTH ASSEMBLY MEMBERS.
FRIEDMAN MURATSUCHI FOR THEIR
WORK. BOTH ON- FOLKS IN THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT SIDE. ON THE
DATING. SITE THAT'S WHY WE'RE
HERE TODAY FIRST OF TO-
HEARINGS WERE WALKING BE
FOCUSED. ON HOW WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER TO BE TO MOVE FORWARD.
HERE AND TWENTY TWENTY. IF IT'S
OKAY WITH COMMITTEE I TO TURN
OVER TO THE CHAIR- TO BE ABLE
TO GIVE A FINAL WORD ON THIS
PANEL THAT WORKS. MISTER MISTER
DID YOU HAVE ANY ITEMS. RUBIO
SCHEDULE ANY. SORT OF A CHAIR
AND THEN I'LL TURN OVER THE
NEXT PANEL FOR YOU MISTER- I
JUST WANTED TO ADD ON TO. WHAT
SENATOR BILL IT CAPTURED. WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT THE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT IN THE
EIGHTY EIGHT- AND I HEARD.
EIGHTY A MOVEMENT TOWARDS. ONE
HUNDRED PERCENT. OF ZERO
EMISSION EVEY. I WOULD HOPE
THAT WE- ABSOLUTELY. MAKE A
COMMITMENT FIRST AS IT'S AN
HONOR SOME COSTLY. ENDEAVOR TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE- RIGHT.
WRITING BUT I RIDER CAPACITY.
WITH DISABILITY- COMPS.
COMPONENTS BE ADDRESSED. BEFORE
WE EVEN. TRIED TO MOVE INTO THE
V. I UNDERSTAND A PARALLEL PATH
BUT IF WE'RE- TRYING TO GO
EQUALLY COURSE WE'RE JACK'S WE
SHORT CHANGING. OF THE ABILITY
TO END RIGHT CHAIR TO MAKE
SURE. THAT EVERYBODY HAS AN
ABILITY BECAUSE OF THEIR
DISABILITY TO BE ABLE TO. TO
GET SOMEWHERE- AND AGAIN I
UNDERSTAND AND I COMPLETELY
APPLIED EVERY EFFORT FOR ZERO
MISSION CAPABILITY. BUT NOT AT
THE COST OF SOMEBODY WHO HAS A
DISABILITY I WANT GOING TO JUST
MAKE SURE HAT. THAT I'M HEARD.
A AS THE CHURCH TRANSPORTATION
THAT EVERY EFFORT IS MADE. IN
THAT IN THAT WORLD BECAUSE IT
IS NOT. THEN THERE WILL BE
LEGISLATION THAT MAKES YOU STOP
AND CAPTURE UP WHAT YOU NEED TO
ON A PERCENTAGE BASIS OF YOUR
POPULATION ON SITE I WANTED TO
BE IDENTIFIED BECAUSE IT MEANS
THE WORLD TO ME AND SENATOR
BELL ON MAKING SURE THAT EVERY
INDIVIDUAL IS HIS. NEEDS ARE.
TAKING CARE OF. GREAT. THANK
YOU FOR MAKING THE TRIP HERE
BOTH THE YOUR INSIGHT WAS
VALUABLE AND- UNBELIEVABLY
HELPFUL TO THIS COMMITTEE AND-
WE WILL HOPE THAT THE CPU SEE
WILL BE A BETTER PARTNER WITH
DATA SHARING COMING FOR DINNER
WE'VE HEARING THROUGH- THIS
COMMITTEE THAT- THAT'S A
POSSIBILITY COMING FORWARD WITH
THE WILLINGNESS SO. THANK YOU
HM THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO OF THE
REGULATORY LANDSCAPE FOR SURE
MOBILITY DEVICES NOW AND INTO
THE FUTURE EXPLORING CHALLENGES
A LOCAL REGULATORY PRACTICES WE
HAVE SO LITTLE RENT RENTALS THE
GENERAL MANAGER OF LOS ANGELES
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION
FRANCIE STEPHAN ACTING TAKE
CHIEF MOBILITY OFFICER AND
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR OF PLANNING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT CITY
OF SANTA MONICA. TOM ACQUIRE A
NO RELATION TO OUR CHAIR IN
TERM DIRECTOR OF TRANSPORTATION
SERVICES COMMUNITY MUNICIPAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY A
JENNIFER DUNN ONE- WYANT A
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING
DIRECTOR CITY OF SACRAMENTO AND
KEVIN AFTER A SO SHE
TRANSPORTATION SPECIAL CITY OF
SAN JOSE DEPARTMENT OF.
TRANSPORTATION THANK YOU ONE
AND ALL FOR COMING. MAYBE YOU
DRAW STRAWS TO SEE WHO WOULD BE
FIRST BUT- LET'S JUST GO LEFT
TO RIGHT IN. AND WE'LL GO FROM
THAT. WHEN I GO TO THAT
PRESENTATION. ARE YOU DEAD.
TECHNOLOGY. AS THEY'RE WORKING
ON IT WILL JUST START AT THE
TOP OF THE COLUMN- SWEATER
RENTALS GENERAL MANAGER WOULD
YOU PLEASE GIVE US A YOU'RE A
FOCUS SURE- THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE
TODAY I'M SO LEADER RENTALS ON
THE GENERAL MANAGER FOR LOS
ANGELES DEPARTMENT
TRANSPORTATION- I'M ALSO THE
PRESIDENT OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF CITY
TRANSPORTATION OFFICIALS- AND-
THE CHAIR OF THE UP IN MOBILITY
FOUNDATION- SO I'M HERE BECAUSE
I'VE SPENT THE LAST TWENTY PLUS
YEARS OF MY CAREER WORKING ON
MAKING CITIES AND STREETS SAFER
FOR PEOPLE WHO WALK AND BIKE-
AND REALLY NO MATTER HOW THEY
GET AROUND. AND BUT THAT HAS
REMAINED A STUBBORN CHALLENGE-
PARTICULARLY THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES OVER HALF OF THE TRIPS
THAT HAPPEN IN THE CITY ON THE
SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED MILES OF
STREETS THAT WE MANAGE AND
OPERATE ARE UNDER THREE MILES
BUT 71% OF THEM ARE PEOPLE
DRIVING THEMSELVES ALONE IN
THEIR CARS AND SO YOU KNOW WE
MAKE A LOT OF INVESTMENTS IN
GIVING PEOPLE CHOICES AND IN
TRYING TO CREATE. A DIFFERENT
KIND OF CITY- BUT WHEN SCOOTER
SHOWED UP ON OUR STREETS ALMOST
OVERNIGHT. FOR THE SHORT TRIPS
AND SO WE TOOK IT UNDER IN OUR
INTEREST TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE COMPANIES COULD SUCCEED
BECAUSE IN THE VERY VERY BEST
VERSION OF THE PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE ROLES- CITIES ARE
MANAGING STREETS AND PRIVATE
COMPANIES ARE BRINGING NEW
OPTIONS AND ARE INNOVATING AND
OUR ITERATING AND ARE
SUCCEEDING SO WE HAD A SERIES
OF PUBLIC HEARINGS- WE HAD
COMMITTEE THAT COMMUNITY
MEETINGS TO COME UP WITH A SET
OF COMMON SENSE REGULATIONS- TO
SORT OF SET THE STAGE ON THE
POSITIVE SIDE WE NOW HAVE THE
LARGEST SCOOTER PROGRAM IN THE
COUNTRY IF NOT THE WORLD WE
HAVE THIRTY EIGHT THOUSAND
SCOOTERS- ON THE STREET OF LOS
ANGELES WE ARE ON TRACK. TO
HAVE NINETEEN MILLION TRIPS
HAPPENED BY SCOOTERS AND BIKES
IN A SINGLE YEAR AND THE
MAJORITY OF THOSE TRIPS ARE
EXACTLY THE ONES THAT WE WERE
TRYING TO GIVE PEOPLE CHOICES
THAT WORK FOR THEIR BETWEEN
HALF A MILE AND TWO MILES OR
TALKING ABOUT NEIGHBORHOOD
TRIPS WERE TALKING ABOUT TRIPS
TO GO TO HAVE LUNCH WITH YOUR
FRIEND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
TRIPS TO GET TO YOUR HOUSE FROM
THE TRANSIT STATION- ON THE NOT
SO GREAT SIDE WE WERE SEEING
THAT COMPANIES WERE AKING A
REALLY LONG TIME TO RESPOND TO
COMMUNITY COMPLAINTS. SOMETIMES
UPWARDS OF TWENTY HOURS TO COME
AND COLLECT THEIR SCOOTERS WHEN
THEY ENDED UP WHERE THEY
WEREN'T SUPPOSED TO BE WHETHER
IT WAS AN ENVIRONMENTALLY
SENSITIVE AREA LIKE THE VENICE
CANALS OR REALLY CROWDED
SIDEWALKS- ON THE WEST SIDE OF
LOS ANGELES WE WERE ALSO SEEING
THAT THESE COMPANIES WERE NOT
SERVING THE CITY EQUITABLY SO
THEY WERE TARGETING A LOT OF
THE HIGHER INCOME DENSER
NEIGHBORHOODS IN THE CITY WHERE
PEOPLE ALREADY HAVE A LOT OF
CHOICES ON HOW TO GET AROUND
AND THEY WERE NOT GOING TO LOW
INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS IN THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY IN BOYLE
HEIGHTS IN WHAT'S PLACES WHERE
PEOPLE DESPERATELY NEED. SERVE
ACCESS TO TRANSPORTATION TO
EXPAND THEIR ACCESS TO
OPPORTUNITY- AND WE WERE JUST
SORT OF SEEING THAT- THEY WERE
ENDING UP OVER DEPLOYING IN
PLACES WHERE THEY SHOULDN'T SO
FOR EXAMPLE IN A ONE SQUARE
MILE AREA IN VENICE THERE WERE
OVER TWO THOUSAND SCOOTERS AND
BIKES. DEPLOYED IN THE SAME
SORT OF ONE SQUARE MILE AREA.
SO BECAUSE WE WERE ABLE TO SET
REGULATIONS AND GET INFORMATION
ABOUT WHERE THE COMPANIES WERE
DEPLOYING WE WERE ABLE TO PUT
WHAT'S CALLED A GEO FENCE
AROUND THAT NEIGHBORHOOD.
MEASURE EXACTLY HOW MUCH SPACE
THERE WAS ON THE SIDEWALK TO
SAFELY STORE THE VEHICLES. AND
THEN GIVE EACH COMPANY AND A
LOT OF BUDGET FOR THE NUMBER OF
SCOOTERS AND BIKES THAT THEY
COULD HAVE IN THAT ARENA. AND
THEN ON A DAY TO DAY BASIS WE
WERE ABLE TO SEE WHO WAS
OBEYING THE RULES. AND WHO WAS
NOT AND IF SOMEBODY WASN'T
OBEYING THE RULES WE WERE ABLE
TO HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE. AND
IN SO DOING WE WERE ABLE TO
BUILD PUBLIC TRUST AND
CONFIDENCE. THAT THESE KINDS OF
NEW IDEAS AND NEW CHOICES COULD
COME INTO THE CITY IN A WAY.
THAT THE CITY CAN HANDLE. SO
THE WAY WE DO THAT IS WE
COLLECT AS LITTLE INFORMATION
AS POSSIBLE WE ONLY GET ABOUT
SIX PIECES OF DATA FROM THESE
COMPANIES. THE COMPANIES
THEMSELVES COLLECT OVER TWO
DOZEN PIECES OF DATA- ABOUT THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE USING THEIR
SYSTEMS AND ABOUT WHERE THEY'RE
GOING AND WHEN AND WHY- WE HAVE
PRIVACY PRINCIPLES THAT WE PUT
FORWARD FOR PUBLIC COMMENT-
THAT REALLY. PUT US IN A VERY
STERN BOX ON MAKING SURE THAT
WE ARE PROTECTING PEOPLE'S
INFORMATION. THAT WE ARE NEVER
MONETIZING ITAND THAT WE'RE
STORING IT FOR A SHORTER PERIOD
AS POSSIBLE- AND WE'RE DOING IT
TRANSPARENTLY ARE OPEN PLATFORM.
OPERATION WITH MANY OF THE
COMPANIES THAT OPERATE IN LOS
ANGELES. SO WHEN WE THINK ABOUT
WHAT WE WOULD LOVE TO SEE IN
TERMS OF STATEWIDE REGULATION.
THERE IS A COMPLETE AND TOTAL
VACUUM WHEN IT COMES TO
REGULATING THE VEHICLES
THEMSELVES. AND WHAT WE SEE IS
COMPANIES DOING A LOT OF
EXPERIMENTATION WITH NEW KINDS
OF VEHICLES. THAT WE'VE NEVER
SEEN BEFORE. AND THEN CITIES
SORT OF AT A LOSS ABOUT HOW TO
REGULATE THEM OR WHAT
CATEGORIES THEY FALL INTO. THE
SECOND ARENA THAT WE THINK IS
REALLY. IMPORTANT AND VALUABLE
FOR THE STATE TO REGULATE IS
AROUND INSURANCE REQUIREMENTS-
WE DO THINK THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT THE STATE HAS
TRADITIONALLY DONE AND DONE A
GOOD JOB OF- AND THAT WOULD BE
GREAT FOR THAT FOR THEM TO
CONTINUE TO DO. SO WITH THAT
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
AND I'LL TURN IT OVER TO- MAYBE
I'LL WERE STILL. ARE WE STILL
HOW WE'RE STILL SPENDING TIME
GOT IT I'LL TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE TOM WHERE. A GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS TOM
ACQUIRE AN INTERPRETER OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO MUNICIPAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY AND IT'S
GREAT TO BE HERE TODAY TO SHARE
SOME OF SAN FRANCISCO'S
EXPERIENCE. WITH ROLLING OUT A
VARIETY OF SURE MOBILITY
OPTIONS ESPECIALLY THE
SCOOTERS. I'D SERVICES SCHOOL
AS MY COLLEAGUE HE TOWARDS THAT
WE SHARE MANY THE STATE'S
AMBITIOUS GOALS AROUND VIçT
T. REDUCTION GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION. AT A SAFETY AND AN
EQUITABLE DISTRIBUTION OF
TRANSPORTATION OPPORTUNITIES.
IT'S BEEN GREAT TO BE ABLE TO
LET THOSE PRINCIPLES PLAY OUT
IN A REGULATION OF SHARED
MOBILITY- WE'VE ALSO- IN AN
EFFORT TO SIGNAL TO PRIVATE
INDUSTRY WHICH IS CONSTANTLY
INNOVATING ON THE STREETS OF
SAN FRANCISCO- WHAT OUR GOALS
ARE FOR THE SYSTEM. WE
PUBLISHED A SERIES OF UP
GUIDING PRINCIPLES FOR THE
ROLLOUT OF SHARED MOBILITY AND
IT COVERS MANY OF THE SAME
KINDS OF POLICY PRINCIPLES THAT
ARE OF INTEREST TO THE STATE.
LIKE CONGESTION REDUCTION
SAFETY AND EQUITY. I WOULD WITH
A- AN INTERESTING TRACK RECORD
OF- THAT SENIOR DIVISION ON OUR
STREETS- AND I THINK WE'VE-
BEEN ABLE TO. LEARN THE LESSONS
THAT WE THAT WE DISCUSSED THE
PREVIOUS TITLES IN THE TNC EASE
AT TRY TO APPLY. A LITTLE MORE
ROBUST REGULATORY APPROACH-
THAT IS- THAT THAT IS POLICY
FORWARD- AND THE RESULT OF THAT
HAS BEEN A WIDE VARIETY OF
CHOICES THAT SAN FRANCISCANS
HAVE TO USE YOUR MOBILITY. WE
HAVE FORTY FIVE HUNDRED DOCKED
SHARED BIKES WE HAVE FIVE
HUNDRED DOCTOR USES BIKES WE
HAVE CURRENTLY TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED E. SCOOTERS. AS WELL AS
PROGRAMS FOR A STREETCAR SHARE-
ST SHARED ELECTRIC MOPEDS AND
PRIVATE COMMUTER SHUTTLE BUSES
SO WE HAVE A LOT OF PRIVATE
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS SERVICES
GO- IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN WHEN
THIS WHEN THREE SCOOTER COMPANY
SHOWED UP IN SAN FRANCISCO. AND
WITH NOTED NOTIFICATION OF
PERMISSION FROM THE CITY
DROPPED OVER TWO THOUSAND
SCOOTERS ARE SIDEWALKS. WE HAD
A WILD WEST CONDITIONS
SOMETHING THAT. WASN'T
ACCEPTABLE TO OUR STAKEHOLDERS
OR TWO WERE TO US THAT THE MTA.
HI WE MOVE QUICKLY. TO
ESTABLISH REGULATORY PROGRAM
THAT. THAT WAS MADE TO ADDRESS
THE SPECIFIC PROBLEMS THAT
SCOOTERS WILL BRING TO SAN
FRANCISCO BUT ALSO AND HARNESS
THE BENEFITS THAT THEY COULD
BRING BEES WE KNOW AS SO MANY
SPEAKERS OF SAID TODAY. THAT
OUR CITIES ARE ARE DROUGHT
WE'RE DROWNING IN TRAFFIC
CONGESTION WE HAVE TO FIND
ALTERNATIVES TO THE CAR. WITH
NO SCOOTERS TO PLAY THAT ROLE
IF THE REGULATED PROPERLY AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL. AND THE
SPECIFIC ISSUES THAT WE NEEDED
TO USE REGULATIONS TO MANAGE
WERE. RIDING ON THE SIDEWALKS
AND PARKING ILLEGALLY
ESPECIALLY IN WAYS THAT BLOCK
CROSSWALK SIDEWALKS AND CURB
RAMPS. AND WE'RE WE'RE PLEASED
TO SAY THAT WE WENT FROM A
SITUATION IN TWENTY EIGHT IN
THE SPRING OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
WE HAD NO REGULATIONS WERE
GETTING AS MANY AS TWO THOUSAND
THREE ONE ONE COMPLAINTS A
MONTH. AND IN TOWN AS MANY AS
FIVE HUNDRED SCOOTERS PROMOTE
FROM OUR OUR SIDEWALKS- TO US A
SYSTEM THAT IS MUCH MORE
ACCEPTABLE TO OUR RESIDENTS.
AND STARTING WILL START TO SEE
SOME OF THOSE REALLY POSITIVE
BENEFITS FROM HAVING. SCOOTERS
AS PART OF OUR TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM. SO SOME OF THE KEY
CONCLUSIONS THAT THAT WE'VE
COME TO INSPECT KEY
OBSERVATIONS THAT I THINK
APPLICABLE- STATEWIDE OR-
PERSONAL IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT LOCAL JURISDICTIONS HAVE
THE ABILITY. TO ADDRESS THEIR
OWN UNIQUE CHALLENGES SO SAN
FRANCISCO WE HAVE VERY NARROW
SIDEWALKS WE HAVE HEAVY Là
HIGH LEVELS OF PEDESTRIAN
TRAFFIC WE HAVE A LOT OF TRUCK
TRAFFIC CONGESTION. THOSE ARE
ISSUES THAT ARE UNIQUE TO SAN
FRANCISCO AND A STATEWIDE
pPOLICY WOULD NOT HELP US
ADDRESS THOSE. THOSE ISSUES ARE
FOR CISCO. SECONDLY WE'VE SEEN
REGULATION DRIVING SOME
POSITIVE TO TECHNOLOGICAL
CHANGE ONE OF THE OUTCOMES OF
OUR REGULATIONS IN SAN
FRANCISCO WITH IT EVERY TOUR
OPERATOR IS NOW DEPLOYING A
LOCK TO MECHANISM. SO YOU CAN
USE A SCOOTER SCARE SHARES
COULD READ SAN FRANCISCO UNLESS
YOU LOCK IT UP TO A BIKE RACK
OR SOME OTHER SORT OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AT THE END OF
YOUR TRIP. AND THAT IS DONE
WONDERS FOR REDUCING ATTIC
CONGESTION OUR SIDEWALKS AND
THAT INNOVATION WOULD OUT OF
HAPPENED IT NOT BEEN FOR A
REGULATORY APPROACH. TIED. TO
OUR LOCAL OUR OUR LOCAL
TRANSPORTATION ISSUES. SO THAT
WE'RE DEALING WITH IT EVOLVING
INDUSTRY. SO WHEN WE- FIRST PUT
OUT A CALL FOR. APPLICATIONS
FOR WAS THE TIME A PERMIT FOR
UPPER THEIR PILOT PROGRAM IN
TWENTY. TWENTY EIGHTEEN WHICH
TWELVE APPLICANTS. MANY OF THE
APPLICANTS ARE ALREADY BEEN IN
BUSINESS THROUGH MERGERS
ACQUISITIONS AND- ADDRESS THE
NATIONAL TURN OF TECH
COMPANIES- WE KNOW THAT- THE-
PLAYERS IN THE FIELD ARE COSTLY
CHANGING. WE KNOW SOME OF THE
EARLY PARTICIPANTS HAD A HARD
TIME TO PULLING THEIR SCOOTERS
EQUITABLY ACROSS THE CITY. WE
KNOW THAT OUR TIME EVEN
MAINTAINING THE FLEET SIZE THEY
PROMISE EMPHASIS IS THEY WOULD
DEPLOY IS ONE WHICH YOU KNOW
YOU KNOW THE MINUTE. OKAY JUST
ABOUT DONE THANKS. AND THAT'S
WHY- DIED DUE TO SHERRY SUPPORT
AS WELL AS THE INDUSTRY EVOLVES
WE NEED TO HAVE SOME
TRANSPARENCY TO THE PUBLIC
THAT. WE ARE. KEEPING TRACK OF
THE DISTRIBUTION ISSUES AND
KEEPING TRACK. OF THE OVERALL
FLEET SIZE. AND FINALLY I WOULD
I WOULD ABSOLUTELY HOLE OR THE
ACT- ECHO ITS LEADERS SAID-
THERE'S A CLEAR ROLE FOR THE
STATE. AND HELPING REGULATE
SAFETY OF THE PRODUCT THAT'S ON
THE STREET. AND HELPING SET THE
MINIMUM. I INSURANCE
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE THAT ARE-
RECORDABLE THESE PROVIDERS
EVERYTHING'S THERE MUST BETTER
DONE AT THE STATE LEVEL AND AT
THE CITY LEVEL. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE
EXPERIENCE THANK YOU FRIENDS HE
WILL GO AHEAD AND GO WITH YOU
AND- AND WAS GET BACK IN LINE.
THREE TWENTY THANK YOU THANK
YOU A PRETTY STEP IN CITY SANTA
MONICA CHIEF ABILITY OFFICER- I
WON'T REPEAT THE- GREAT
COMMENTS FROM. MY COLLEAGUES- I
AGREE WITH EVERYTHING THAT
THEY'VE SAID TO DATE- SO FAR
BUT ABOUT OF THE PRIMARY ISSUES
THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH. IN
SANTA MONICA I WILL I WOULD
THINK I'D LIKE TO UNDERSCORE-
THE THINGS THAT ARE REALLY
LOCAL RULES THAT THAT THE
COMMUNITY AND CONSERVANCY
TURNED TO US TO ADDRESS AND
THAT IS PRIMARILY DATED A
PUBLIC RIGHT AWAY MANAGEMENT-
IN ADDITION TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN SERVICE TO THE POINT
THAT WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO
BUILD OUR STREETS FOR SAFETY.
WE ALSO HAVE AN UP WE ARE THE
COMMUNITY EARNS TO US TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE MAINTAINING
SAFETY IN ORDER IN THE PUBLIC
RIGHT OF WAY. AND THE SCOOTERS
HAVE PROVIDED- WONDERFUL
MOBILITY OPTION- IN SANTA
MONICA OR IS WRAPPING UP. A
PILOT PROGRAM IN. OVER THIRTEEN
MONTHS WE'VE HAD TWO POINT SIX
MILLION TRIPS. A. ON THE FOR
OPERATORS. IN THE CITY THAT'S
INCREDIBLE- IT'S REDUCE A LOT
OF A COLD STARTS EMISSIONS AND
DEALT WITH SOME REAL.
FUNDAMENTAL ISSUES WE HAVE WITH
PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO GET AROUND
TOWN. HOWEVER WE ALSO HAVE
THOUSANDS OF INCIDENTS OF A
SIDEWALK BLOCKAGES AND IT IS
FUNDAMENTALLY POSSIBLE FOR A
CITY EVEN AS SMALL AS HOURS OF
EIGHT SQUARE MILES. TO BE ON
EVERY STREET CORNER AT ALL
TIMES MANAGING THREE THOUSAND
VEHICLES THAT MOVE ALL THE
TIME. IT'S JUST NOT REALISTIC
FOR US TO BE OUT THERE LOOKING
FOR THEM COUNTING THEM FINDING
THESE PROBLEMS AND FOR US TO
MAINTAIN ACCESS FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. WE NEED
TECHNOLOGY TOOLS AND WE NEED A
TRUE PARTNERSHIP WITH THE WITH
THE COMPANIES. TO HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE TO DO THEIR PART.
THESE DEVICES ARE NOT CARS SO
THEY ARE NOT AS VALUABLE
THEY'RE MORE LIKELY TO BE LEFT.
THROWN DESTROYED. VANDALIZED
AND SO WE NEED. UP TRUE
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND THE COMPANIES
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE- THAT
THEY'RE DOING THEIR PART TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEIR ASSETS ARE
BEING MAINTAINED. AND ALSO
DEALT WITH IN THE PUBLIC RIGHT
AWAY SO I WANT TO JUST
UNDERSCORE THAT IS A IS A
REALLY FUNDAMENTAL TO THIS-
ROLE THAT WE ALL. THAT WE ALL
PLAY- I ALSO WANT TO. SAY THAT
YOU KNOW IS THE CITY WE CONVENE
FOURTEEN LEADING CITIES FROM
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. LAST MONTH
TO SURVEY BEST PRACTICES. AS
WE'RE EMBARKING ON OUR NEXT
PILOT PROGRAM AND IT'S QUITE
TRUE THAT THERE ARE SOME BEST
PRACTICES BUT THERE'S NO
DOMINANT MODEL AT THIS POINT.
AND GIVEN THAT THE INDUSTRY IS
NOT YET. DEMONSTRATING A-
FINANCIAL SUSTAINABILITY. THEY
NEED TO MAKE CHANGES TO MEET
THEIR BOTTOM LINE JUST LIKE
CITIES HAVE TO MAKE CHANGES TO
MEET OUR MINIMUM SAFETY
REQUIREMENTS SO WE EXPECT THAT
THAT COME. WILL NEED TO CHANGE
AND THAT'S OKAY- NOBODY'S LOOK
MUCH BEYOND EIGHT. TO TWENTY
FOUR MONTHS AT THIS POINT FROM
A REGULATORY STANDPOINT BECAUSE
WE'VE NO. THIS WILL CHANGE
THAT'S WHY PEOPLE ARE DOING
SECOND THIRD PILOT PROGRAM THIS
IS. GOOD YOU'RE SICK TO BE ARE
WE BUT RATHER MORE STE. BUT
THAT'S THE NET THAT'S TRUE THE
STE I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT MAILING THINGS
DOWN TOO SOON WOULD ACTUALLY
TAKE A WAVE FOR THE ABILITY FOR
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO HAVE
THAT FLEXIBILITY AND PROBLEM
SOLVE. SO WITHOUT REPEATING
ANYTHING OTHERS IS SET ON
CLOSER LOOK FOR TO A
CONVERSATION QUESTIONS. THAT
WILL. MOVE ON TO A JENNIFER
DUNN POINT. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JENNIFER
DOMINO I AND I AM THE
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING MANAGER
FOR THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO WE
ARE HONORED AND EXCITED TO BE
AT THE TABLE AND MEETING BEFORE
YOU TODAY- WE ADOPTED A
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK ABOUT A IN
APRIL OF THIS YEAR- AND HAVE
SINCE THEN BROUGHT IN FOR
COMPANIES OPERATE IN OUR CITY-
WE HAD ABOUT SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND TRIPS IN THAT TIME
WERE IN ABOUT A YEAR PROCESS
BECAUSE JOHN WAS HE ABOUT HERE
ABOUT A YEAR BEFORE HAND- WE
DEVELOPED OUR REGULATIONS ARE
ON BEST PRACTICES FOR THAT WAS
HAPPENING IN CALIFORNIA AND
ACROSS THE US. AND ALSO LESSONS
LEARNED BECAUSE WE WERE A
LITTLE BIT LATER THAN OTHER
CITIES TO SEE- MICRO ABILITY
WHETHER IT BE- BIKES SCOOTERS
OR- WE'RE GONNA MOPEDS SOON AND
WHATEVER ELSE THE FUTURE MAY
BRING. LET'S SEE IF I CAN GET
THIS TO WORK GREAT- SO WE
DEVELOPED A REGULATORY
FRAMEWORK- DOING A LOT OF LOCAL
INPUT SO IS REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT TO US THAT NOT ONLY
DO WE RELY ON BEST PRACTICES
AND LESSONS LEARNED. BUT THAT
WE HEARD FROM OUR COMMUNITIES
WE HAVE A LOT OF COMMUNITIES
OBVIOUSLY WE LISTEN TO YOU ARE
WALKING BIKING COMMUNITIES. AND
WE ALSO WORKS THE BUSINESS
GROUPS HER BEEN INCREDIBLE
CHAMPIONS FOR A COMPLETE
STREETS IN VISITOR TRAFFIC
SAFETY WORK- AND THEIR INPUT
RANGE FROM A WE LOVE THEM BRING
THEM TO WITH. APPREHENSION AND
A LITTLE BIT OF ANXIETY- WE
ALSO WORKED WITH A DISABILITIES
ADVISORY COMMISSION WHO HAD AND
CONTINUE TO HAVE. ISSUES AND
CHALLENGES WERE BOUGHT PASS A
TRAVEL. AND THEN WE WERE THERE
NEIGHBORHOODS SO YOU ARE
RELATIVELY LOCAL YOU SPENT A
LOT OF TIME IN OUR FAIR CITY.
YOU'RE PROBABLY VERY FAMILIAR
WITH OUR GREAT AND- WHERE WE
HAVE A LOT F DIFFERENT TYPES
OF NEIGHBORHOODS BUT YOU GO
FURTHER OUT. WE HAVE OUR
STREETCAR SUBURBS THAN A MORE
SUBURBAN. NEIGHBORHOODS THE ALL
HAVE VERY DIFFERENT INTERESTS
AND WANTED US TO ADDRESS EACH
OTHER NEIGHBORHOODS DIFFERENTLY.
SO CHALLENGES- I'M SURE THAT
YOU'RE WHERE THE CHALLENGES
HERE IN SACRAMENTO AS WELL AS
YOUR HOME CITIES IF YOU HAVE
THESE DEVICES THERE- BUT WELL
YOU PROBABLY DON'T KNOW IS THE
STRAIN THAT HAS HAD ON STAFF
RESOURCES. WE ARE A SMALL CITY
OUR HOME IT'S A CITY WITH A
SMALL BUDGET. OUT AND WE'RE
STILL FUNDED DEPARTMENTS AND SO
THIS IS BEEN AN INCREDIBLE
STRAIN ON STAFF RESOURCES MY
TEAM IT NORMALLY DOES
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING. IS NOW
DEALING WITH A LOT OF ISSUES
THAT COME THROUGH DEALING WITH.
OVER SIXTEEN HUNDRED CALLS
MAYBE NOT AS MANY AS ARE PURE
CITIES HEREWE ARE BUT SMALLER.
BUT SIXTEEN HUNDRED CALLS. ON
APPROXIMATELY FIVE HUNDRED HAVE
TO DEAL WITH BLOCKED ASSESSABLE
PASSIVE TRAVEL. AND THAT'S
SIGNIFICANT WE TAKE EIGHTY
EIGHT SS ABILITY VERY
SERIOUSLY. AND BLOCK HAS A
TRAVEL OR SIGNIFICANT ISSUE FOR
US- WE REQUIRE THAT THE SHARED
RIDE IT WILL E PARTY CALL
INSURED VITALS- WHETHER IT'S
BIKES SCOOTERS WHATEVER IT MAY
BE. GLOBAL TERM BE PARKED. AT A
BIKE RACK OR CITY TO CITY DOES
NEED TO DROP SOME. LET'S NOT
HAPPENING OBVIOUSLY- IT'S BEEN
IT'S BEEN A CHALLENGE FOR US
WE'VE DONE A LOT OF OUT REACH.
OUT THROUGH- FUN VIDEOS THAT
YOU MIGHT SEE OF ME AND OUT
TAKES TO WORKING WITH OUR
POLICE DEPARTMENT. AND
PARTNERING WITH C. H. P.
PARTICULAR ON THE CAPITAL-
WE'VE DONE A LOT OF WORK OUR
FREE URBAN BIKING SKATING
CLASSES WE HAVEN'T GOT THE
RESULTS THAT WE REALLY WANT TO
SEE. SO HOW DO WE DEVELOP OUR
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK ONE THING
I THINK IS REALLY KEY IS THAT
WE WANT OUR FEES TO COVER STAFF
TIME TO DEAL WITH ISSUES THAT
ARE. ARISING WE DON'T WANT TO
BE HAVE TO TAKE AWAY. FROM OUR
WORK ON COMPLETE STREETS FROM
OUR TRAFFIC SAFETY WORK. IS
REALLY SHOULD THE IMPACT TO THE
CITY SHOULD BE COST RECOVERY
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT FOR US.
WE CREATED A CITATION FOR
WALKING PAST A TRAVEL JUST LIKE
IF YOU HAVE A RIGHT RENTAL CAR
WITH THE BUDGET OR ENTERPRISE.
YOU GET A CITATION TO THE
COMPANY WITH A COMPANY CHOOSES
TO DO WITH IT IS UP TO THEM-
WE'VE HAD SOME CHALLENGES FOR
THEIR SOFTWARE BUT THIS MONTH
WILL BE ISSUING CITATIONS TO.
COMPANIES WHOSE DEVICES ARE
WALKING THE SIDEWALKS.
COMPANIES CAN I CHOOSE TO PASS
IT ON TO THE USER IF THEY WANT.
BUT WE DON'T KNOW WHO THAT USER
IT AS- WE REQUIRE AT LITTLE
DISTRIBUTION AND ACCESS IS
REALLY KEY AGAIN I THINK IT'S
ALREADY BEEN SAID- WELL THIS S
NOT A CITY PROGRAM WE TREAT
THIS LIKE. A COFFEE SHOP WE
DON'T REGULATE HOW MANY COFFEE
SHOPS. CAN OPERATE IN THE CITY
OR HOW MANY COMPANIES CAN A
COFFEE SHOP COMPANIES CAN
OPERATE IN THE CITY. WE DO
THINK WE HAVE A MORAL
OBLIGATION TO ENSURE THESE
DEVICES WHICH ALL ASPECTS OF
OUR CITY. THE 20% OF THEIR
DEVICES MUST THOSE WHO ARE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. WE
WERE FEE STRUCTURE THE PIECE
FOR THE PARKING SO WE REQUIRE
THAT THEY BE A BIKE RACKS IT IS
NAY DROP ZONES WE COLLECT A
SMALL FEE OF TEN CENTS PER
TRIP. TO PAY FOR THE PARKING
SPACES- AND LASTLY. WE'RE USING
THE DATA WERE COLLECTED A GOOD
AMOUNT OF DATA. AND I GET THAT-
TO DO MAKE DATA DRIVEN
DECISIONS. WE WANT TO KNOW
WHERE THE- TRIPS ARE ENDING. SO
THAT WE CAN PUT IN BIKE
PARKING. WE WORK CLOSELY WITH
OUR MPO SAY KAGU ROLLED. OUT
OUR PICTURE PROGRAM LAST YEAR.
AND ON THE BIKE PARKING MAYBE
WASN'T PUT IN ALWAYS THE BEST
PLACES THEY WERE HAVING SOME
UNDER UTILIZE- BIKE PARKING.
BUT NOW WE'RE MAKING BETTER
DECISIONS USING THE DATA THAT
WE COLLECT THROUGH THE SEVENTY
S. PROCESS TO PUT IN THE
PARKING THAT IS NEEDED. AND
IT'S NOT ROCKET SCIENCE IS
MAGICAL YOU PUT IN THE RACKS
AND- THE DEVICES ALONG THE
BLOCK ALL GRAVITATE TO THAT
PARKING IT'S BEEN INCREDIBLE-
PROCESS THAT WE HAD- SO THIS IS
A DE OVERVIEW OF WHAT WE'VE
BEEN DOING IN THE DATA WERE
COLLECTING I NEVER GOING TO
HAVE ANOTHER. HEARING ON THE
DATA SO WE CAN GO INTO THAT A
LITTLE BIT MORE- SERVER THE
CITY SACRAMENTO WHEN I THOUGHT
EVERYBODY ELSE'S ALREADY SAID-
BUT THIS IS REALLY INVOLVING
FEELS AND WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
BE RESPONSIVE AND QUICK THIS IS
ACTUALLY THE SECOND SET OF
ITERATIONS OF REGULATORY.
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK THAT WE'VE
HAD. WE CAN MOVE QUICKLY THE
CITY TO ADDRESS ANY ISSUES THAT
HAVE. COME UP. WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THERE'S NO FINANCIAL
IMPACT TO THE CITY. WHERE BY
TAKING TWO PENNIES A TRYING TO
MAKE IT A LOT OF WHAT WE DO
HERE. AND SO WE WANT TO AVOID
COST TO THE WORK THAT WE DO-
HEY WE WANT ACCESS TO DATA I
THINK IT'S BEEN PRETTY CLEAR SO
THAT WE CAN MAKE DATABASES
ASIAN SO WE WANT TO RESPOND TO
OUR MANY COMMUNITIES- WE WERE-
OR DIVERSITY AND WE- ARE
CONSTANTLY GROWING WERE
INCREASING INTENSITY- WE ARE I
ONE OF THE MORE AFFORDABLE
CITIES AND CALIFORNIA AND SO
WE'RE SEEING THE INFLUX OF
FOLKS COMING IN- AND THEN AGAIN
WE WANT TO RETAIN OUR POLICE
POWERS SO THAT WE CAN. GET THE
BETTER BEHAVIOR THAT WE WANT
WHEN WE CAN EDUCATION FIRST AND
THEN FOR SPENT LATER. SOME OF
YOU VERY MUCH I'M HAPPY TO
QUESTIONS WHEN TURN OVER SAN
JOSE. THANK YOU IN KEVIN WILL
GO PICK WOULD REGISTER WITH YOU.
YEAH
. CRITICS
. PERFECT AT ONCE
AGAIN KEVIN HEPPNER WITH THE
CITY OF SAN JOSE- SO ONE ECHO
ALL THE COMMENTS OF THE
PREVIOUS CITIES IF MADE- WE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY AGREE BUT I'LL
TRY TO KEEP MY COMMENTS- AND
SORT OF OUR EXPERIENCES
SEPARATE FROM THIS PRESENTATION
SO YOU KNOW WOULD MUCH LIKE
OTHER CITIES HERE THESE DEVICES
BASICALLY CARD WITH VERY LITTLE
NOTIFICATION IN ADVANCE
OVERNIGHT- ONCE WE KIND OF GOT
OVER THE THRILL AS A DEPARTMENT
OF- GIVING THESE THINGS A TRY%
WE DECIDED THAT WE SHOULD
PROBABLY TAKE A LOOK AT
THINKING ABOUT SOME REGULATIONS
FOR THEM. SO JUST A QUICK
TIMELINE OF WHEN THESE DEVICES
DERIVING WHERE WE GOT TODAY SO
JUST EARLIER THIS YEAR WE HAVE
ISSUED OUR ORDINANCES AND
PERMITS FOR SCOOTERS AND NOW WE
ARE UP TO- FIVE DIFFERENT
OPERATORS IN THE CITY SAN JOSE
AND- ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO THE
MARK MORE THAN SIXTY FOUR
HUNDRED DEVICES BEING DEPLOYED
OUR STREETS SO- SO JUST
PROBABLY AND THAT THE
PRINCIPLES THAT WE WANTED TO
ADDRESS WITH OUR LOCAL
ORDINANCES THAT FIRST OF ALL
MOST IMPORTANTLY SAFETY
OBVIOUSLY OUR PRIMARY MISSION
IS A DEPARTMENT I LIKE OTHER
CITIES ON THIS PANEL WE ARE
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES AS A
RESULT OF. TRAFFIC FATALITIES
PARTICULARLY TO PEDESTRIANS AND
OTHER VULNERABLE USERS OUR
STREETS AND ROADS- SECONDLY
EQUITY YOU KNOW HOW WE MAKE
SURE SYSTEM THAT WASN'T
DESIGNED FOR EVERYONE WORKS FOR
EVERYONE- MOD CHIPS MUCH LIKE
OTHER CITIES HERE WE HAVE LOFTY
GOALS ABOUT HOW TO MOVE PEOPLE
OUT OF THEIR CARS AND INTO
ALTERNATIVE MODES OF
TRANSPORTATION INCLUDING
SCOOTERS LASTLY PUBLIC LIFE AND
VIBRANCY YOU KNOW IS A CITY
WHO- EXPERIENCED DIDN'T LOTS OF
SPRAWL AND HOW WE'VE DEVELOPED
AND IS NOW WORKING TO IDENTIFY
OURSELVES- YOU KNOW HOW DO WE
ENSURE. THAT OUR PUBLIC LIFE
AND VIBRANCY IS MAINTAINED. HI
AND WITHIN THAT THE GOALS FOR A
LOCAL ORDINANCE SO YOU KNOW
FIRST OF ALL WE WANTED TO
MONITOR SO THAT'S UNDERSTANDING
HOW THESE DEVICES IN TRIPS.
INTERACT WITH OUR
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM. NEXT WE
WANT TO CONFIRM THE STATE LOCAL
LAWS HAVE RULES AND MAKES SENSE
AND THAT CAN BE ENFORCED.
LASTLY WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE ENSURE THAT OUR RESIDENTS
CONCERNS AND COMPLAINTS CAN BE
ADDRESSED BOTH ON OUR CITIES
AND ON THE END OF THE OPERATORS
AS WELL. SOLDIERS GET INTO AN
OVERVIEW OF WHAT OUR LOCAL
ORDINANCE DOES FIRST HOW WE
JUST HAVE SOME GENERAL
PRINCIPLES ARE ON THE OPERATION
OF THESE DEVICES. WE SET A MAX
SPEED OF TWELVE MILES AN HOUR-
WE HAVE A MODEL FOR A CUSTOMER
SERVICE COMPLAINTS TO. FOR
THESE OPERATORS HAVE A PUBLIC.
PHONE NUMBER LISTED FOR FOLKS
WHETHER THEY'RE OPERATORS OR
JUST LOCAL RESIDENTS TO CONTACT
EACH OF THEM WITH CONCERNS
WHETHER THAT'S- YOU KNOW
SCOOTER BEING PARKED ILLEGALLY
BEING OPERATED- AND SAFELY
THINGS ALONG THOSE LINES- WE
ALSO WAS DOWN FORSMAN SINN
FEIN'S SO. YOU KNOW FOR
OPERATORS WHO ARE OUT OF
COMPLIANCE THERE IS A MECHANISM
FOR US. TO REMEDY THOSE
CONCERNS. LASTLY WE DO HAVE
REQUIREMENTS FOR COVERAGE SO
FOR COMMUNITIES OF CONCERN
WITHIN OUR JURISDICTION. NOW WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE
DEVICES ARE WE BALLOTS TO THOSE
AREAS FOR- FOLKS USE THAT
QUICKLY. AT LAST SECONDLY WE
ALSO APPLICATION REQUIREMENTS
SO THAT INCLUDES A REBALANCING
THAT I JUST MENTIONED- ALSO
PARKING IN LOCKING REQUIREMENTS
BEYOND JUST THE KERR BRAND AND-
OTHER ISSUES THAT OTHER CITIES
MENTIONED WE ALSO HAVE HAD
ISSUES WITH. THESE DEVICES
BEING PARKING FOR FIRE
HYDRANTS- THE- LIMITING ARMORED
SEE RESPONSE- AND BEYOND.
LASTLY JUST WITHIN THAT DATA-
SO THESE ARE LOCATION DEVICE
STATUS FOR INSTANCE WE'VE HAD
TO TELL OPERATORS TO PULL MORE
THAN FORTY SCOOTERS AT A BAR
STREAMS RIVERS AND CREEKS LAST
YEAR. AND YOU KNOW THESE WERE-
MEAL THERE'S UNCLE NUMBER THAT
HAD. TO BE REMOVED EITHER BY
RESIDENTS WERE BY OPERATORS IN
ADDITION TO THAT. SO WITHIN
THAT DATA AS WELL FOR AGRA'S
AGGREGATED IN AND OUT OF MY
STRICT DATA. WITHIN DEVICES
THAT'S THE MAXIMUM MINIMUM
NUMBER OF DEVICES THAT ARE TO
PLAYED ANYONE TIME WITHIN OUR
CITY AND JUST GENERAL SAFETY
PRINCIPLES FOR THOSE DEVICES TO
ENSURE THEY CAN BE OPERATED
SAFELY. LASTLY ON THE EQUITY
AND- SO AGAIN WE BOUNCING FOR
COMMUNITIES OF CONCERN BUT WE
ALSO HAVE A REQUIREMENT FOR FEE
REDUCTIONS FOR OUR LOCAL
RESIDENTS WHO ARE TO MEET THAT
TO UNDER PERCENT POVERTY
THRESHOLD SO THEY CAN OPERATE
AT THESE WERE INSPIRED LARGELY
BY OUR- BIKESHARE- REQUIREMENTS
THAT ARE IN LINE FROM MTC. SO
THE EXPERIENCE SO LIKE MANY
OTHER CITIES WE OF EXPERIENCE A
LARGE NUMBER OF TRIPS MILES.
MAYBE NOT AS MAYES OTHERS HERE
ON THAT PANEL BUT CERTAINLY
FEEL- YOU KNOW JUST SOME.
THINGS TO LOOK AT YOUR RATHER
THAN GOING ON THE TAX YOU CAN
SEE JUST THERE'S A PICTURE IN
THE BOTTOM RIGHT THAT'S FROM A
NEW STORY ABOUT. THE SCOOTERS
BEING IN OUR CREEKS RIVERS AND
STREAMS- ACTUALLY NEWS STORY
FROM GUY WHO WORKS WITH THE
LOCAL FISHING- NONPROFIT. AND
HE HAD I WANT TO SAY FIFTEEN OR
TWENTY THESE BROKEN SCOOTERS IN
ITS TRUNK. SO REALLY JUST- YOU
KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS
THAT WERE OF LEARNING AND-
MOVING INTO THAT WHAT HAVE WE
LEARNED SO. FIRST OF ALL BLANCA
POLICIES ARE INSUFFICIENT YOU
KNOW THESE. ARE EXPERIENCES A
CITY. DIFFERS FROM EVERYONE OF
THE CITY'S HERE ON THE PANEL.
OUR EXPERIENCE ALSO AS A CITY
CHANGES STREET BY STREET BLOCK
BY BLOCK NEIGHBORHOOD BY
NEIGHBORHOOD AND SO. YOU KNOW
FOR US WE REALIZE THAT THESE
KIND OF BLANKET RESTRICTIONS OR
REGULATIONS THAT WE MAY HAVE AS
A CITY. MAY BE INSUFFICIENT TO
REALLY THINK ABOUT THIS MODE AS%
A WHOLE. NEXT JUST IN TERMS OF
OUR NETWORK- WE FOUND IT'S
REALLY JUST REFLECTIVE OF YOU
KNOW THE QUALITY OF A BIKE
NETWORK HOW OUR BIKE LANES WORK
HOW THEY OPERATE THE QUALITY OF
THEM GENERALLY. FOR
TRANSPORTATION- SECONDLY
THINKING ABOUT THIS MOVING
BEYOND A FAD YOU KNOW THESE OF.
THESE DEVICES ARE NOW BACK ON
THE STREETS FOR. AROUND TWO
YEARS HERE AND WHILE YOU KNOW
THEY WERE SORT OF AN
INTERESTING DEVICE NOW. IT'S
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'RE THINKING ABOUT IT SO HOW
DO WE REALLY WORKED. TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS MOVES US IN THE
WAY THAT WE WANT TO WITH
REGARDS TO REDUCING VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED. AND YOU KNOW
OTHER GOALS. THE NEXT SEVEN
THING IN TERMS OF INTEGRATION
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE
DEVICES CAN INTEGRATE WITH IN
OUR CITY AND OUR ENVIRONMENT
WITHIN IT. SO THEY SUPPORT
WHETHER THAT'S LOCAL
NEIGHBORHOOD EVENTS. LARGER
EVENTS LIKE SHARKS GAMES THINGS
ALONG THOSE LINES. HOW DO WE
MAKE SURE THAT THESE CAN BE
USED IN OUR FISH ONLY USE
WITHIN OUR CITY. LASTLY HER
SECOND SIGNAL LAST JUST ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE'VE LEARNED
IS THIS IS A REAL PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN US AS A CITY AS WELL AS
THE OPERATORS. AND THAT WE NEED
TO WORK TOGETHER TO REALLY
THINK ABOUT HOW TO DELIVER
THESE AND EFFECTIVE WAY. AND
LASTLY LIKE OTHER CITIES OF
SAID ADDITIONAL RESOURCES ARE
NEEDED FOR REALLY STRETCH THAN
IS A CITY IN TERMS OF HOW. WE
CAN FORCE AND THINK ABOUT YOU
KNOW MY CREDIBILITY- THANKS TO
THE WORK THAT AWAY IS DONE- ON
AROUND DATA AND THINK ABOUT THE
REGULATIONS GENERALLY BECAUSE
WITHOUT THAT WOULD PROBABLY BE
LOST BUT- YOU KNOW. THAT'S WE
ARE NOW. THANK YOU FOR.
COMPLETING THAT. CENTER RUBIO
YOU HAD A QUESTION. I'M JUST
CURIOUS A LITTLE BUT I KNOW
IT'S A DIFFERENT CIRCUMSTANCE
ABOUT THE CREEKS. TELL ME BOB.
JERRY I DON'T WHY THAT'S
HAPPENING DEFINING THE SCOOTERS
INSIDE THE CREEKS AND WHAT ARE
YOU DOING TO KERR THAT KIND OF
BEHAVIOR. AS FAR AS TO WHY IT'S
HARD TO TELL I MEAN A LOT OF
THESE THE CREEKS- THAT HAVE
EXPERIENCES ARE OFTEN. ALONG
THESE CORRIDORS OF TRAVEL SO
YOU KNOW IT'S RARE TO SEE THEM
BEING SORT OF LAUGHTER BY THE
CREEK- BUT- AS FAR AS WHAT
WE'RE DOING YOU KNOW WE ARE
WORKING WITH OUR OPERATORS TO
ENSURE THAT THERE'S AB. YOU
KNOW. MORE RESPONSIVE TEST TO
THESE KIND OF COMPLAINTS
BECAUSE FOR US YOU KNOW THESE
THE OTHER CERTAINLY BATTERIES
WITHIN THE SCOOTERS THAT CAN.
YOU KNOW HARM THE ENVIRONMENTAL
THE NATURE OF THE CREEKS AND
YOU KNOW GET INTO OUR WATERWAYS
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
REALLY WANT TO WORK TO SOLVE.
THANK YOU FOR SHARING THAT
SOMETHING. HAD NOT OCCURRED TO
ME SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MISTER MURATSUCHI. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE PRESENTATIONS
FROM ALL THE CITIES LIKE WAS
FINDING MYSELF AGREEING WITH SO
MUCH OF WHAT YOU'RE SAYING THAT
IT WAS LIKE MUSIC TWO YEARS IN
TERMS OF SPECIALLY YOUR FOR
YOUR FIRST POINT TO- IT'S- BONE
ON THE ISSUE OF INSURANCE. THAT
I HEARD BOTH LOS ANGELES SAN
FRANCISCO AGREE- THAT- THIS IS
AN AREA THAT THE STATE SHOULD-
ESTABLISHED MINIMUM INSURANCE-REQUIREMENTS THE A TO- ADDRESS
SHARED MOBILITY DEVICES. ARE
ARE THERE ANY CITIES THAT THEY
WOULD DISAGREE WITH THAT. NO
OKAY- IN AND JUST FOR REFERENCE
LOS ANGELES COULD YOU SHARE. DO
YOU HAVE WHAT ARE YOUR CURRENT
A MINIMUM INSURANCE
REQUIREMENTS SO WE HAVE A FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR UMBRELLA
REQUIREMENT AND- I BELIEVE IT'S
ONE MILLION DOLLARS PER
INCIDENT. YEP WE CAN SHARE THE
DETAILS OF THEM WHAT WE'VE
HEARD SO THIS IS ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT THE STATE'S SENT
A SIGNAL WHAT WE'VE HEARD IS
THAT THERE'S ONLY ONE INSURER
IN THE IN THE ENTIRE WORLD
LLOYDS OF LONDON THAT WILL EVEN
RIGHT. THE COVERAGE AND WHAT
THAT MEANS IS THAT IT'S VERY
EXPENSIVE AND WHAT THAT MEANS
IS THAT THERE'S A BARRIER TO
ENTRY TO SMALLER START UPS
WHICH ARE PREDOMINANTLY OWNED
BY WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF COLOR
AND SO I THINK IF THE STATE
SENDS A SIGNAL THAT THIS IS A
NEW INSURANCE MARKET. MY HOPE
WOULD BE THAT THERE WOULD BE
MORE UNDERWRITERS WILLING TO
OFFER THIS KIND OF INSURANCE
AND ELIMINATE THAT BARRIER TO
ENTRY FOR SMALLER COMPANIES. A
RIGHT. AND I ALSO WANT TO ASK
SANTA MONICA WITH A WAY WHAT IS
YOUR INSURANCE REQUIREMENT. I'M
WE HAVE A FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
INCIDENT WITH NO AGGREGATE
MAXIMUM. AND THEN MISTER.
MCGUIRE FROM SAM CISCO YOU
EMPHASIZE THE POINT THAT- THAT
LOCAL LOCAL- REGULATIONS OR
LOCAL NEEDS SHOULD BE ADDRESSED
BY LOCAL REGULATIONS AND THAT
YOU ARE DEFINITELY AGAINST A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL. APPROACH
FROM SACRAMENTO IS THAT CORRECT.
ALL RIGHT IN AND I HEARD A
SIMILAR SENTIMENT FROM SAN
JOSE- THAT- THAT OFTENTIMES
EVEN A- THINGS CAN CHANGE FROM
STREET BY STREET OR
NEIGHBORHOOD BY NEIGHBORHOOD
CORRECT. AND SO THAT WOULD-
ARGUE IN FAVOR OF A CITIES
BEING ABLE TO TAILOR- YOUR
SAFETY RULES FOR THE UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF YOUR YOUR
STREETS. AND ALL CITIES WOULD
AGREE WITH THAT EVEN IN A SMALL
CITY THE SIZE OF SANTA MONICA
WE HAVE NATIONAL DESTINATIONS
WITH APPEAR IN THE PROM AND
ODD- BUT WE HAVE REGULAR
NEIGHBORHOODS LIKE EVERYONE
ELSE SO EVEN IN A SMALL CITY
YOU NEED A VERY WIDE VARIETY OF
LOCAL ABILITY TO PROVIDE
SAFETY. ALL RIGHT WE JUST OFFER
ONE ADDITIONAL SORT OF POINT TO
THAT WHICH IS THAT YOU KNOW LOS
ANGELES IS LARGE ENOUGH THAT WE
HAVE CITIES INSIDE OUR CITY
AND- BECAUSE SOME OF THOSE
CITIES HAVE PUT IN- EXTREMELY
RESTRICTIVE PROGRAMS ARE
OUTRIGHT BANS WHAT WE
EXPERIENCE IS ALL OF THE
SCOOTERS ENDING UP CLUSTERED
RIGHT AROUND THE BOUNDARY OF
THOSE CITIES AND SO THEY END UP
BEING AND AN ISSUE FOR LOS
ANGELES. I DO THINK THAT THERE
IS A ROLE FOR THE STATE TO
ALLOW PASSAGE AT LEAST THROUGH
CITIES AND SET SOME CLARITY
AROUND THAT BECAUSE EVERY
COMPANY IS TREATING THOSE BANDS
IN A DIFFERENT WAY SOME OF THEM
WON'T EVEN LET YOU BRING THIS
GOOD OR INTO THE CITIES. OTHERS
pNOT STOP OTHERS WILL LET YOU
BRING IT IN BUT GO SLOW THAT
FEELS LIKE AN AREA WHERE SOME
KIND OF REGIONAL APPROACH IS
REALLY REQUIRED. ALRIGHT I
APPRECIATE THAT AND- ONE LAST
QUESTION FOR NOW HAVE ANY OF
THE CITY'S REPRESENTED ON THIS
PANEL ADDRESSED THE ISSUE OF.
AND MANY OF THESE. MOBILITY.
PROVIDERS REQUIRE A WAIVERS OF
LEGAL RIGHTS WHEN THEY WHEN
THEY SIGN UP FOR THE SERVICES
HAVE HAVE ANY OF YOU ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE. OKAY ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN. JUST A
COUPLE OF THINGS I'M CURIOUS
ABOUT OF ANY YOU AN ANSWER SO I
COULD BE WRONG ABOUT THIS BUT
SO I KNOW WE JUST HEARD THAT
CALIFORNIA DOESN'T ALLOW-
SCREWS RE WRITTEN ON SIDEWALKS
A STATEWIDE BUT AS FAR AS I
KNOW BICYCLES CAN BE WRITEN
INSIDE WALKS IN A LOT OF CITIES
IN CERTAIN PLACES SO IS THAT
ONE OF THOSE LAWS THAT YOU WISH
YOU HAD THE ABILITY TO HAVE THE
CONTROL OVER WHERE AND- WITH
THE WEATHER SCOOTERS COULD BE
ALLOWED INSIDE WALKS IN CERTAIN
PLACES AT CERTAIN TIMES.
BECAUSE I MUCH SORT OF
WONDERING. BICYCLES CAN GO A
LOT FASTER THAN FIFTEEN MILES
AN HOUR- SO WHY HAVE WE TREATED
THE SCOOTERS DIFFERENTLY THAN
BICYCLES. IT'S A GREAT
QUESTION- AGAIN JENNIFER CITIES
SACRAMENTO IT'S VERY CONFUSING
FOR OUR ACTUAL RESIDENTS OF THE
CITY SACRAMENTO IS ALLOWED
BIKING ON SIDEWALKS EVERYWHERE
EXCEPT WHERE WE PERMIT. HAVE
PROHIBITED AND WE HAVEN'T WE
NEED TO HAVE WHAT WE CALL LOW
STRESS BIKE WAY ADJACENT TO
PROHIBIT SIDEWALK WRITING. AND
THAT INCLUDES ELECTRIC ASSIST
BICYCLE SO WE HAVE JOHN BIKE
SHARE HERE- WHICH IS ALLWED TO
USE THE CITY SIDEWALKS-
HOWEVER- IT YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED
TO SCOOT ON SIDEWALKS- SO IN.
THE STATE IS SAID YOU CAN
CITIES. DANTE BICYCLES YOU CAN
REGULATE THE MEASURE WISH BUT
FOR SCOOTERS YOU CAN'T AND SO
IT'S BEEN A CHALLENGE FOR A
POLICE DEPARTMENT WE'VE BEEN
GOING OUT DOING OUR
ENFORCEMENT. THAT IT IS AND
DOES NOT MAKE SENSE TO THE USER
EVEN THOUGH WE REQUIRE THAT
THERE BE STICKERS ON THEIR ON
THE CERES IS A NO SCOOTING ON
SIDEWALKS- WHO'S LOOKING AT ALL
THE TAXES ON A SCOOTER THEY'RE
NOT. I SO I THINK THE CITY
SACRAMENTO'S. RESPECTIVELY
WOULD LIKE THE AUTHORITY TO
MAKE THAT DECISION OURSELVES.
YEAH AND THE OTHER THING IS
THERE ARE CERTAINLY TIMES WHERE
SOMEONE'S ON A SCOOTER THERE
COULD BE MOMENTS WHERE. THERE
REALLY UNSAFE ON THE STREET.
AND WE'VE TAKEN THE ABILITY FOR
THOSE PEOPLE AT THOSE MOMENTS
TO MAKE THAT VALUE CALL. AND
WHERE THEY MIGHT HAVE TO PUT
THEMSELVES IN DANGER AND I
DON'T UNDERSTAND- MORE WE DON'T
DO THAT FOR BIKES ARE YOU BIKES
WHICH YOU KNOW HAVE A LOT MORE
POTENTIAL FOR DAMAGE THAN A
SCOOTER SO I THINK IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD TAKE
ANOTHER LOOK AT- AND HAVING
SOME KIND OF PARITY. WITH THESE
OTHER. MODES OF TRANSPORTATION
SEEMS TO BE VERY PUNITIVE
SOMETHING'S VERY ARBITRARY JUST
FOR SCOOTERS AND NOT FOR YOU
BIKES OR OTHER. TYPES OF THINGS
AND AAIN. HAMPERING THEIR
ABILITY TO REGULATE. I DO HAVE
A QUESTION FOR SACRAMENTO. AND
I'M JUST CURIOUS ON TAKE IT AS
A CRITICISM- SO. THE IDEA THAT
YOU HAVE TO HAVE THESE PLACES
WERE YOU DOCK YOUR SCOOTERS. I
MAKE SENSE IN THE GROUP YOU
KNOW IN MID TOWN WITH THERE'S-
A LOT OF PEOPLE BUT WHAT IF
WHEN YOU GET OUT TO THE SUBURBS
I MEAN YOU CAN'T HAVE THAT MANY
OF THESE DOCKS SO. HOW FAR THAT
ARE YOU TELLING PEOPLE THEY
HAVE TO EITHER WALK OR TAKEN
UBER TOO SO YOU EXPECTING
PEOPLE TO THEN. EITHER WALK A
MILE COUPLE MILES OR TO CALL
AND UBER WHEN THEY GET TO. A
PLACE WHERE THERE'S NOT A LOT
OF THESE DOCKS I'M JUST CURIOUS
WHAT THE THINKING IS WITH THAT.
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU DON'T
LIKE THESE WHERE AND THEY CAN
CAUSE A PROBLEM. BUT AREN'T YOU
ALSO LIMITING THE USE OF THESE
IN YOUR SUBURBAN AREAS. IT'S
GREAT QUESTIONING THE CHALLENGE
THAT WE ARE GRAPPLING WITH
RIGHT NOW. I'M SO WE REQUIRE
THAT THE SHARED RIVALS. BY CAR
OR DROP ZONE WHICH IS. AREA
WHICH WORKS WELL IN THE- CITY
OF MIDTOWN EVEN JUST OFF THE
GREAT THE SECOND. PLAN PARKERS
PARK IN THOSE AREAS. IT DOES
NOT WORK WELL IN A MORE
SUBURBAN AREAS IF YOU'RE
THINKING IN THE CLINTON HEIGHTS
NEIGHBORHOODS OUTSIDE- TO PASS
A HIGH IT'S UP TO THE NORTH. SO
WE ARE LOOKING AT OTHER WAYS
THAT WE CAN ADDRESS THIS CAN WE
TREAT THEM THIS IS WHAT I WANT
THE FLEXIBILITY. CAN WE TREAT
THEM LIKE A MOTORCYCLE OR MOPED
AND WHERE THEY CAN PARK IN THE
PARKING ONLY PERPENDICULAR TO
THE CURB IN A SUBURBAN AREAS
WHERE WE DON'T HAVE A LANDSCAPE
SHOULD BE A PARKING LEAN. A
FOUR FOOT SIDEWALK IN SOMEONE'S
FRONT YARD- SO COULD WE DO THAT
SO THESE ARE THE THINGS THAT
WE'RE LOOKING INTO TRYING TO
GET REALLY CREATIVE ABOUT IT SO
WE'RE NOT PENALIZING RIGHT NOW
ALSO IF YOU. SCOOT HOMER BIKE
HOME WHEN YOU. PARKED ON THE
STREET IN FRONT OFYOUR HOUSE
YOU WILL NOT HAVE A PENALTY.
BUT IF YOU BLOCK THAT SIDEWALK
YOU CAN AND PROBABLY SHOULD
RECEIVE A PENALTY WE HAVE A- A
RESIDENT WHO HAS A CHILD WITH
A- DISABILITY IS TO LISTEN TO
SINGLE FAMILY RESIDENTIAL AREA.
WITH NO LANDSCAPE STRIP. THE AS
NEIGHBORS WHO ARE USING THE
SIDEWALKS AS PARKING FOR THE
BIKES AND SCOOTERS. WHICH MEANS
THAT HIS SON CAN'T TRAVEL HIS
OWN NEIGHBORHOOD. THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE REALLY WANT
TO ADDRESS IMMEDIATELY. WE WANT
THAT PERSON TO HAVE ACCESS TO
MOBILITY THROUGHOUT HIS
NEIGHBORHOOD. I'M GLAD THAT
YOU'RE- THINKING ABOUT THIS AND
BRING THESE. CREATIVE
SOLUTIONS- MY LAST QUESTION.
WHAT WAS MY- SO IN TERMS OF THE
SCOOTERS BEING THROWN INTO THE
WATER AND- INTO THE BAY AND THE
RIVERS AND ALL THAT YOU KNOW
MAYBE A LITTLE SCOOTER HATE
GOING ON- SOMETHING HAPPENING
THERE. DO ANY OF YOU. SORT OF
CHARGE THE SCOOTER COMPANIES OR
DO YOU HAVE A FUND THAT THEY
HAVE TO PAY INTO TO DEAL WITH
THIS SORT OF ENVIRONMENTAL.
PROBLEM THAT THESE CREATE.
SOMETIMES OF HAVE YOU THOUGHT
ABOUT DOING THAT. TAKE YOUR
ENVIRONMENTAL FINE NO YOU KNOW
IT IF THE SCOOTERS ARE LEFT
UNATTENDED AND AN ADDRESS FOR
MORE THAN TWENTY FOUR HOURS
THEY WOULD BE FINED A HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER DEVICE FOR EACH
VIOLATION BUT THERE'S KNOWS.
KILLER ENVIRONMENT TO FIND TO
ADDRESS KIND OF THAT MEDICATION.
SIMILARLY WE DON'T HAVE A
SPECIFIC FOR FUND FOR THAT ONE
OF THE CHALLENGES IS THAT. THE
DEVICES ACTUALLY DO GO OUT OF
COMMUNICATION ACTUALLY A LOT
MORE QUICKLY THAN YOU MIGHT
THINK AS WELL. SO YOU KNOW OUR
OUR APPROACH IS A CITY WOULD BE
TO CON I FOR WHERE THE DEVICES
IS AND THAT KIND OF POSITION.
TO RIP RECALL TO TELL THE
COMPANIES AND SAY YOU KNOW
WITHIN REASON A LOT OF TIME YOU-HAVE TO REMEDY THE SITUATION-
AND LEAVE IT AT THAT. HOWEVER
THE BIGGEST CONCERN IS JUST
WHAT IS THE WHAT IS THE NUMBER
OF THEM THAT WE DON'T EVEN KNOW
OUR IS THERE IN THE PACIFIC
OCEAN. YEAH IT JUST SEEMS THAT.
YOU KNOW THEY HAVE THESE
DEVICES THAT THERE DON'T THEY
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF INCENTIVE
TO GO AND TRY TO COLLECT. ONCE
THEY'RE IN THE KINDEST ONCE ARE
UNDER WATER. AND MAYBE. YOU
KNOW THAT'S AN AREA WHERE
PENALTIES. MIGHT HELP THEM.
PROACTIVELY DEAL WITH THAT. TO
SURVIVE. AND JUST TO FOLLOW UP
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT ENFORCEMENT FOR
US AS WE- YOU KNOW BALANCING
THE SORT OF FEE TO OPERATORS
AND JUST IN TERMS OF THEIR
COSTS FOR PUTTING A NEW ONE OUT
INTO THE STREETS I MEAN. YOU
KNOW IF FOR US IF WE CHARGE TOO
GREAT OF A PENALTY FOR THE SOME
OF THESE OPERATORS THEY HAVE NO
INCENTIVE TO GO GET IT AND
THEY'D RATHER JUST BUY A NEW
ONE AND PUT IT ON THE STREETS
AND YOU KNOW GET FROM US. WHERE
IS OUR EXPERIENCE OF-
PROACTIVELY BOTH REQUIRING THAT
THE SCOOTERS THE LOCK TO A BIKE
RACK BUT ALSO STRUCTURING- THE
COST OF THIS BIKE RACKS A BILL
TO THE SCREW COMPANIES FEES SO
YOU CAN. YOU CAN CHARGE AND-
THE COST OF PULLING OUT OF THE
WATER OR YOU CAN. CHARGE OF A
LOT SMALLER COST TO BUILD A
GOOD INFRASTRUCTURE OF BIKE
RACKS AND HAVE THOSE. SCOOTERS
LOCKS OF THE VANDALISM IS LESS.
IS A LESS IMPACTFUL THE
PUBLIC'S OF THE PROJECT. IF YOU
WERE PUTTING GEO FENCES AROUND
THE VENICE SO IN LA IT'S THE
VENICE CANALS IS WHERE THEY
WERE ENDING UP SO WE PUT AT. A
GEO FENCE AROUND THE CANALS
ITSELF. AND SO BECAUSE WE HAVE
THE INFORMATION IN ALMOST REAL
TIME ABOUT. IF THESE THINGS END
UP THERE WE- ARE ABLE TO GO OUT
AND DO ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS IN A
HIGHLY VISIBLE WAY THAT
CREATES. A REAL DISINCENTIVE-
FOR THE COMPANIES TO DO THAT
BECAUSE THEIR WHOLE PERMIT TO
OPERATE LOS ANGELES IS. AT
STAKE IF THEY CAN'T. STAY OUT
OF THAT THIS ENVIRONMENTALLY
SENSITIVE AREA TO BEGIN WITH.
RIGHT THANK YOU. SENATOR
MORLOCK. YOUR CHAIR OF WORKING
HERE IN SACRAMENTO I. LEAVE THE
OFFICE LATER IN THE DAY I LIKE
TO AVOID TRAFFIC AND I LIKE TO
WORK COURTS QUITE IN THE OFFICE
BEFORE I GO TO MY PLACE HERE.
AND WHAT I'VE NOTICED WITH THE
SCOOTERS IS NOT THAT THEY ARE
ASSISTING PEOPLE WITH TRANSIT
TO GET FROM POINT A TO POINT B.
BUT THEY TEND TO BE
RECREATIONAL AND I SEE GROUPS
OF YOUNG ADULTS JUST WHIZZING
BY- FLYING OFF CURBS A IN
GROUPS IT'S JUST A RECREATIONAL
KIND OF. EXERCISER LIKE A NIGHT
OUT KIND OF A OPPORTUNITY YOU
KNOW. SO I'M JUST CURIOUS HOW
HARD IT MY OBSERVING. THIS
CORRECTLY- WILL. YOU KNOW WHAT
ARE THEY REALLY BEING USED FOR
WE DON'T KNOW BECAUSE WE
HAVEN'T COLLECTED THE DATA ON
THAT SUCH A GREAT QUESTION- WE
DO KNOW THAT OUR- OURDEVICES
ARE GETTING A LOT OF TRIPS.
THAT THERE ABOUT A MILE ON
SCOOTERS IN A LITTLE BIT TWO
MILES ON BIKES ARE FOR EACH
TRIP- SO THAT'S INCLUDED MAYBE
MORE THE RECREATION ME PART OF
IT IS RECOGNITION MAYBE THEY'RE
GOING TO WATCH THE KINGS PLAY A
GOLDEN ONE. WE DON'T KNOW YET
WE WILL BE ROLLING OUT A USER
SURVEY THE SPRING- FOR ALL OUR
MEMBER- MORE PERMIT COMPANIES
TO GET A BETTER UNDERSANDING
OF WHAT THEY ARE DOING. WE ARE
IT WE HAVE BEEN WORKING REALLY
HARD EDUCATING THE USERS SO
THEY KNOW- HOW TO SAFELY USE A
SCOOTER OR SHARED BIKE AND
URBAN ENVIRONMENTS. WE OFFER
FREE CLASSES EVERY MONTH- WE
WENT OUT WITH PD AND CH FEET
GIVEN OUT INFORMATIONAL FLIERS
WE'VE DONE OUR VIDEOS SOCIAL
MEDIA- BUT IT HASN'T BEEN
ENOUGH WE RELY ON THE COMPANIES
WE ACTUALLY REQUIRE IN OUR
PERMIT. THEN THEY ALSO DO THEIR
OWN EDUCATION I DON'T REALLY
THINK THAT THAT'S ACTUALLY COME
TO FRUITION OR TO THE LEVEL
THAT WE WOULD HAVE EXPECTED-
AND SO WE WILL BE ROLLING OUT
ON ENFORCEMENT AND SCOOTING ON
SIDEWALKS AND- PARKING
ILLEGALLY BALKING ABOUT THE
TRAVEL. THIS MONTH ON IT'S NOT
MEANT TO BE PUNITIVE IT IS NOT
MEANT TO COLLECT ANY SORT OF
CITATION FEET BUT IT'S REALLY
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE. IN THE
FOLKS OUT THERE UNDERSTAND THAT
GOOD BEHAVIOR. BUT A WITH ANY
OF THESE. MOVING. OPPORTUNITIES
SKATEBOARDS SETTER OF PEOPLE
GET PROFESSIONAL DOING
INTERESTING. THINGS WITH THEM-
SO I JUST WONDER WOULD THE
OWNERS OF THESE SCOOTERS WOULD
WOULD THEY REALIZE ALL MY
GOODNESS THEY WENT FROM POINT A
TO POINT B. AT A RATHER HIGH
SPEED. MOST OF. DONE SOME KIND
OF JUMPING COULD HAVE. YOU KNOW
SHORTEN THE LIFE OF A VEHICLE
LIKE MAYBE I SHOULD ASK THAT IN
THE NEXT PANEL BUT- I I'M JUST
SEEING THEM IS JUST TOYS THAT
KIDS ARE JUST HAVING A FUN TIME
AT NIGHT ZOOMING THROUGH THE
ARENA AND THE CAPITAL AREA. SO
THANK YOU. SIR MCGUIRE. THE
QUICKNESS TO CHAIR A GOING TO-
LOS ANGELES MANAGER MANAGER YOU
MENTION SIX PIECES OF DATA CAN
YOU TAKE THEM OFF REAL QUICK
THAT YOU'RE COLLECTING- TRIPS
START TRIP END VEHICLE ID TRIP
TIME- AND THEN- THE FLEET THE
NUMBER OF VEHICLES AND ANY
GIVEN LOCATION AND I CAN'T
REMEMBER THE SIX ONE BUT THAT'S
THE THAT'S THE L. O. AND THE
ROUTE THE ROUTE ITSELF BUT WE
DON'T GET THE ROUTE IN REAL
TIME WE ONLY GET THAT TWENTY
FOUR HOURS AFTER THE RIDE IS
DONE SO THE START IN THE END WE
GET THE REST OF THOSE IN MORE
OR LESS REAL TIME. BECAUSE WE
NEED TO KNOW WHERE THIRTY EIGHT
THOUSAND THINGS ARE- INNER CITY
AT ANY GIVEN TIME WE CAN FOLLOW
UP WITH YOU ON THAT AS WELL IF
YOU DON'T MIND. FOR EACH OF THE
PANELISTS CAN YOU PLEASE
PROVIDE. THE COMMITTEES YOUR
INSURANCE POLICIES THAT WOULD
BE GREAT- THAT YOU HAVE
IMPLEMENTED THAT WOULD BE
REALLY HELPFUL AS WE MOVE
FORWARD- WHEN I GO TO SEE
COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO IN REGARDS
TO- HAVING TO LOCK. THE DEVICE
AT THE END. SO IT IS. A IS
SOMEONE LOCKS INTO A- IT'S
REGARD TO SAID ALSO COUNT TO ME
WHAT WOULD YOU SEE HOW DOES
THAT WORK EXACTLY. YES SO WE
DON'T WANT THE DEVICE TO BE
LOCKED PLACES WITH IT WHETHER
OUT SAFE SO WE DON'T WANT THEM
LOCKED TO- TO THE SIDES OF
BUILDINGS OR THINGS LIKE THAT-
IT'S A PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE SO
WE'LL HAVE TO BE LOCKED BY
CRACKS OR TO PRIVATELY OWNED BY
CRACKS- ON EITHER PUBLIC OR
PRIVATE PROPERTY- WE DON'T WANT
TO. MISS A PERFECT SENSORS AT.
THAT'S A PERFECT SCIENCE OR.
IT'S A IT IS AN IMPERFECT SIDE
YEAH IT'S OR BUT- BUT EVEN THE
A PERFECT SIZE IT'S SO MUCH
BETTER WHEN THEY WERE WHEN THEY
WERE BEING PART OF THE MIDDLE
THE SIDEWALKS AS WE SEE THIS IS
AN EVOLUTION CAN YOU JUST GIVE
US. OVER UNDER HERE SO FROM. HE
STARTED THAT TO NOW ARE YOU
LOOKING AT A- SIXTY PERCENT.
DIFFERENCE AS FAR AS- CHANGING
AND- LACK OF BLOCKAGE WALKS
THROUGH THAT REALLY QUICKLY.
YEAH I THINK THE BEST INDICATOR
AT USE THE COMPLAINTS WE GET.
SO LIKE I SAID BEFORE WE HAD A
REGULATORY PROGRAM IN PLACE WE
WERE GETTING TWO THOUSAND
COMPLAINTS. A MONTH AND IN
COUNTY OVER FIVE HUNDRED
SCOOTERS PER MONTH- AT THIS
POINT WE ARE RECEIVING. ON THE
ORDER OF A HUNDRED TO TWO
HUNDRED COMPLAINTS. PER MONTH
AND- IT SOUNDED IS IT'S
NEGLIGIBLE IT'S A- YOU KNOW. A
FEW SCOOTERS. IT'S INTERESTING.
THAT'S GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH
THAT'S REALLY HELPFUL. THANK
YOU TO EVERYONE OF YOU FOR
TAKING THE TIME IN HELPING US
WITH THIS SERVICE. I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO IS AGAIN COMING FROM
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. THINK OF THE
LOCALS TO HAVE THE ABILITY TO
WEIGH IN. BECAUSE ONE SIZE
DOESN'T FIT ALL AND I'M ASKING.
HAVE YOU FOUND IT THE ABILITY
TO ROLL BACK ENFORCEMENT WHEN
YOU FOUND OUT IT WASN'T WORKING
AND. WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT CAN
FORSMAN. ISN'T IT JUST LIKE OF
THE SHOPPING CART AND FORCED
WE'RE COLD COULD FORCE MEANT
WENT OUT AND PICKED THEM UP IF
THEY WERE THERE. GOING FORWARD
IN BEING ABLE TO- CHARGE A FEE
FOR THE FOR THE PICK UP THERE
pABOUT THE CREEKS I UNDERSTAND
OVER LAKE MERRITT THEY PULLED
SIXTY OUT OF LAKE MERRITT.
RECENTLY SO- BUT YOU KNOW THEY
SAY. HAVE YOU FOUND A-
BUILDING- SO.HAVE YOU FOUND IT
IS ROLLING BACK ENFORCEMENT HAS
BEEN EFFECTIVE AND WORKING WITH
SKINNER COMPANIES. I'M IN SANTA
MONICA OR JUST WRAPPING UP THE
FIRST PILOT AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'RE NOTICING IS
THAT- YOU KNOW WE DON'T WANNA
ISSUE CITATIONS THAT ARE NOT
AND FOR THAT ARE NOT DEFENSIBLE
AND SO IT'S FAIRLY REASONABLE
TO ISSUE CITATIONS FOR THINGS
THAT ARE QUANTIFIABLE AND
CLEARLY SPELLED OUT SPELLED
OUT. HOWEVER AS A PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION SOURCE IN AN
OSTENSIBLY THE SHOULD BE PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION BECAUSE THEY'RE
USING THE PUBLIC RIGHT OF WAY-
THE SOME OF THOSE OUTCOMES
ABOUT EQUITY AND ABOUT ACCESS
AND DISTRIBUTION THOSE ARE
THOSE ARE REALLY HARD TO ISSUE
CITATIONS FOR- SO I THINK- TO
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION. M. YES
WE'RE SEEING THAT ENFORCEMENT
ISN'T EFFECTIVE FOR CERTAIN
OUTCOMES THAT WE WANT TO-
ACHIEVE TOGETHER AND SO WE ARE
I THINK ALL WE HAVE OUR HEADS
TOGETHER TO KIND OF THINK ABOUT
WHAT ARE THE TOOLS THAT ARE
NEEDED THAT OUR PARTNERSHIP
TOOLS. TO GET TO THE OUTCOMES
BECAUSE CITIES DON'T WANT TO
HAVE TO GO OUT SITE IT'S OF NO
INTEREST TO US TO CHASE
SCOOTERS- IT IS OF INTEREST FOR
SCOOTERS TO BE AVAILABLE AFTER
WILL AFFORDABLE AND SAFE AND SO
THAT'S WHY SORT OF WE'RE STILL
AT THE TABLE. AND I THINK THIS
SORT OF LOCAL CONTROL LOCAL
PROBLEM SOLVING IS STILL IN ITS
RELATIVE JUVENILE STATE- AS WE
FIGURED OUT SO YEAH WE'RE WE'RE
ACTIVELY KIND OF PULLING BACK
AND PUSHING FORWARD AND TESTING
IN TRYING- ON A- PRETTY MUCH
MONTHLY BASIS. CENTER THANK YOU
SO MUCH WE WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU EACH OF YOU FOR TAKING TIME
AND YOU'RE REALLY BUSY
SCHEDULES BE WITH US TODAY
FANTASTIC JOB THANK YOU SO
MUCH- WE'RE NOT GONNA BE MOVING
ON TO OUR- FINAL. PANEL HERE IN
THIS IS WE'RE GONNA HEAR. FROM
STAKEHOLDER PERSPECTIVES. ON
CHAIR MOBILITY REGULATION YOU
CAN HEAR TWO DIFFERENT AND
DISTINCT SITES. FIRST OVER HERE
FROM EDWARD FOO IS A SENIOR
REGULATORY COUNSEL FOR BIRD.
ORGAN NAY NAY HERE FROM OUR
SINGER GOING IS HE'S THE SENIOR
REGULATORY COUNSEL FOR NEW
MOBILITY. AND UBER. AND WE'RE
GONNA HEAR FROM CRYSTAL AND
HE'S THE A PAST PRESIDENT. FROM
THE CALIFORNIA CONUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA. LISTEN
JIM IF IT WORKS FOR THIS
COMMITTEE WE'RE GONNA TURN THE
FLOOR OVER TO MISTER FOO FIRST
IN REGARD TO SCREW THE ONUS AND
THEN MISTER DOLAN. WE WELCOME
EACH OF YOU HERE EACH OF YOU OF
FIVE MINUTES WE'LL GIVE YOU A
ONE MINUTE HEADS UP. AS WE
START GETTING TOWARDS THE END
OF YOUR TESTIMONY. EDWARD THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING US
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE TO
FOUR STORES YOUR FIVE MINUTES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MY NAME IS
EDWARD FOO IT'S A REAL HONOR TO
BE HERE TODAY AMONG SO MANY OF
CALIFORNIA'S BRIGHTEST
TRANSPORTATION MONTHS- I AM
THE- HEAD. OF REGULATORY POLICY
AD LEGISLATION FOR BURKE. THE
COMPANY THAT TWO YEARS AGO IN
SANTA MONICA PLACE TENDS SHARED
SCOOTERS ON THEIR SIDEWALKS.
AND I DON'T THINK ANY OF US
COULD HAVE PREDICTED WHAT HAS.
WHAT WE HAVE SET IN MOTION. I
THINK IT IS HARD TO UNDERSTAND
HOW MUCH WE HAVE LEARNED IN
THESE PAST TWO YEARS CREATING
THIS INDUSTRY FROM SCRATCH AND
I THINK OF THOSE TWO YEARS.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY
NINETEEN. AS A SORTS CEASE
OFFER MICHAEL BILLETING. IN
THAT TWENTY EIGHTEEN WAS ABOUT
THE INDUSTRY WE AGGRESSIVELY
EXPANDED ALL ACROSS CALIFORNIA
AND- YES WE DIDN'T ALWAYS ASK
FOR PERMISSION. AND I THINK
THAT MEANS LEARNING THAT WE HAD
WAS THAT THIS WASN'T THE RIGHT
APPROACH. THAT NO MATTER HOW
POPULAR ARE SCREWS WERE WITH WE
SHOULD JST BE COPYING THE
PLAYBOOKS OF OTHERS. AND THAT
WE HAD A SHARE RESPONSIBILITIES
THE COMMUNITIES IN WHICH WE
OPERATE IT. AND THAT WAS OUR
FIRST MAJOR LEARNING. AND SO WE
MAY TWENTY NINETEEN ABOUT THE
CITIES WE STOP WATCHING WITHOUT
PERMISSION. WE REACHED OUT TO
EVERY CITY IN CALIFORNIA. TO
DEVELOP THEIR OWN SURE DOC WAS
PROGRAM. EACH WITH THEIR OWN
RULES TAILORED TO THE NEEDS OF
THE COMMUNITY WE'VE HEARD A
LOT. ABOUT THEM FROM- FROM THE
PREVIOUS PANEL. AND THEY'VE
DONE VERY WELL AND A SON BEAR
IT REMARKABLY WELL FOR THE
GROWTH OF SHARED MICHAEL
ABILITY AND CALIFORNIA. HOWEVER
WHAT I WANT TO BRING TO WHAT
WHAT I WANT TO DISCUSS TODAY.
IS THIS IS FROM OUR SIDE. THE
SECOND MAJOR LEARNING THAT WE
LEARN FROM THESE REGULATION. IS
THAT IT WORKS BUT IT COMES AT A
COST. AND I DON'T MEAN THE COST
UPON US BIRD THE CORPORATE AND
SEE I MEAN UPON OUR WRITERS. IN
LESS THAN A YEAR THE COST OF
SHARED MICHAEL ABILITY IN
CALIFORNIA HAS. TRIPLED AND IT
CONTINUES TO GROW. IN SOME
AREAS RIDERSHIP HAS DROPPED
FIFTY TO EIGHTY PERCENT. MUCH
OF ITS SWITCHING BACK TO CARSON
DNC'S. AND SO WE'RE HERE BEFORE
YOU TODAY TO RECONCILE THOSE
TWO LEARNINGS. I HOPE THAT WE
ALL AGREE THAT LEARNING FROM
THE LESSONS OF T. AND SEES.
THAT SHARED MICHAEL BILLY IS
SOMETHING THAT IS BEST
REGULATED ON THE LOCAL LEVEL. I
HOPE THAT WE ALSO ALL AGREE.
THE CALIFORNIA WHAT CAN'T BE
PUSHING PEOPLE AWAY FROM BIKES
AND SCOOTERS. AND TOWARDS CARS.
AND IF ANYTHING THE OPPOSITE
SHOULD BE TRUE. IN FACT
EXISTING CALIFORNIA VEHICLE
CODE TWO ONE TWO TWO ZERO
ALREADY SAYS THAT. AND SO THESE
TWO GOALS ARE POLICY PILLARS.
AND ACHIEVING THE REQUIRES
COOPERATION BETWEEN NOT JUST
BIRD IN THE CITIES BUT ALSO THE
STATE. AND WE KNOW THE SOME
PART BECAUSE WE ASK
CALIFORNIA'S DIRECTLY. WITH ASK
THEM OVER AND OVER AGAIN WHAT
WOULD MAKE YOU TAKE CARS LESSEN
WHAT WOULD MAKE YOU TAKE
BURDEN. OTHER MICHAEL BUILDING
MORE. IN ALMOST EVERY TIME WE
ALWAYS GET THE SAME THREE
ANSWERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
FIRST IS INFRASTRUCTURE.
WRITERS DON'T FEEL SAFE. FROM
CARS WITHOUT A PROTECTED BY
PLANE. SO THEY STAY IN CARS
PERPETUATING A VICIOUS CYCLE. I
THINK WE'RE ALL BUT VERY WELL
FAMILIAR WITH THE CHALLENGES OF
BUILDING COMPLETE STREETS. AND
SO I WON'T REHASH THEM. BUT
THAT THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT
WE'VE INTRODUCED MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS TO MY- MOBILITY.
HELPING THEM. APPRECIATE WHAT
PROTECTED BY PLEASE CAN DO FOR
THE COMMUNITIES. SECOND IS
AVAILABILITY. FOR
TRANSPORTATION MODE TO BE
RELIABLE AND A PART OF YOUR
ROUTINE TO HAS TO BE READILY
AVAILABLE. AND SO THAT'S WHY IN
SAN FRANCISCO ALONE. THERE ARE
FIFTY THOUSAND TNC DRIVERS ON
THE ROADS. SO THAT WHENEVER YOU
PULL OUT YOUR PHONE YOU CAN
FIND A TNC CAR WITHIN A FEW
MINUTES. HOWEVER WHEN IT COMES
TO DOUGLAS MICHAEL ABILITY SAN
FRANCISCO'S LIMITED TO TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED DEVICES ONE
TWENTIETH THE NUMBER OF TNC
DRIVERS. IMAGINE IF IT'LL
TWENTY TIMES AS LONG TO GET A
TNC CAR. COULD YOU WOULD YOU TO
RELY ON THAT AS AN OPTION TO
GET TO WORK. OR WOULD YOU FIND
SOMETHING ELSE. AND FINALLY IS
COSTS. AS I MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY THE COST OF SHARE
MICHAEL BUILDING CALIFORNIA HAS
TRIPLED IN LESS THAN A YEAR. IN
SOME PLACES AND NOW COSTS MORE
TAKE A SCOOTER BUT IT DOESN'T
TAKE A TNC CAR. THIS IS DUE TO
MANY REASONS ONE OF WHICH HAS
TO DO WITH THE DYSTROPHY
STRUCTURE THAT. THAT MOBILITY
FACES IN CALIFORNIA. THROUGHOUT
THE STATE CALIFORNIANS WRITING
IN THE TNC CAR. PAID ZERO POINT
25% OF THEIR FARE TO THE CPC. I
CONTRAST DEPENDING ON THE CITY
CALIFORNIA'S WRITING ON SHARED
BIKES AND SCOOTERS PAY BETWEEN
TWENTY TO EIGHTY TIMES THAT.
ENOUGH FIGURE CONTINUES TO
RISE. FOR SURE MICHAEL ABILITY
TO FULFILL ITS MOTION POTENTIAL
HAS TO BE AN OPTION AVAILABLE
TO ALL CALIFORNIANS. WE SEE
THESE AS THE THREE MAKE
CONSTRAINTS ON THE GROWTH OF
MICHAEL BUILDING CALIFORNIA
INFRASTRUCTURE AVAILABILITY AND
COST. THESE ARE NOT CHALLENGES
THAT CAN BE SOLVED BY BIRD LOAN
OR BY THE CITY'S ALONE OR BY
THE STATE ALONE AND THEY HAVE
TO BE SOLVED BY ALL THREE OF US
TOGETHER. WHICH BRINGS ME TO MY
FINAL POINT. HISTORICALLY A LOT
OF TECH COMPANIES MISSIONS HAVE
BEEN FOUR THOUSAND- OR EVEN
OPPOSED TOWARDS THE PUBLIC
INTEREST. BUT OUR MISSION ISN'T
TO SELL POLITICAL ADS OR TO GET
YOUR PACKAGE ONE DAY SOONER OUR
MISSION IS TO GET PEOPLE OUT OF
CARS AND I BELIEVE THAT'S A
MISSION THE ALMOST EVERYONE IN
THIS ROOM SHARES. WERE ALL ON
THE SAME TEAM AND SO AS WE
PIONEERED THIS INDUSTRY WE HOPE
TO ALSO PIONEER A NEW PLAYBOOK
THAT'S HOW WE INTERACT WITH
LOCAL AND STATE GOVERNMENTS ONE
THAT ISN'T BASED ON ASKING FOR
FORGIVENESS. BUT TOWARDS
COLLABORATING TOWARDS OUR
SHARED POLICY GOALS IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WAS ABOUT THE INDUSTRY
AND TWENTY NINETEEN WAS ABOUT
CITIES BUT I HOPE THE TWENTY
TWENTIES THE YEAR. IN WHICH THE
SEIZE ALL SETTLES AND WE FIND
THE RIGHT BALANCE BETWEEN THE
INDUSTRY PRIVATE ENTERPRISE.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND STATE
GOVERNMENT TO WORK TOGETHER ON
A CLIMATE CONGESTION AND SAFETY
GOALS THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE'RE GRATEFUL YOU'RE HERE
TODAY WERE NOT ENTERED OR MISC
GONE IS. A SENIOR REGULATORY
COUNSEL- NEW MOBILITY FOR OVER
THE FLOORS GEORGIA FIVE MINUTES
ARE GIVE YOU MINUTES UP. THANKS
HI GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
MCGUIRE AND FRAZIER AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEES- MY NAME
SOUTH WE'RE GONNA SAME AS
SENIOR REGULATORY COUNCIL FOR
NEW ABILITY AT UBER. AND I
FOCUS ON MY PROMOTE BILLY
OPERATIONS THROUGH DROP. I WANT
TO SHARE A BIT ABOUT MY
EXPERTISE- I HAVE WORKED FOR
OVER TEN YEARS IN PUBLIC POLICY
AND REGULATION. DURING MY YEARS
OF GOVERNMENT SERVICE HAVE BEEN
A REGULATOR I'VE BEEN A POLICY
ADVISER TO BUILD ADMINISTRATIVE
AND ELECTED OFFICIALS. SO WITH
THAT I APPRECIATE THE ROLE THE
GOVERNMENT'S ESPECIALLY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE TO PLAY IN
SHAPING THE NEXT GENERATION OF
AMERICAN CITIES. AND I
APPRECIATE THAT DEVELOPING.
POLICY RESPONSES TO NEW
TECHNOLOGY IS NEVER EASY. I
SPENT THE LAST SIX MONTHS AT
UBER REVIEWING EVERY
APPLICATION WE SUBMIT IN
CALIFORNIA AND WORKING WITH OUR
OPERATIONS TEAM TO SUPPORT ANY
COMPLIANCE ENQUIRIES. I FOR THE
LIFE CYCLE OF OUR PERMITS SO I
APPRECIATE THE RANGE OF ISSUES
THAT YOU MAY BE HEARING FROM
YOUR CONSTITUENTS. WHICH IS I
REALLY WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME HERE TO SHARE MORE
ABOUT JUMPS APPROACH IN THE
SPACE. TODAY JUMP OPERATES IN
MORE THAN TWO DOZEN US CITIES
INCLUDING FIVE CITIES IN
CALIFORNIA THIS INCLUDE
SACRAMENTO SAN FRANCISCO SANTA
CRUZ SANTA MONICA AND LOS
ANGELES. WE'VE HEARD FROM MANY
TODAY. AND INCLUDES ALSO
SEVERAL INTERNATIONAL MARKETS
INCLUDING PARIS ROME AND BERLIN.
WE SUPPORT COMMONSENSE
REGULATION AS WITH ANYTHING THE
CHALLENGE IN THE OPPORTUNITY IS
IN THE DETAILS WE BELIEVE THAT
THERE'S A WAY TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS INCLUDING THEIR
PRIVACY AND REGULATOR INDUSTRY
AND WOULD DO IT WITHOUT
SACRIFICING PUBLIC SAFETY. OR
GOVERNMENT PLANNING EFFORTS.
GETTING THIS RIGHT WILL REQUIRE
AN ONGOING COLLABORATIVE
APPROACH BETWEEN CITY
REGULATORS INDUSTRY AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS AND ANYTHING LESS
WILL BE A SHORT TERM PANACEA
REALLY A CHECK THE BOX EFFORT.
AND IT'S GOING TO JEOPARDIZE
THE WHAT OUR GOALS IN THE LONG
RUN. WE'RE ALL EXCITED ABOUT
THE POTENTIAL TO MAKE ABILITY
HAS AND WE REALLY WANT TO
STRIKE THE RIGHT BALANCE HERE.
SO TO THAT END WE BELIEVE THAT
OUR EXPERIENCE AND QUALITY
MATTER TO ENSURE RELIABILITY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY. WE HAVE
EIGHT YEARS EXPERIENCE WORKING
WITH GOVERNMENT PARTNERS AND WE
PROBABLY MAINTAIN MORE THAN
FOUR CONTRACTS AND PER FORTY
CONTRACTS AND PERMITS
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD. MICHAEL
MOBILITY OFFERS YOUR
CONSTITUENTS TRANSPORTATION
OPTIONS THAT ARE MORE
AFFORDABLE AND MORE CONVENIENT
AND MORE ENVIRONMENTALLY
FRIENDLY. THE GOAL FOR BOTH
JUMP IN OVER IS TO CONNECT
RURAL OR URBAN AREAS TO ONE
ANOTHER BY CREATING A SEAMLESS
EXPERIENCE DIRECTLY WITH IN ONE
APP. BIKES IS GUNNERS HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO REDUCE TRAFFIC AND
ALLEVIATE THE NEED FOR PARKING.
AND SIMPLY PUT MICHAEL MOBILITY
PROVIDERS OUT PROVIDE A PATHWAY
TO REDUCING URBAN AMERICANS
DEPENDENCY ON CARS. WHAT I
BIGGER BACKGROUND ON JOB I'D
LIKE TO DISCUSS HOW WE APPROACH
REGULATION SPECIFICALLY. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE LEGITIMATE
CONCERNS WE KNOW THAT CITIES
CARE MOST ABOUT SAFETY
OVERSATURATION STREET VERSUS
SIDEWALK USAGE PARKING
VIOLATIONS AND EQUITY CONCERNS
AND I THINK THOSE WERE OUTLINED
OUT QUITE NICELY BY MISS TO ON
WHY IT AND HER SITES.
OVERSEEING THESE PROGRAMS IS
ALSO RESOURCES INTENSIVE TODAY
AS CITY'S MINISTERS HERE CAN
ATTEST AND HAVE IT TESTED
TODAY. OUR HOPE IS AT BEST
PRACTICES WILL BE IDENTIFIED
AND ADOPTED INTO THE REGULATORY
SCHEME TO REDUCE THIS BURDEN-
AND WE WOULD WELCOME THE
CERTAINTY AS WELL I THINK WE'VE
HEARD TODAY THAT A LOT OF
TESTIMONY THAT THERE'S NO
DOMINANT REGULATORY SCHEME. AND
THEN THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME
FLEXIBILITY TO ALLOW FOR
CONTINUED INNOVATION IN THE
SPACE. TO GET THERE WE ARE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. ON MEANINGFUL AND
RESPONSIBLE REGULATIONS. LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE IMPORTANT
PARTNERS FOR ENSURING PUBLIC
SAFETY WE APPRECIATE THE CLOUT
ABILITY TO COLLABORATE WITH
THEM AND I WANTED TO SHARE
RECENT EXAMPLE. WE ARE EXCITED
TO PARTICIPATE IN A RECENT
WORKSHOP WITH THE LAPD TO SHARE
THAT JOHN VIA UBER HAS AN
ESTABLISHED PORTAL FOR HANDLING
LAW ENFORCEMENT REQUESTS.
BUILDING THOSE RELATIONSHIPS
ARE REALLY GOOD INVESTMENT FOR
EVERYBODY FOLLOWING THE
WORKSHOP MOST RECENTLY AN LAPD
DETECTIVE CONTACTED OUR WEST
HOLLYWOOD LIAISON FOR
ASSISTANCE WITH A HATE CRIME.
OR A SUSPECT HAD USED TO ADD
RIGHT SURE SCOOTER. WITHIN THE
HOUR THE DETECTIVE WAS ABLE TO
GET HIS ACCOUNT CREATED AND HAS
WARRANT SUBMITTED
ELECTRONICALLY. CITIES CAN
REALLY CHAMPION- INNOVATION AND
TECHNOLOGY TO KEEP SIDEWALKS
CLEAR AND ENSURE MY COME
ABILITY IS SEEN AS A BENEFIT
AND NOT A HEADACHE BY USING
INTELLIGENT REGULATIONS. I
BELIEVE OTHER PANELISTS HAD
DISCUSSED- DISCUSSED A COUPLE
OPTIONS INCLUDING PERFORMANCE
SPACE PERMITS I BELIEVE THIS IS
A TECHNIQUE THAT SOME PLAYED BY
SANTA MONICA WITH SOME SUCCESS-
WE WOULD ENCOURAGE LIKE WHEN
USING PERFORMANCE BASED PERMITS
THAT. GOOD ACTORS ARE REPORTED.
AS WE WERE LOCK TO BIKE
REQUIREMENTS THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT OFFICIALS FROM SAN
FRANCISCO REALLY EMPHASIZED-
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT OUR JUMP
BIKES HOWEVER- HAVE A TRUE
LOCKING DESIGN- WHICH HELPS
KEEP THE CITY'S. STREETS
ORDERLY AND SAFE. I ALSO REALLY
SUPPORT RIGHT SIZE FLEETS TO
AVOID OVERCROWDING ISSUE AND
IMPLEMENTING TRIP OPTIMIZE FLEA
CAPS. THIS IS THE APPROACH THAT
WE'VE SEEN IN PLACES LIKE
WASHINGTON DC. ONE MINUTE.
WE'RE ALSO USING TECHNOLOGY TO
PILE INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS LIKE
SIDEWALK DETECTION AND MAPPING
SO WE CAN IMPROVE THE
LIMITATIONS OF GPS AND CREATE A
MEANINGFUL FEEDBACK LOOP TO
USERS ABOUT RIPRAP WRITING
BEHAVIOR. WE CAN ALSO DRAW ON
OUR EXPERIENCE NOW IN THE
TRANSPORTATION INDUSTRY FOR
EXAMPLE WE ALREADY HAVE
COMPREHENSIVE INSURANCE
POLICIES WE FOLLOW ALL LOCAL
STATE AND FEDERAL INSURANCE AN
INDEMNITY REQUIREMENTS. AND WE
SUPPORT HOLDING OPERATORS
FINANCIALLY ACCOUNTABLE FOR
ACCIDENTS AND PERSONAL INJURY
ARISING FROM THEIR OWN AND
NEGLIGENCE. LASTLY OVER AND
GENTLY SURE MY CREDIBILITY CAN
OFFER VALUABLE DATA IN INSIDE
TO CITIES AND OTHER PARTNERS-
THAT IMPROVE SAFETY AND INFORM
INFRASTRUCTURE AND TRANSIT
PLANNING. AND COURAGE OFTEN USE
OF THESE MOBILITY DEVICES. WE
ALSO SUPPORT UNIFORM DATA
SHARING TO STANDARDS FOR CITIES
TO RECEIVE TIMELY AGGREGATED
DATA SO THAT THEY CAN RESPOND
WHEN TRAFFIC PATTERNS HUMAN
BEHAVIOR AND TRENDS CHANGE.
HOWEVER WE DO NOT SUPPORT THE
DIRECTION WE'VE SEEN IN SOME
CITIES THAT REQUIRES REAL TIME
LOCATION DATA FROM WRITERS. ON
A TRIP AS A CONDITION OF THE
PERMIT. WHEN THE ITY HAS THE
ABILITY TO FIGURE OUT OF A
CERTAIN SET A SENATE'S TAKING A
CERTAIN DEVICE IN A CERTAIN
LOCATION THE VERY MINUTE THAT
THEY DO. AND THEN ALL THE
PLACES THAT THEY GO ALONG THE
WAY WE ARE CONCERNED. AS OUR
PRIVACY GROUPS. THIS IS A
REALLY COMPLICATED AND NEW AREA
OF THE LAW AND WE'D REALLY
ENCOURAGE THIS COMMITTEE TO
TAKE THE TIME TO SLOW DOWN AND
UNDERSTAND ALL THE NUANCES HERE.
BOTH CALIFORNIA LAW AND ACTO
DEFINED LOCATION AS PERSONALLY
IDENTIFIABLE DATA AND THAT
REQUIRES DEDICATED PROTECTIONS.
WE TAKE THIS SERIOUSLY AND WE
REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
COMMITTEES. IN THE COMING YEAR.
WE MUST CAPITALIZE ON THE A
UNLIMITED BENEFITS OF MY
CAMILLUS STANDS TO PROVIDE TO
FUTURE GENERATIONS. A SHARED
ZERO ZERO EMISSION RELIABLE
EFFICIENT AND AFFORDABLE
TRANSPORTATION OPTION. THERE
WERE THERE ARE AND WILL BE
CHALLENGES THAT A LOT ARISE
ALONG THE WAY. BUT WE A TRUMP
AND UBER FUNDAMENTALLY BELIEVE
THAT MIKE MOBILITY OPERATORS I
GOVERNMENTS CAN MAKE GREAT
STRIDES AT REDUCING CONESTION
AND SLASHING EMISSIONS BY
PRACTICALLY WORKING TOGETHER.
THANK YOU I LOOK FORWARD TO
ANSWERING QUESTIONS WE HAVE
THANK YOU SO MUCH APPRECIATE
THAT WE'RE NOT GOING TO TURN
OVER TO OUR LAST ANALYST OF THE
DAY. CRYSTAL AND PAST PRESIDENT
OF THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS A
CALIFORNIA STOLE AS GOOD AS
HE'S HER FOUR STORES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO BOTH THE CHAIRS IN
THOSE. ARE HERE TODAY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR THE BILL THAT'S BEEN
PUT FORTH. IT'S INTERESTING BUT
THE LAST TO SPEAK IS THE ONE
WHO IS WORRIED ABOUT THE
WRITER. AND I THINK THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
IS NOT LOST IN THIS. THERE'S
BUT YOU KNOW AND WE HEARD THAT
THEY WANT TO BOUNCE BETWEEN
INDUSTRY. OF GOVERNMENT. AND
PRIVATE. INDUSTRY GOVERNMENT
AND PRIVATE ENTITIES YES BUT
THAT BOUNCE NEEDS TO INCLUDE
SAFETY AND PROTECTION TO THOSE
WHO ARE USING THEM. AND I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
WE'RE NOT DEALING WITH MOM AND
POP ORGANIZATIONS. WE'RE
DEALING WITH LEFT WE'RE DEALING
WITH UBER. I WAS PERSONALLY
INVOLVED IN THE NEGOTIATIONS
AND THE DRAFTING OF THE TNC
BILL THAT RELATED TO INSURANCE
I WAS HERE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT MAKING SURE THAT WE GOT A
DEAL DONE. I KNOW HOW THAT
SAUSAGE WAS MADE WE HEARD THE
SAME ARGUMENTS THAT WE'RE
HEARING NOW WHEN WE HEARD ABOUT
DNC'S INSURANCE IS GOING TO
STYMIE THE INDUSTRY WE'RE GOING
TO BE SOMEHOW RESTRICTED IF WE
HAVE TO BE- REQUIRED TO FOLLOW
LEGISLATION OR WE HAVE TO BE
REQUIRED TO FOLLOW RULES. WE
SAW THE EXACT SAME BEHAVIOR
HERE THAT WE SAW WITH PNC'S
DUMP THEM ON THE STREET THEN
ASK FOR REGULATION LATER. THIS
IS NOT NEW THIS IS JUST A NEW
FORM OF TRANSPORTATION
TRANSPORTATION IS NOT NEW. WHAT
WE ARE SEEING WITH THE
STATISTICS IS THAT 55% OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE INJURED ON THESE
THINGS ARE INJURED WITH HEAD
INJURIES. WHERE DO THESE PEOPLE
GO WE'RE HEARING THAT THESE ARE
MANY FOLKS WHO HAVE LOWER
INCOME. THEY WIND UP IN THE
CITY'S EMERGENCY ROOMS THEY
WIND UP SEEKING MEDICARE NOW SO
WHO IS PAYING FOR THE COST THE
TRUE COST OF THE USE OF THESE
ITEMS WHEN PEOPLE ARE INJURED.
THE TAXPAYERS ARE NOT THE
COMPANIES WHO ARE FORWARDING
THIS TYPE OF A SERVICE IN THERE
IN THE BEST POSITION TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE IS INSURANCE TO
COVER INJURY TO PERSONS. WHO
ARE USING THESE DEVICES BY
HAVING A SMALL SURCHARGE ON
WHATEVER THERE IS THE COST THIS
IS NOT NEW THIS IS HAPPENED FOR
EVER WE HAVE MINIMUM INSURANCE
REQUIREMENTS ON CARS THIS IS
JUST ANOTHER FORM OF A VEHICLE.
INDEED WE NOW HAVE I SAW TODAY
THE BIRD IS RENTING THESE BY
THE MONTH. SO THIS IS NOT JUST
LAST MILE TRANSPORTATION BUT
FOR TWENTY FOUR NINETY NINE YOU
CAN RENT ONE OF THESE SCOOTERS
EXCLUSIVELY FOR A MONTH. I KNOW
OF NO CAR RENTAL AGENCY THAT
WOULD SEEK THE BENEFITS THE
PROTECTION OF THEIR CONTRACTS
WHICH INCLUDES THE FOLLOWING.
LIMITATION OF LIABILITY UP TO
ONE HUNDRED DOLLARS. A
RESTRICTION IN A WAIVER OF
LIABILITY EVEN IF THEIR DEVICE
CATCHES ON FIRE IN YOUR HOME.
IF THE DEVICE FALLS APART WHICH
WE'VE SEEN A NUMBER OF
HANDLEBARS COME OFF OF PEOPLE
SUFFERING HEAD INJURIES WE SAW
A LONGTIME PULLING THESE THINGS
OFF THE STREET BECAUSE THEY
WERE CATCHING FIRE IN PEOPLE'S
HOMES AND WE SAW BREAKING
MALFUNCTIONS WHERE PEOPLE WERE
GOING HEAD OVER HEELS. AND
SUFFERING SERIOUS INJURIES THE
WAY THEIR CONTRACTS ARE WRITTEN
RIGHT NOW A COMPLETE WAIVER AND
RELEASE OF LIABILITY AGAINST
THEM EVEN IF IT'S THEIR PRODUCT
THAT FAILS WITH A HUNDRED
DOLLAR CAPON LIABILITY. SO YES
THERE NEEDS TO BE A BALANCE BUT
THAT BALANCE CAN'T LEAVE OUT
THE CONSUMER WHO MAY BE HURT IN
THE COST IT WILL HAVE ON THE
GOVERNMENT. THESE ARE CAUSING
REAL LIFE THREATENING INJURIES
AND SO WHEN REGULATION YES
NEEDS TO HAPPEN BUT WHEN WE'RE
LOOKING AT REGULATION THAT
AFFECTS THE CONSUMER IN THIS
WAY IT HAS TO HAPPEN ON THE
STATE LEVEL. IT CAN HAPPEN ON
THE INDIVIDUAL LEVEL WE HEAR
COSTA BECOME PROHIBITIVE WE
HEARD THAT THE COSTS TRIPLED
BUT THAT'S BECAUSE THE COST IS
PROBABLY INITIALLY VERY LOW TO
ENCOURAGE ADOPTION. WE HAVE OF
THE VARIOUS CITIES THAT ARE
REQUIRING INSURANCE AND IT'S
NOT PROHIBITED ANY ENTRANCE
FROM THIS MARKET OR PEOPLE WHO
ARE ACTUALLY- USING THESE OR
BUSINESSES THAT ARE ALLOWING
THEM. SO JUST A FEW THINGS THAT
ARE IN EACH ONE OF THEIR
AGREEMENTS. NO CLASS ACTIONS
HANDLE DOWN IN LOS ANGELES
ATTORNEYS FEES FOR. THE WINNER.
OF A RELEASE OF LIABILITY
INCLUDING ALL AFFILIATES
MANUFACTURERS AND SUPPLIERS OF
THE VEHICLES IN THEIR PARTS.
THE WAIVER OF ANY MUNICIPAL-
LIABILITY AND A COMPLETE
ASSUMPTION OF THE RISK. SO WHAT
WE'RE HEARING AND THESE THINGS
ARE LIKE JUMPING OUT OF PLANES
ARE THESE THINGS ARE SOMEHOW
RECREATION DEVICE I LISTEN
CAREFULLY TO YOUR- COMMENTS
ABOUT HOW THEY'RE BEING USED I
LIVE IN SAN FRANCISCO. THESE
ARE BEING USED FOR
TRANSPORTATION. AND THE
MAJORITY OF PEOPLE ARE NOT
WEARING HELMETS THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT THAT THEY WEAR A
HELMET. INDEED THERE'S NOTHING
THAT THE COMPANIES DO TO MAKE
SURE THEY WEAR A HELMET BY
EVENING USING WHAT WE HAVE NOW
WHICH IS FACIAL RECOGNITION
SOFTWARE. IT'S BEING USED
ACROSS THE BOARD AND OTHER
THINGS. SO WHO'S GOING TO PICK
UP THE BILL FOR THEIR
ADVANCEMENT IN TECHNOLOGY THE
BOUNCING THE BALANCING THAT
THEY'RE SEEING. IT IS THE
STATE. IT IS THE STATE THE
TAXPAYERS OF THE STATE. AND SO
THIS MUST BE SHARED THE
RESPONSIBILITY THE COST TO THE
CONSUMER INCLUDING THE HARMS
BECAUSE TO THEM. MUST BE SHARED
THROUGH REQUIREMENTS THAT DAY
BACK WHAT THEY'RE PUTTING ON
THE ROAD. THE THING NOT GET A
FREE. PASS IF THEY HAVE A
DEVICE IS CATHING ON FIRE.
THEY NOT BE ABLE TO WALK AWAY
IF THEY'RE AT THE HANDLE BARS
FALL OFF THE THING IN PEOPLE
ARE HITTING THEIR HEADS ON THE
PAVEMENT. I MEAN I'M I'M
HANDLING THESE CASES. I HANDLE
THE TNC CASES AND THANK GOD FOR
THE INSURANCE OF THE OR THAT
STATE WOULD BE HITTING SUCH A
HIGH COST WITH PROVIDING. FOR
THE CARE AND TREATMENT OF THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE BEING INJURED.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT THE
STATE NEEDS TO REGULATE. AND
PROVIDE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO PUT IN THE
FACT THEIR OWN SPECIFIC
REGULATIONS. BUT THE STATE
CANNOT ABDICATE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF THE TONE.
PLEASE ENTER THE COMMITTEE
WE'RE GONNA OPEN UP FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR A
START WITH CHAIR CHAIR FRAZIER
RUNNING AND GOT A VICE CHAIR
MORE LOCK. WITH A TO BE TO SEE
IF WE HAVE ANY OTHER
INDIVIDUALS. RESEARCH. WITH A-
BILL MISS RUBIO THANK YOU SO
MUCH. ALL RIGHT WHEATON SO
LET'S START WITH MR FRAZIER.
WILL GO TO MISTER MOORE LOCK
THEM UP AND GOING TO MISS RUBIO
PLEASE CHEN FRAZIER THANK YOU
MISTER- WHEN WE TALK ABOUT-
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT TO LIMITED
ACCESS CAN COMPARE OF LEE TO
TEEN SEASON ONE NOT. FOR THE
SCOOTERS. WITH THE ADVENT OF AB
FIVE COMING IN JANUARY FIRST
AND YOUR INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS TO PICK UP IN
CHARGE. PER UNIT. HOW THAT CAN
AFFECT YOUR. BOTTOM LINE AS FAR
AS TO THE CONSUMER NUMBER ONE
AND THE FLEXIBILITY THE NIGHT
YOU KNOW LOSE. I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THE IT'S A GREAT
QUESTION TO STAR IN MANY CITIES
WE ALREADY EMPLOYED ON FULL
TIME AND OR W. TO WORKERS- BE
GIVEN LOCAL PERMIT
REQUIREMENTS- IS AN EXAMPLE I
THINK OF HOUSES SOME CITIES CAN
PRIORITIZE- THEIR PARTICULAR
WHAT THEY SEE AS MOST
IMPORTANT. SECOND I THINK IS
THAT OUR USE OF GIVE WORKERS IS
VERY DIFFERENT THAN THAT OF AN
UBER DRIVER AND UBER DRIVERS IN
IN LARGE PART BECAUSE ARGUED
WORKERS PRIMARILY PICK UP
SCOOTERS ON THEIR WAY HOME FROM
WORK WERE ON THEIR WAY TO WORK
ON LONG THE WAY THERE ISN'T A
THERE'S A DEVICE THAT NEEDS TO
BE CHARGED THEY CAN PICK IT UP.
BRING IT HOME CHARGES AND THEN
ON THE WAY BACK TO WORK DROP IT
OFF AGAIN IT'S VERY DIFFERENT
THAN SOMEONE WHO RELIES ON IT
WHO STRIVE WHO'S THAT HEADING
AROUND ON THE SAN FRANCISCO
STREETS ALL DAY. AND THIRD I
THINK ON TO YOUR POINT IS AN
EXAMPLE OF THE FLEXIBILITY OF
THE YOU'RE RIGHT THAT IT DOES
LIMIT OUR FLEXIBILITY I THINK
THAT THERE ARE CERTAIN BENEFITS
AND DRAWBACKS TO DO SO TO DOING
SO NOW WE'VE EXPLORED LOCAL
CITIES. AS THEY PROMULGATE.
THEIR REGULATIONS RELATING TO
THE LABOR THAT WE CAN HIRE.
SHOW UP IN A TMELY MANNER
BECAUSE IT WAS ADDRESSED. AND
THERE WAS A COMPETITIVE NATURE
THERE PUT HOW DOES THAT NOW
CHANGE. THE CURRENTLY WE USE W.
TO WORK FORCE WE USE A LOT OF
STAFFING AGENCIES AND WE ALSO
HAVE EMPLOYEES A RECORD WHERE
WHERE THE EMPLOYER OF RECORD
AND THAT'S NOT GONNA CHANGE. SO
IT'LL BE. SAME THING. CATHERINE
YOU'VE GOT NO EMPOWER HAVE ANY
YEAH WE DON'T HAVE ANY W. TWO
OR A TEN NINETY NINE WORKERS IN
THE JUMPS SMOKER. AND FOR YOU
SIR WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE- THE
EFFORTS IN THE SAUSAGE MAKING
COMPONENT OF THE TEENS HE'S- AS
SENATOR BLL AND TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER TODAY ADDRESSING THE
ADA- WE SEE. A LIMITED AMOUNT
OF EFFORTS BEING PUT TOWARDS
THE PARA TRANSIT COMPONENT. OF
THE TEAM IN SEASON WONDER WHAT
YOU SAW WHEN YOU WERE IN THIS
COMPONENT LATE AT NIGHT. OF THE
EFFORTS THAT MADE SURE THAT
THERE WAS CONSTITUTIONALLY OF.
THE EFFORTS MADE ON BEHALF OF
THE CONSTITUTION THAT.
RELATIVELY NOTHING YOU'RE ON
NOTHING I'M SORRY SAY YOUR
HONOR AND CECIL RECORD. OF THE
PROMOTION BUT THANK YOU THERE
IS SOMETHING I'D LIKE TO HANG
OUT AND AS YOUR PREVIOUS
QUESTION AS IT RELATED TO-
COSTS IN IMPACTS AND NO TEN
NINETY NINE WORKERS. I THINK
WHAT THE COMMITTEE NEEDS TO%
KNOW IS THAT HOW ARE THESE
DEVICES MAINTAINED AND
INSPECTED THE ART. THERE PICKED
UP BY PEOPLE YOU SAW A PICTURE
OF SOMEBODY WITH TEN SCOOTERS
ON ON ON A BIKE THEY'RE BROUGHT
HOME THEY'RE PLUGGED IN IN
THOSE PEOPLE GET PAID PER
SCOOTER. I DON'T THINK THAT
THEIR EMPLOYEES I DON'T KNOW IF
THEY'RE TEN NINETY NINE I DOUBT
THEIR W. TWOS BUT THEY'RE BEING
PAID BUT THEY ARE NOT REQUIRED
TO INSPECT OR MAINTAIN THESE
DEVICES NOR IS THERE ANY
SCHEDULE FOR DOING SO. SO YOU
HAVE DEVICES THAT ARE OUT THERE
THAT ARE BEING AS YOU HEARD
THROWN ON THE SIDEWALK COST
OVER FENCES THROWN INTO LAKES
BUT THERE'S NOTHING THAT'S IN
ANY REGULATIONS REQUIRING ANY
TYPE OF INSPECTION AND THEY GET
A COMPLETE WAIVER AND RELEASE
OF LIABILITY EVEN IF THEY
DON'T. INSPECTOR MAINTAIN THEIR
DEVICES. THANK YOU FOR THAT WHO
ISN'T ME. UNDER MORE MONEY TO
MISTER FOO FOR- BEING HERE I
JUST WANT TO ASK YOU A FEW
QUESTIONS BUT KIND OF REVIEWING
ALL THE MATERIAL- I GOT THE
SENSE THAT. ARE JUMPING ON A
SCOOTER IS SORT OF LIKE SNOW
SKIING WHICH I'VE DONE FOR
ABOUT. SIX DECADES BUT YOU HAVE.
BEGINNER INTERMEDIATE EXPERTEN
I'M JUST WONDERING. IF DO YOU
GIVE. SOMEONE WHO HAS NEVER
WRITTEN ONE BEFORE WHO IS CAN
BE A LITTLE NERVOUS ABOUT SPEED
MEANS AND STOPPING AND ALL THE
REST DO YOU GIVE THEM LIKE THE
FIRST MYLAR TO FREEZE SO THEY
CAN KIND OF. FIELD. A LITTLE
MORE RELAXED ABOUT LEARNING HOW
TO PROPERLY. FLOW WITH TRAFFIC
FEDERAL AID I THINK WE HAVE
SOMETHING THAT'S SOME SOMETHING
EVEN BETTER THAN THAT THAT
WE'RE WORKING ON ACTIVELY RIGHT
NOW WHICH IS THE ON WHEN
SOMEONE'S WHEN SOMEONE'S TAKING
THEIR FIRST RIDE AN OPTION TO
ENABLE WHAT WHAT YOU COULD CALL
BEGIN REMOTE SAYS THAT YOU
LIMIT YOUR ACCELERATION SPEED
AND THEN RUN OPTION TO COULD
KEEP IT ON IF YOU FEEL IF YOU
FEEL IT'S NECESSARY OR TURN IT
OFF- I THINK IT'S A IT'S A
SIMPLE WAY I THINK THAT WERE
WORKING ON TO TRY TO ALLEVIATE
WHILE OTHERS HAVE POINTED OUT
WHICH IS THE ON YOUR VERY FIRST
EXPERIENCE ARE OBVIOUSLY MORE
LIKELY TO HAVE- HAVE AN
INCIDENT ON. THAN AS A SEASONED
PRO HOW STRICTER YOU ON THE
WEIGHT REQUIREMENT I UNDERSTAND
IT'S TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
POUNDS OR LESS. THE IT'S NOT
LIKE IT'S NOT AS THOUGH THERE'S
A SENSOR WITHIN THE SCOOTER
THAT WILL KICK YOU OFF OF YOUR
OVER. OVER WAY I THINK THE WE I
DON'T THINK I'M OVERWEIGHT.
CERTAINLY CERTAINLY NOT SENATOR
NO I'M. BUT A THE I JUST I JUST
KIND OF I I'M- BY COULD LOSE
SOME WEIGHT THANK YOU MISTER
TRUE BUT- BY MAY NOT BE
ELIGIBLE TO USE YOUR SCOOTER
AND I WAS KIND OF FEELING LEFT
OUT. THE GOODBYE WITH. ARE YOU.
AS SURE AS YOU'RE GROWING AS
YOU'RE DEALING WITH ALL THESE
MUNICIPALITIES STATES ARE ARE
YOU COMING TO A- MAY BE AN
INTERNAL. REALIZATION THAT
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO HAVE SOME
MINIMAL. LEVEL OF THE OF
STANDARDIZATION FOR EVERYONE SO
YOU'RE NOT DEALING WITH EVERY
DIFFERENT CITY. EVERY EVERY DAY
OF THE WEEK BUT IF WE HAD A
MINIMUM STANDARD ARE YOU ARE
YOU DEVELOPING THAT ARE YOU
READY TO MAYBE PROVIDE
SOMETHING THAT WOULD. RESOLVE A
LOT OF THESE CONCERNS. CENTER
MORE LIKE- TO BE TO BE HONEST
YES I THINK IT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE HAVE THOUGHT ABOUT A LOT
WHICH IS THAT THERE WE HAVE A
LOT OF DIFFERENT OPERATIONAL
KARMA SO ALL OF OUR CITIES. WE
DON'T THINK THAT WE DON'T
EXPECT TO EVER GET RID OF THAT
WE PRICE THAT WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT EVERY CITY BE
ABLE TO DETERMINE FOR ITSELF
FOR INSTANCE THAT THE VENICE
CANALS FOR INSTANCE ARE OFF
LIMITS OR THIS OTHER
NEIGHBORHOOD IS A NO PARKS ON.
I DON'T THINK THAT THAT'S AN
APPROPRIATE PLACE FOR THE STATE
TO STEP IN WHERE I DO THINK IT
IS MORE APPROPRIATE FOR THE
STATE TO SEVEN WILL BE ON
ISSUES THAT RELATE TO. THE
ADOPTION OF MY PROBABILITY
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA MORE
GENERALLY THAT AREN'T.
NECESSARILY LOCALITY SPECIFIC.
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS FOR COMING. THE QUESTION
A THAT I'M INTERESTED IN IT IS
I'M GONNA. IS GONNA COME UP
AGAIN AND AGAIN FOR ME. ABOUT
THE AMERICAN DISABILITIES ACT
AND WHETHER OR NOT HERE IS ANY
ENFORCEABLE METHOD OR MECHANISM.
TO PREVENT. DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST PEOPLE WITH JUST
VARIOUS TYPES OF DISABILITIES
AND THEN. THE CIVIL RIGHTS
ASPECTS RELATES TO THE
NEIGHBORHOODS AND WHERE YOU
LIVE AND HOW YOU PROTECT FROM
OF DISCRIMINATION. ESTáN
LOCATION OF THESE THESE
TRANSPORTATION DEVICES SO I I'M
INTERESTED NON I'M INTERESTED
IN WHAT YOUR OPINION IS ON
HELMETS. SHOULD THEY BE
REQUIRED IS THERE ANY KIND OF
SAFETY STUDIES. OF SPECIAL WE
USE PUBLIC FUNDS IN TERMS OF-
IF IT'S A- PART OF THE MICRO
MOBILITY. PARTNERSHIP WITH A
PUBLIC AGENCY A TRANSIT
AGENCIES SAY LIKE- LIKE IN SAN
JOSE THERE'S A LOT OF ROOM
LOCATED NEXT TO OUR- MALLS ARE
TRAIN STATION HERE ALSO WHAT
HAPPENS IS PEOPLE GET OFF THE
TRAIN THE HOP ON THOSE THINGS
AND THEY GO. TO THE SAN JOSE
STATE OR WHATEVER YOU KNOW A
LOT OF ROOM FOR STUDENTS YOU
KNOW FOR EXAMPLE THAT'S WHAT.
WHAT HAPPENS EVERY DAY. IT'S A
ROOM. JUST GOING UP TO STREET
TO SAN JOSE STATE UNIVERSITY
WHERE WE HAVE LIKE FORTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS SO AND- I'M
IT I'M INTERESTED IN YOUR YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THAT BECAUSE I
THINK. I THINK YOUR ARM. IT
COULD BE A BENEFIT TO HAVE OF.
YOU KNOW A PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP TO AID PEOPLE IN
TERMS OF TRANSPORTATION YES OF
SUPPORT AT THE OTHER HAND. I
DON'T SEE ANY EXCEPTIONS IN MY
THINKING TO THE CIVIL RIGHTS.
ASPECTS I CAN'T YOU KNOW
HONESTLY WITH PUBLIC FUNDS
THEY'RE JUST. THERE'S NO WAY WE
CAN. REGULATE YOUR CONTROL YOU
WITHOUT A KIND OF CIVIL RIGHTS.
SUPPOSITION. THE CITY OF SAN
JOSE AYE AYE A I WAS ON THE
COUNCIL. I GOT ELECTED TO THE
COUNCIL. AND A IBM OR REAR
ACTUALLY REPLACE ME AS A MEMBER
OF THE PLANNING COMMISSION I
WAS A PLANNING COMMISSION FOR
FOUR YEARS AGO ON A COUNCIL IN
A WE APPOINTED A GENTLEMAN
FROM- THE EVERGREEN AREA SAN
JOSE'S NAME WAS FRANKLIN WEST.
AND HIS SON IS NOW. SO I'M I'M
KIND OF INTERESTED WITH FRANK
WESS WOULD HAVE SET. ABOUT THE
SUBJECT. AS ONE OF MY PLANNING
COMMISSIONERS THAT I WORK WITH
IN SAN JOSE IN THOSE DAYS- SO
IT IS CAN YOU RESPOND TO THOSE
QUESTIONS I'M VERY CURIOUS AS
TO HOW YOU WOULD APPROACH THOSE
ISSUES SURE- SO FOR THE RECORD
I DON'T THINK WE CONSIDER
OURSELVES AS EXAM FROM EIGHTY
EIGHT WE DO A LOT TO RESPOND TO
PARKING COMPLAINTS WERE WE
MIGHT BE BLOCKING SIDEWALK OR
OTHER AREAS OF ACHERAL ACCESS-
WE DO THINGS LIKE RE BALANCE WE
SEND PEOPLE OUT TO GRAB SKATERS
HAVE BEEN MISS PARK TERM BIKES
AT MYSTIC. BEEN MESSED PARKED-
WE'VE INTEGRATED WITH THREE ONE
ONE SO PEOPLE CAN CALL AND
LEAVE NOTES WITH THE CITY OF
THE PASS ALONG TO US- WE ALSO
OF EXPERIMENTAL WITH OFFERING
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES TO
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO DO THE
RIGHT THING IN THE FIRST PLACE
PARK IN THE RIGHT SPOT WE
SUPPORT THINGS LIKE LOCKED TO
TECHNOLOGY. SO PEOPLE ARE IN
FURNITURE DOWN THERE NOT THE
MIDDLE THE RIGHT AWAY. THINGS
LIKE EDUCATION. ALSO DOING
THINGS LIKE FINANCIAL
DISINCENTIVES FINES- AND THEN
WE'RE DEVELOPING TECHNOLOGY
WE'RE DEVELOPING THINGS LIKE
SIDEWALK DETECTION LOCALIZATION
TECHNOLOGY WERE YOU ARE
PARTNERING WITH CITIES ON THAT.
BEING VERY TRANSPARENT THE
LIKE. YOU KNOW JUST. STOP THEIR
BLOCKING THE RAMPS ON THE
SIDEWALKS. PUTTING THEM IN
FRONT OF THE BUS STOPS YOU KNOW
THE BUT YOU KNOW THE- THE
TRANSIT AREAS WHERE PEOPLE
WERE. TRYING TO GET ACCESS TO
THE- ONE SOURCE OF MOBILITY
WHICH IS THE PUBLIC TRANSIT
SYSTEM THEY DON'T HAVE ANY
OTHER CHOICE BECAUSE THEY'RE
TRANSIT DEPENDENT SO THEY. YOU
KNOW IF THERE IF THERE DOESN'T
SEEM TO BE ANY. POSSIBLE WAY
THE DROPPED THE THINGS IN A
CERTAIN LOCATION HONOR IS OUR
WAY OF. DINNER FIND THE
CULPRITS THE. YOU KNOW DO
SOMETHING THAT WOULD TO ME
WOULD BE A CAN TO SOMEBODY
PARKING AND- DISABLED PARKING
SPACE IT ALSO YOU KNOW YOU ARE
MADE A SORT OF A DISABILITY ACT
I I'M I'M KIND OF LIKE I DON'T
KNOW THE ANSWER TO THIS BUT I
THINK. I WANT TO FIGURE IT OUT
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT OPINIONS OR.
NO I WE WANT TO SHARE WE WANT
TO FIGURE IT OUT ALONG WITH YOU
ALONG WITH OUR CITY PARTNERS
AND I THINK THEY'RE AT THIS
STAGE THERE ISN'T ANY ONE RIGHT
ANSWER I THINK THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF- LOCALIZE AND THERE'S
JUST ISN'T A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
ANSWER RIGHT. NOW IF I MAY.
ABOUT GEO FENCING JUST AWHILE
AGO REMEMBER HEARING ABOUT THAT
SERGIO FENCING MEANS YOU CAN
SET UP A BORDER AROUND CERTAIN
AREAS TO MONITOR THE ACTIVITY
THERE IS A POSSIBILITY TO
REQUIRE THAT THE SCOOTER IN
ORDER TO END THE RIDE BE PUT
WITHIN A GEO FENCED AREA IN SAN
FRANCISCO WE SEE THESE LYING ON
THE GROUND AND WE SEE ELDERLY
PEOPLE HAVING AND NAVIGATE THEM
AND TRIP OVER THEM. THERE LEFT
RANDOMLY AT THE RAMPS WERE THE
HANDICAPPED PEOPLE HAVE TO GET
UP AND DOWN THE BIRD I THINK IT
IS IF IT FALLS OVER ON ITS SIDE
IT BEEPS SO THERE'S A WAY THAT
THEY MAY KNOW AND DE THAT
THROUGH THEIR OWN TECHNOLOGY IS
THE THING ON THE SIDE BUT I DO
BELIEVE THERE IS A WAY TO
ADDRESS THE ADA ISSUES ARE
STOCKS. BUT THERE COULD BE NO
THIS LIKE THE FIRST IS THE
COVERED BUT STOPS WHERE PEOPLE
WERE TRYING TO GET AND THEY
HAVE SPOTS FOR PEOPLE THE WHEEL
THEMSELVES IN A WAY FOR THEIR
BUS. AND THEN I SEE WHERE THE.
WHAT IS THE PARK THEY JUST
DON'T THESE THINGS AND- IT
SHOULD JUST TO ME I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY PEOPLE WOULD DO
THAT YOU KNOW IT'S LIKE BUT- IT
HAPPENS YOU KNOW SO. THAT'S I
AM THIS IS DISTURBING OKAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SOONER BUT I
THINK THE HAVE BEEN KEEPING
TRACK ON FILE IF YOU TO FOLLOW
UP HERE IN ONE OF THE ITEMS
THAT CENTER BELL AND AS SOON
FRASIER'S BUT EVEN FOCUSING IN
ON IS OF ONE EXCESS ABILITY. ON
THE DEVICES INTO ENSURING THAT
PUBLIC SPACES ARE FREE AND
CLEAR OF- ANY POTENTIAL CHIP
HAZARDS OR BLOCKING ACCESS OR
MOBILITY SO WE HAVE THAT IS A.
ONE BOLDED FOLLOW UP ITEM
SUGGEST VERY VERY GRATEFUL FOR
THAT. MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO BE
TO TURN IT OVER TO THE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN FRIEDMAN AND THEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI
CINNAMON FORESHORES. YOU'RE
JUST A TWO QUESTIONS QUICKLY
FIRST FOR MISTER DOLE AND I'M
JUST CURIOUS SO WHEN I RIDE. MY
BIKE WHICH GOES A LOT FASTER.
THAN A SCOOTER CAM. IF I RIDE
MY HORSE WHO'S A LOT BIGGER
GOES FASTER AND IS MUCH
STUPIDER THAN A SCOOTER I DON'T
HAVE TO WEAR A HELMET BY LAW.
ON EITHER OF THOSE CASES SO I'M
JUST CURIOUS I UNDERSTAND THE
PEOPLE OF HEAD INJURIES FROM A
SCOOTER SURVIVE BY USED ONE I
MEAN IRA WHICH IS THE HOME OF
MY WORSE I ALWAYS USE IT ON A
BIKE I. I DON'T KNOW IF I ISN'T
AS GOOD OR NOT- BUT LEGALLY I
DON'T HAVE TO AND THOSE OTHER
TWO. THAT TYPES OF MOBILITY AND
THEY'RE CERTAINLY HEAD INJURIES
WITH THOSE TWO SO I'M JUST
WONDERING WHY YOU KEEP COMING
BACK. TO THE HELMET ISSUE. IS
IT BECAUSE YOU THINK THEY'RE
MORE DANGEROUS ARE MORE PRONE
THAN BICYCLES TO HEAD INJURIES
OR IS IT BECAUSE THEY'RE
RENTALS AND YOU THINK THAT
SOMEHOW. THAT SHOULD COMPEL
PEOPLE. ADULTS TO WEAR HELMETS
EVEN THOUGH THEY DON'T HAVE TO.
ON BICYCLES OR OTHER TYPES OF
DEVICES. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION. YOU ON YOUR HORSE YOU
ON YOUR BIKE. YOU KNOW HOW THAT
THEIR MAINTAINED YOU KNOW HOW
THE HORSES FED WHETHER IT'S
LAME. YOU WATCH YOUR BIKE YOU
INSPECT YOUR BIKE. THEREFORE
YOU HAVE MORE CONTROL OVER YOUR
BIKE. I WAS A MOTORCYCLIST
UNTIL I HAD A CATASTROPHIC
MOTORCYCLE ACCIDENT SIX YEARS
AGO. STATE OF CALIFORNIA
REQUIRED ME TO WEAR A HELMET.
THE REASON BEING THERE IS A
GREATER PROPENSITY FOR INJURY
TO MY HEAD. BY USING THAT FORM
OF TRANSPORTATION. THESE
SCOOTERS HAVE VERY SMALL
WHEELS. YOUR BICYCLE HAS A
LARGE WHEEL. WHEN YOU GO OVER A
CRACK IN PAVEMENT- A POTHOLE.
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO BE THROWN
FROM YOUR BICYCLE BECAUSE
THERE'S A GREATER AREA OF
SURFACED IT'S TOUCHING THE
GROUND OKAY SO YOU. YOU THINK
THAT THE SCOOTERS THAN THAT
THERE'S DATA THAT THEY ARE
INHERENTLY. MORE UNSTABLE OR
MORE DANGEROUS AND I I'VE I'VE
ACTUALLY HEARD THE SAME THING
SO I'M NOT ARGUING WITH YOU.
BUT SO IT'S NOT ABOUT THEM
BEING A RENTAL NECESSARILY THAT
YOU THINK THAT THEY ARE. MORE
DANGEROUS THAN A BICYCLE AND
THEREFORE MORE. THERE SHOULD
BE. SORT OF HIGHER SAFETY
STANDARDS. FOR THE USER THAT'S
CORRECT. AND YOU THINK IF YOU
OWN YOUR- YOUR SCOOTER YOU
SHOULD ALSO HAVE TO WEAR A
HELMET. PERSONALLY YES. OKAY
THIS BECAUSE MY ARMY GOT IT. I
THANK YOU MY NEXT QUESTION IS
FOR. THE TWO OF YOU. SO WE'VE
HEARD A LOT FROM THE CITIES
THAT WERE HERE ABOUT THEIR
NEED. TO HAVE DATA ABOUT TRIPS.
AND HAVING BEEN IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT I THINK THEY'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THAT THEY
CAN'T PLAN. SCOOTERS THEY CAN'T
REGULATE THEM THEY CAN'T DO
WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT TIE
THEM IN WITH- THEIR TRANSIT AND
MAKE THEM USEFUL WITHOUT HAVING
VERY SPECIFIC DATA ABOUT WHERE
PEOPLEARE TAKING THEM AND WHEN
THEY'RE USING THEM. AND YET YOU
HAVE FOUGHT THE EFFORTS FOR ME
AND FROM OTHERS TO HAVE THAT
KIND OF DATA PROVIDED TO THE
CITIES. SO WHERE IS THAT LINE
FOR YOU WHAT DO YOU THINK IS
REASONABLE TO BE SHARED WITH
THE CITIES. OF WHO RIGHT NOW
ARE UNABLE TO DO THE PLANNING
THAT THEY NEED TO DO- TO MAKE
THAT TEIR CONGESTION BETTER TO
TIE THEIR TRANSPORTATION AND
WITH. WITH WHAT YOU SAY IS
SUPPOSED TO BE THE USE OF YOUR
PRODUCT WHICH IS TO SOLVE FIRST
MILE LAST MILE TO SOLVE
TRANSPORTATION. THERE'D BE
THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO GET THAT
DATA. ARE FROM YOU INCIDENT
LARGE CITIES MIGHT BE ABLE TO.
TO LEVERAGE- GETTING THE DATA
FROM YOU ON THEIR OWN BUT THE
SMALLER CITIES CANNULAS HELL NO
WE'RE NOT GIVING IT YOU WOULD
JUST ONE OPERATE. SO WHAT IS
THE LINE FOR YOU HOW MUCH DATA
SHOULD YOU BE REQUIRED UNDER
THE LAW TO PROVIDE TO THE TUNE
TO ME TOO FOR CITIES TO BE ABLE
TO REGULATE PROPERLY. AND TO-
GET THE BEST OUT OF YOUR
SERVICE AS POSSIBLE. THANK
HANK YOU SIMPLY WOMAN- I THINK
IT WAS PROFESSOR BUT TO SAY
THAT MENTIONED THAT SEVERAL
OTHER STATES HAD ALREADY
DRAFTED THIS- OUT OF KIND OF
SHOW FRAMEWORK. AND PROUD TO
SAY THAT THAT WAS WITH A LOT OF
INPUT FROM US AS TO WHAT THE
APPROPRIATE LINE SHOULD BE TO
WHAT IS WHAT IS THE LINE
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
YOU ON. FOR A YEAR NOW ON THIS
AND I HAVEN'T GOTTEN IT FROM
YOU I'VE GOTTEN AS- A LOT OF-
CONCERN FROM YOUR TECH
COMPANIES. ABOUT PRIVACY WHICH
IS A LITTLE BIT IRONIC- BUT%
THAT'S WHAT WE'VE BEEN HEARING
A LOT OF THAT WITH YOU KNOW
CITIES HAVE NO RIGHT TO HAVE
ANY OF THIS AND THEY- THEY
COULD. DO SOMETHING VERY
NEFARIOUS IF THEY HAD THE DATA
AND YET WE HAVE CITIES TELLING
US. THAT THEY CAN'T SOLVE ALL
THE PROBLEMS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT WITH THE DATA SO I'D I'D
LIKE TO KNOW FROM YOU WHAT IS
THAT BRIGHT WHAT IS THAT LINE.
I THINK FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
THE BRIGHT LINE IS THAT CITIES
ABSOLUTELY HAVE A RIGHT TO THE
DATA FROM OUR DEVICES ON THEIR
STREETS. AT THE SAME TIME OF
COURSE THERE ARE PRIVACY
CONSIDERATIONS THAT RELATE FROM
OUR WRITERS AND THE DEVICES
THAT THEY WRITE ON. BUT THAT
THAT THOSE TWO GOALS ARE NOT
INCOMPATIBLE IN THAT WITH THE
APPROPRIATE DATA PRIVACY
GOVERNANCE STANDARDS THAT IS TO
SAY ONCE THE CITY RECEIVES THE
DATA THEY ARE SUBJECT TO SOME
OF THE SAME DATA PRIVACY
CENTERS THAT WE ARE. THAT WE
DON'T SEE A PROBLEM WITH THAT
KIND OF THAT LEVEL DATA SHARING.
YES WE WOULD ECHO THAT TRIP
DATA IS PERSONAL DATA. WE DRAW
THE LINE WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
DATA BEING SURE THAT'S
ANONYMIZED AN AGGREGATED. AND
THAT CAN SOLVE ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT GOVERNMENT WANTS TO
DO ALL THE LEGITIMATE
REGULATORY GOALS. THIS IS NOT
TO STOP THOSE LEGITIMATE
REGULATORY GOALS IS TO PROTECT
DATA PRIVACY. PRESS CONSUMER
PRIVACY WE HAVE RESPONSIBILITY
TO DO THAT UNDER THE LAW. WHAT
ABOUT THE DATA OF WHERE THE
SCOOTERS ARE WHEN THERE'S NO
ONE ON IT. TO THE PEOPLE TO BE
ENTITLED TO. THAT OF ALL TIME
SO THAT THEY KNOW WHERE ALL
YOUR SCOOTERS ARE- THEY KNOW IF
THEY'RE BLOCKING THE DRIVEWAY
OR HANDICAP SPOT. YES THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN TRIP DATA
AND DEVICE DADDO. DEVICE THAT
IS THE OPERATIONAL DATA THAT
WOULD ALLOW CITIES TO COMPLETE
THE REGULATORY MISSIONS. TO SEE
WHAT IS IN THEIR- JURISDICTION.
MEET OUR REGULATORY CAPS THINGS-LIKE THAT. THE AGGREGATE BUT
NOT AGGREGATED SO MUCH THAT
THEY DON'T KNOW. EXACTLY WHERE
THEY'RE GOING. AND SORT OF WHEN
THEY'RE GOING RIGHT. CORRECT
THE WEEKEND IS A LIGHTLY
AGGREGATED DATA. LATELY
AGGREGATE LIGHTLY AGGREGATED
ENOUGH TO DRAW INSIGHTS. AND
VERY FOR YOU KNOW. GET DOWN TO.
CERTAIN GRANULARITY WITHOUT.
WHERE YOU'RE NOW STEPPING IN
VIOLATING USER PRIVACY IS WE
FELT THAT WE- HAD THAT IN OUR
BILL. AND YET YOU WERE STILL
OPPOSED. TO MAYBE NOT RIGHT NOW
BUT YOU CAN TELL US- YOU KNOW.
WHERE THAT LINE IS. WE'LL BE
HAPPY TO SHARE AND FOLLOW UP
AND LIKE WE SAID THAT WE REALLY
ENCOURAGE THE FULL COMMITTEE TO
DIVE INTO THIS ISSUE I KNOW YOU
GUYS ARE PLANNING TO. NEXT YEAR
IT'S A VERY. THANK YOU
TECHNICAL ISSUE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH ISN'T EVER. GOING TO GO TO
MR MASUCCI. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MISTER DOLE AND YOU
HIGHLIGHTED THE ISSUE. OF MANY
OF THESE. MOBILITY DEVICE
PROVIDERS HAVING- CONTRACTUAL
LIMITATIONS ON LIABILITY. I
HAVE A. TAKE BY ONE ASKED THE
REPRESENTATIVE A BIRD IS IT IS
IT I AM I CORRECT IN
UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU- THAT
BIRD DOES NOT HAVE SUCH A
LIMITATION OF LIABILITY WE
DON'T KERRY. FOR AS- JUMP WHICH
IS PROVIDED BY UBER- YOU DO
HAVE THE CONTRACTUAL-
LIMITATION OF LIABILITY OF A
HUNDRED DOLLARS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH IS MURATSUCHI
THE AND THAT WAS GONNA BE MY
NEXT QUESTION IS SAID- TO
LOOKING AT IN ISSUE IN REGARDS
TO LIABILITY AND I THINK
THAT'S- GOING TO BE AN ONGOING
CONCERN ESPECIALLY AT THAT.
ARTIFICIALLY LOW THRESHOLD
RIGHT UNDERSTAND THAT MAY BE
GOOD FOR THE COMPANY BUT- THERE
ARE GONNA BE CHALLENGES FOR THE
CONSUMERS AND THAT'S AN ISSUE
THAT WE'RE GONNA NEED TO BE
ABLE TO WORK OUT- AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. CLICK BACK TO WHERE-
AND I'M NOT GOING TO DO A DEEP
DIVE ON THIS BECAUSE WE HAVE. A
DATE A HEARING COMING UP. AFTER
THE FIRST PART OF THE YEAR. BUT
I WANT TO GO BACK TO WHERE THE
GENERAL MANAGER FROM. LOS
ANGELES. WAS AT. I IN REGARDS
TO SIX POINTS. AND ON. THE
INDIVIDUAL- TRIP. BECAME TWENTY
FOUR HOURS AFTER THE TRIP WAS
COMPLETED. IS THAT AN ISSUE. ON
THE SIX POINTED SHOULD MENTION
I THINK THAT LOOK- UNDERSTAND
WE ALL ANT TO BE ABLE TO GO IN
TO BE TO PROTECT PRIVACY RIGHT
AND OBVIOUSLY THERE NEED TO BE
SOME TYPE OF PRIVACY AGREEMENT
AS THERE ARE NOW RIGHT SO IT'S
NOT TO BE- OUT IN THE PUBLIC.
SPHERE BUT ALSO TRYING TO BE
ABLE TO ASSIST CITY SO. ON
THOSE SIX POINTS. THAT YOU
HEARD TODAY. THAT SEEM
REASONABLE SINCE IT'S ALREADY
IN UNDER AGREEMENT ANYWAY. IT
DOES I IN I THINK THAT WHAT
PART OF THE- PART OF IN MY
RESPONSE TO US TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN'S EMPHASIS WAS
THAT WE CARE WHAT HAPPENS TO
THE DATA AFTER THE CITY GETS
THE AFTER THE CITY GETS IT IS
IT- SUBSTITUTE IS THIS
SOMETHING THAT IS PROTECTED IS
A SOMETHING THE SUBJECT TO FOIL
OR OPEN RECORDS REQUESTS OR IS
THIS SOMETHING THAT IS
ESSENTIALLY AT AS ESSENTIALLY
UNPROTECTED.WE'VE
UNFORTUNATELY HAD NEGATIVE
EXPERIENCES WITH OTHER CITIES
NONE OF THE CITIES ON THIS
PANEL OF COURSE IT HAD NATIVE
EXPENSES ELSEWHERE AND THAT'S
OUR PRIMARY FOCUSED CAN I GET
AND I AND I GUESS I DON'T SEE
WHY IT CAN'T BE TREATED LIKE
FOR EXAMPLE CITY STREET BED TAX
FOR EXAMPLE RIGHT. SO BY TAX IS
NOT UNDER THE PUBLIC RECORDS
ACT REQUEST YOU CAN'T REQUESTED
BY CITIES GIVE IT OUT AS ONE
LARGE TOTAL ON A QUARTERLY
BASIS FOREVER THEY REPORTED BUT
THEY DON'T. GO INDIVIDUAL BY
INDIVIDUAL SO I. I JUST KNOW
THERE'S A SWEET SPOT IN THERE
TO BE ABLE TO. FIGURE THAT OUT.
PLEASE MA'AM YEAH I WOULD JUST
TRY TO. TURNED OUT IF THERE'S A
SPECTRUM BETWEEN YOU KNOW FULL
SELF REGULATION WHICH I THINK-WAS. A DISCUSSED EARLIER AND
THEN WHERE WE'RE AT WITH REAL
TIME TRIP INFORMATION I THINK
THERE'S A NICE MIDDLE GROUND.
IN THERE WERE WERE ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH ALL THE GOALS THAT
WE'VE DISCUSSED TODAY THAT WE
SUPPORT- BUT THEN DO IT IN A
WAY THAT'S PRIVACY PROTECTED
THAT'S AGGREGATED THAT'S
ANONYMIZE AND WE CAN AND JUST
FOR A LIMITED THOSE OTHER
CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE ABOUT
USER PRIVACY. CARD AND AGAIN I
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
SOMEONE INNOCENT WOMEN FOR
THEIR WILLINGNESS TO BE TO WORK
WITH THE COMMITTEES RIGHT.
BECAUSE THEY HAD BILLS THAT
WERE GOING THEY HAD BILLS THAT
PASSED THE ASSEMBLY AND THEIR
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH THIS
COMMITTEE AND OTHERS. TO TRY
TO- REALLY WORK THAT OUT IN
TRYING TO GET IT RIGHT SO I'M
WE'RE JUST ONE SEE HOW GRATEFUL
WE ARE ONCE AGAIN. ANOTHER ITEM
IN REGARDS TO MANDATED MINIMUMS
FOR INSURANCE. YOU LOOK AT THE
LARGER. CITIES. SIMILAR IN
NATURE CAN I GET YOUR THOUGHTS
ON THAT WHAT YOU SEE OUT THERE
IN THE MARKET PLACE IN
CALIFORNIA. YES SO WE HAVE- I
HAVE TWO COMMENTS ON THAT
FRONT- WE MEET ALL OF THE YOU
KNOW. LOCAL STATE. FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- INSURANCE
REGULATIONS- WE'VE NO CONCERNS
WITH THAT THERE'S SOME THAT ARE
BAKED INTO OUR PERMIT TERMS- WE
ASSESS THOSE WHEN WE ARE
APPLYING AND INTEND TO LIVE
UNDER THOSE- THE CHALLENGES
WHEN A POLICY BEING ASKED TO.
GO OUT AND GET A POLICY DOESN'T
EXIST ON THE MARKET TODAY. I
WOULD FLAG THAT IS A CONCERN
AND ANOTHER ONE IS. ARE THE
MECHANISMS THAT LIKE IT WHAT'S
IN THE BILL IS THAT ACTUALLY
LEAING THE CONCERN THAT YOU
HAVE SO LOOKING AT WHAT THE
GOALS ARE SO WE HAVE A REALLY
BROAD COMPREHENSIVE COVERAGE WE
HAVE A TEN MILLION DOLLAR. GET
LIMIT WE HAVE A FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR PER CURRENTS LIMIT THAT
MEETS. THE RIVER ON MANY OF
THEIR BOB. ENTRANCE
REQUIREMENTS THAT YOU HEARD
TODAY- AND SO WE JUST DON'T
WANT TO GET. TO WHERE WERE KIND
OF SO BOXED IN THAT WERE IN
KIND OF MISSING WHAT THE GOALS
OF WHAT THE REGULATIONS TRYING
TO ACCOMPLISH. DO YOU BELIEVE-
THERE'S A COMMENT MADE THAT IF
THERE WAS SAID AS STATEWIDE
STANDARD RIGHT I THAT THAT
WOULD ACTUALLY ASSIST IN
REGARDS TO THE NUMBER. OF
COMPANIES THAT WERE OFFERING
INSURANCE AS WELL YOU WANT TO
COMMENT ON THAT BECAUSE- IN AND
I'M GOING TO PARAPHRASE HERE
AND WANT TO PUT WORDS INTO THE
INDIVIDUALS MOUTH BUT- IT. THE
COMMENT WAS THAT IF WE LOOK AT
A STATEWIDE STANDARD THAT MAY
BECOME. MORE OF AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR OTHER COMPANIES APPEAR TO
GET IN VERSES OUT ONE INSURANCE
CARRIER AND IT CAN BE VERY
EXPENSIVE CAN YOU CAN. COME IN
ON THE ACT. BUT YOU HEARD FROM
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. I TINK
THAT'S ABSOLUTELY LIKELY TO BE
THE CASE A FEW STATES HAVE
ALREADY PASSED SUCH IT SUCH
STATEWIDE INSURANCE
REQUIREMENTS. WE HAVEN'T SEEN
AGREE UP TO GET ONE FROM THE
INSURANCE COMPANIES BUT IT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE THAT WE KNOW
THAT THERE ARE. OTHERS ACTIVELY
LOOKING TO GET INTO THE SPACE
AS WELL. SORRY THAT THE ONLY
OTHER THING I WOULD ADD IS THAT
AS AS IS THE CASE FOR MOST.
MOST COMPANIES IT'S NOT THAT WE
HAVE A SEPARATE INSURANCE
POLICY FOR EVERY CITY IN WHICH
WE OPERATE. AND SO THE REASON
WHY WE SUPPORT THE CENTER'S
IDEATION OF THESE CHARTS
APARTMENTS AS WITH THE CITIES.
IS THAT- IT WOULD IT WOULD
BEHOOVE ANYONE TO HAVE ONE
CITIES CREE INSURANCE
REQUIREMENT THAT EVERY OTHER
CITY IN CALIFORNIA NOW
ESSENTIALLY HAS TO FALL. PLEASE
AND I'M GONNA GO ALONG THE
LINES THAT WITH MY TRADITIONAL
STAFF FOR A RESPONSE WHICH IS
YOU KNOW SUPPORT THE GOALS- WE
HAVE TO SEE THE DETAILS OF
COURSE YOU KNOW THE LAWYER IN
ME AS I CAN BE ABLE TO SAY YES
WE JUST CAN SUPPORT- BUT- THE
GOALS YES. ARE LAUDABLE AND
WE'RE NOT NECESSARILY OPPOSED
TO SEE REGULATION BUT WE'RE NOT
TRYING TO PREEMPT. LOCALS FROM
GETTING IN AND HAVING VALID
CONCERNS EITHER SO ON MAKE THAT
POINT. IS MIDDLE. THANK YOU WE
HEARD THE SAME ARGUMENT DURING
THE TNC IS AN INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER DAVE JONES- THEN
WORK WITH THE INSURANCE
COMPANIES THE CREATED A WHOLE
NEW MARKET OF INSURANCE.
INCLUDING WHAT WE'RE NOW
HEARING ON TV CALL METRO MILE
THAT SUPPLIED BEYOND THE TNC IS
TO PERSONS WERE USING IT WITH
THEIR OWN VEHICLES. THERE WAS
NO DIFFICULTY IN GETTING
INSURANCE COMPANIES TO COME IN
AND UNDER RIGHT. THE UBER LIFT
DRIVERS. I DON'T SEE THAT THERE
WOULD BE SUCH A DIFFICULTY NOW
BECAUSE THERE'S A MODEL TO
FOLLOW. PLEASE IF I COULD I
THINK THERE IS THE VERY SLIGHT
DIFFERENCE IS SIMPLY THAT CAR
INSURANCE FOR UBER UBER LET'S
AT AS MY UNDERSTANDING- DEPLOY
A VARIANT OF THE CAR INSURANCE
THAT ALREADY EXISTS AND THERE
WERE CERTAINLY A LOT OF- DREW A
LOT OF NEW THING YOU ASPECTS OF
IT THAT THEY HAD TO SIT DOWN AT
THE TABLE WITH THE INSURANCE
COMES TO DO SO AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO DOING THAT- IN THE
COMING YEAR TO DEVELOP THE SURE
CENTERS FOR THIS VERY NEW MODE
FOR WHICH THERE ISN'T REALLY
ANY A CURRENT ANALOG AND WE'RE
MEETING WITH. AND WE'RE MEETING
ACTIVELY WORKING WITH THEM
RIGHT NO. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WOULD LIKE TO BE ETERNAL
RICHARD FRAZIER UP FOR ANOTHER
QUESTION PLEASE JUST A- MOMENT
UBER AND- PER TO KIND OF
COMMENT ON THE LAST FEW WEEKS
WE'VE BEEN HAVING THESE
BLACKOUTS IN. OUR SHUT OFFS.
HAVE YOU SEEN A DECLINE IN THE
USAGE OF YOUR SCOOTERS AND THE
AND THEN ALSO- THE ABILITY TO
CHARGE HIM HELLO. FOR USAGE
HAVE USED CONTRACTING MATT. SIR
CERTAINLY IT IS CERTAINLY THE
CHALLENGE FOR US AS IS AS IS AS
EVERYONE ELSE THAT DEPENDS ON
THE POWER GRID OF FOUR USES I
KNOW THAT IN A FEW CITIES WE'VE
WE'VE WE'VE UNLOCKED- AS AN
OPTION FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE IN.
EXISTENCE CIRCUMSTANCES TO USE
FREE OF CHARGE TO GET OUT OF
WHERE THEY NEED TO BE IS- AS AS
A POTENTIAL OPTION BUT
CERTAINLY YOU'RE RIGHT THAT THE
BLACKOUTS AND THE AND THE WILD
FIRES HAVE. TAKEN THEIR TOLL ON
US AS THEY DO THE REST OF
CALIFORNIA. I DON'T HAVE ANY
SPECIFIC DATA ABOUT HOW THE
WILD FIRES OF AFFECTED SERVICE
OTHER THAN WE HAVE DONE SAFETY
MESSAGING TO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE
TO. YOU KNOW USE MIKE MOBILITY
OPTIONS AND IN TE OPPOSITE
DIRECTION. WE HAVE THE WILD
FIRES ARE HAPPENING- BUT NOT
SURE ABOUT THAT AND- THE-
IMPLICATIONS FOR OUR POWER GRAD
CHARGING AT OPERATIONS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT. I WOULD JUST
BE CURIOUS ON HOW MUCH. OF
PEOPLE THAT RELY ON THEM ON A
DAILY BASIS- HAVE BEEN AFFECTED
AND HOW. ARE YOU THE REDUCTION
OF USAGE HAS. NOT ONLY AFFECTED
YOU. THE CONSUMER BUT ALSO A
YOUR BOTTOM LINE. I HAVE A
FOLLOW UP AND SEE IF THERE'S
ANY SPECIFICS WE CAN SHARE WITH
YOU. THANK YOU. ONE LESS ITEM A
PROMISE AND THEN I WILL TURN IT
OVER TO- THE CHAIRMAN FOR
CLOSING COMMENTS AS WELL. CAN
WE GO BACK SO- HE HE ALL
COMMENTED ON ISSUES IN REGARDS
TO PC FEES AND LOCAL FEES AS
WELL. I THINK THAT IT IS A REAL
CHALLENGE IS WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMING FROM
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. TRYING TO
RECOUP THE COSTS THAT IT TAKES
TO BE ABLE TO MANAGE THE
PROGRAM. SO WALK US THROUGH
THAT ONE MORE TIME- IF YOU
DON'T MIND THAT BECAUSE I THINK
WITH THE CHALLENGES. OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT JUST COULD BE CANTON
I'LL GIVE YOU MY OWN EDITORIAL.
I THINK THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION IS SWAMPED. I THINK
THAT- TO SAY THE LEAST. THEY
NEED TO SPEND MORE TIME
REGULATING P. JEANNIE LESS TIME
ON THIS AND THAT THE LOCALS TO
WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO DO. MY
OWN OPINION WE WILL GO THERE WE
WILL SURPASS RAN A CUSS JAR. SO.
BUT WHAT I WILL SAY IS. IF
THERE COULD BE SOME ROOM.
REGION GREEN OF THOSE DOLLARS
THAT COULD GO TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY HELP THEM SINCE ARE
THE ONES THAT ARE ON THE GROUND
THERE REGULATING. CAN YOU
COMMENT ON THAT A LITTLE BIT
BECAUSE- I CAN'T IMAGINE THAT
YOU ARE GETTING WHAT YOU NEED
AT THIS POINT. THE P. C. ON
THIS ISSUE. SOME OF OUR THANK
YOU SO MUCH- I THINK THAT'S
EXACTLY RIGHT THAT WE DON'T
HAVE WE DON'T HAVE ANY PUBLIC
WE DON'T HAVE PUBLIC SUPPORT WE
DON'T RELY ON IT HOWEVER AS A
RESULT OF THAT AS A RESULT OF
CITIES- RECOUPING THE COSTS
WHICH WILL WHICH AS SOMEONE WHO
HAS ALSO. HAD EXPERIENCE WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENT WE I
ABSOLUTELY UNDERSTAND THAT YOU
CAN'T HAVE IN YET ANOTHER LARGE
RED ITEM ON YOUR BUDGET. I
THINK THE PROBLEM FOR US COMES
IN THE FACT THAT THIS IS AN
APPLIED EQUALLY ACROSS
TRANSPORTATION MODES THE FEES
THAT WE PAY FOR DRIVING CARS OR
FOR TAKING ON TNC TRIPS OR FOR
ANY OTHER MODE OF TRANSPORT
DON'T REALLY COME CLOSE TO
MATCHING THE COST OF ALL THE
TRANSPORTATION STAFFERS THAT
CITIES HIGHER THE TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
TRANSPORTATION AND SO ON.
THERE'S AN UNDERSTANDING THAT
TO SOME EXTENT THIS IS
SUBSIDIZED BY THE REST OF THE
PUBLIC IN IN AFFORDABLE TO
ALLOW ALL OF US TO GET AROUND.
I THINK THAT WHAT WE SWITCH
SCENE THAT I CON ME IN WHEN IT
COMES TO CITIES RECOUPINGTHE
COSTS COMING TO US IS THAT
THOSE COSTS ARE TWENTY TO
EIGHTY TIMES HIGHER THAN THE
COSTS IMPOSED ON DNC'S AND THAT
THIS NOT BECAUSE CITIES ARE OUT
ON ARE OUT TRYING TO RAISE
REVENUE OR TRYING TO EXTORT
ANYBODY IT'S SIMPLY THAT WE ARE
WE ARE ONE OF THE FEW MOST THAT
THERE IS A- THERE'S ACTIVE
ATTEMPT TO TRY TO RECOUP ALL
THE COSTS. AND SO THAT'S ONE OF
THE ASPECTS WERE I THINK HAVING
STATE MARCIA WOULD BE MOST
HELPFUL IN THAT THE STATE HAS
CONTRIBUTED A LOT TOWARDS
ENCOURAGING THE ADOPTION OF
ZERO MISSION TRANSPORTATION AND
THAT IS EXACTLY THE SORT OF
THING. THAT WOULD BENEFIT MOST
I THINK. FROM LOWERING THE COST
UPON WRITERS. GOT IT OKAY IN I
THINK THAT- I APPRECIATE AND I
THINK THE ISSUE IS. ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY. WE WANT TO DO THIS
HEARING TODAY IS. AS WE SEEN.
WHETHER IT'S ISSUES EIGHTEEN C.
OR ISSUES. AGAIN OF CANNABIS
RIGHT. WE ALLOW INDUSTRIES AGO
AND THEN WE TRY TO BE A
RELIGION OVERSEEN CHALLENGES.
TRYING TO BE TO DO IT RIGHT THE
FIRST TIME ALL AT ONCE. SO I
APPRECIATE THAT IS WELL- IN
THAT INSIGHT- WOULD LIKE TO BE
TO LOOK FOR ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS FROM THE THREE PEOPLE
CERTAIN SHOULD OWN GO TO OUR
RIGHT- AND THEN WE'RE GONNA
OPEN UP FOR THE PUBLIC. PLEASE
DON'T CLOSE INCOMING PLEASE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ONE POINT
OF CLARIFICATION THE CPUC DOES
NOT REGULATE SCOOTERS. TN CZS
SCOOTERS NO- WHAT I DO WANNA IT
STRESSED AND I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY IS
THAT THE CONSUMER CAN'T COME
LAST. IN THE BILL CAN'T BE
FOOTED BY THE CITY OR MEDI CAL.
THERE MUST BE SOME
APPORTIONMENT AS IS THE
STANDARD THROUGH LAW AND
ECONOMICS. ALL THROUGHOUT TIME.
IF A PRODUCT A PRODUCT IS BEING
SOLD IT MUST INCORPORATE THE
TRUE COSTS OF THE PRODUCT.
OTHERWISE THE MARKET WILL NOT.
SET THE RIGHT POINT IN WHICH IS
TO BE USED TO THE RIGHT COST.
THIS MUST INCLUDE THE COST OF
INJURIES TO PERSONS. THERE
SHOULD NOT AND CANNOT BE A
COMPLETE RELEASE AND WAIVER. OF
ALL LIABILITY FOR SOMEONE WHO
USES THIS DEVICE THAT THEY'RE
NOT MAINTAINING. INSPECTING OR
REALLY HAVING ANY CONTROL OVER
OTHER THAN TAKING A PROFIT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR CALLING US. I WOULD SAY
REAL TIME COLLECTION TRIP
DETAIL DATA IS A SERIOUS THREAT
TO CONSUMER PRIVACY. IT'S ALSO
THE COMPLETE OPPOSITE DIRECTION
A CALIFORNIA HAS TAKEN. ON
PRIVACY ISSUES- ESPECIALLY WHEN
ALL THE LEGITIMATE REGULATORY
GOALS THAT WE DISCUSSED HERE
TODAY LIKE MONITORING CAPS
UTILIZATION AND DISTRIBUTION
CAN BE ACHIEVED WITHOUT
TRACKING INDIVIDUAL WRITERS.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
ON THIS ISSUE. EXCEPT FOR WHEN
WE DO THINK SO MUCH FOR. AND I
WOULD AND I WOULD AGREE THAT
THE CONSUMER DOESN'T. FIRST I
THINK THAT THERE'S A LOT THAT
IT THAT. MATTERS TO CONSUMERS
ALONG WITH MAKING SURE THAT
THEY ARE SO. AND SAFE AND
PROTECTED ON ON OUR DEVICES.
BUT THIS AT THE SAME TIME THAT
WE WANT TO PRESERVE CHOICE OF
PEOPLE CHOOSING BETWEEN CARS
AND OTHER MODES. IN THAT RIGHT
NOW IT'S THE EXISTING LOCAL
REGULATORY FRAMEWORKS AND THE
STATE REGULATORY FROM A FOR
CALIFORNIA. GREATLY INCENTIVIZE
PEOPLE TO TAKE CARS INSTEAD OF
SCOOTERS AND BIKES IN THAT IF
WE WANT TO FIX THAT BUT THE
ANSWER ISN'T TO GET RID OF
LOCAL REGULATION BEFORE THE
CITY'S. FOR US THE WRITERS AND
THE STATE. TO ALL WORK TOGETHER.
TOO MUCH. EXCELLENT PANEL WE'RE
GRATEFUL THAT ALL THE WOULD
HANG WITH US TODAY- IN YOUR
TESTIMONY THANK YOU FOR TAKING
TIME IN YOUR BUSY SCHEDULES.
RESIDENT NORTH BAY. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP DURING
THIS- FIRE SEASON I KNOW YOU'VE
BEEN BOOTSON THE GROUND OUT
THERE. AND I REALLY WANT TO
THANK YOU FROM OUR COMMUNITY SO
I THINK SO MUCH HAS DAHLE AND
IT'S BEEN A- ROUGH COUPLE WEEKS
SO VERY VERY GRATEFUL AND I
WILL PASS THAT ALONG TO
EVERYONE UP THERE THANK YOU SO
MUCH IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE'RE NOT
GONNA BE OPEN UP FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT WE'RE GONNA ASSET EACH
INDIVIDUAL BE ABLE TO SAY THE
FIRST AND LAST NAME WE WELCOME
YOU. HERE THREE MINUTES SIR
THANK YOU FOR HANGING WITH US
AND FOR YOUR PATIENCE- IT'S
GOOD TO SEE YOU YOU HAVE THE
FLOOR SIR. THREE MINUTES. HELLO
SENATOR. FIRE CENTERED RUBIO AS
ASSEMBLYMAN FRAZIER- WHAT I
WILL OFFER TO YOU IS FIRST
THING IS TO PAGE SEVEN. THE
EIGHTY EIGHTY I ONLY HAVE A
CALIFORNIA INSURANCE CARD.
IDENTIFICATION SO I WOULD NOT
BE ABLE TO USE THOSE SYSTEMS
BECAUSE IT MANDATES THAT YOU
HAVE TO HAVE A CALIFORNIA
DRIVER'S LICENSE WHICH IS WHAT
YOU WILL HAVE IN MOST PEOPLE OF
DISABILITY QUALIFICATIONS WHAT
YOU NEED TO FIGURE IS A PATH I
THINK IT'S A CLASS THAT NEEDS
TO BE OFFERED IN FULL
INSTRUCTION ABILITY SO THAT YOU
UTILIZE. THESE MEANS BECAUSE I
WATCH THE JUMP BIKES IN
SACRAMENTO SEE HOW BADLY
DAMAGED THEY ARE THE STORY OF
THE TWO SHOWS TWENTY NINTH
STREET I WATCH SOMEBODY TAKE A
JUMP BIKE AND JUST PLOP RIGHT
DOWN IN THE PEDESTRIAN
CROSSWALK AND LEAVE IT THERE I
ASKED THEM TO MOVE NO WAY THIS
GOES BACK TO THE COMPANY. SO I
WILL SAY TO YOU IS WHAT NEEDS
TO HAPPEN. IS JUMPED PARKS
AARON SCOOTERS NEED TO BE WHERE
THEY START OUT GPS FIVE OR TEN
MINUTES WHEN THEY'RE FINISHED
IS RECORDED ANY NEED TO HAVE A
PLACE FROM TO BE PICKED UP AND
A PLACE FOR THEM TO BE DROPPED
OFF LOT OF PEOPLE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO HAVE TO GO THROUGH
TRYING TO FIND ON A MAP WERE
IN THE WORLD THEY ARE I DO NOT
KNOW WHAT THE OTHER CITIES ARE
LIKE. BUT THAT'S SOMETHING FOR
BOTH UBER AND LIFT ALSO IS
WHERE THEY TRY AND PICK UP
PEOPLE IT WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL
IF YOU CAME UP WITH BEST
PRACTICES IN LOOKED AT WHAT
WORKS IN THE STATE AND IN THE
CITIES AND COME UP WITH
COMMONALITY AGREEMENTS ALSO
PROBABLY MAYBE IT'S THREE
O'CLOCK IN THE MORNING OR
SOMETHING THAT EVERY SINGLE
DEVICE THAT THESE COMPANIES
MAINTAIN THAT YOU CAN GPS
SETTING. SEE YOU KNOW WHAT THE
HECK WHERE THEY ARE THAT'S NOT
ANYTHING PRIVACY OR ANYTHING
ELSE BUT YOU HAVE A CLUE NO WAY
IN AND SO YOU HAVE SOME OF THE
PROBLEMS TO BE ADDRESSED. AND I
WILL OFFER FOR DISABLED YES
THEY'RE ALWAYS IN MY WAY IN
SACRAMENTO I DO HAVE TO KEEP
BROWN AND MOVE THEM- DEXTER HAD
I'M WORRIED RIGHT NARAL TO
KILLING YOU ABOUT THIS. BUT
AGAIN I THINK IF YOU DO THOSE
THINGS YOU WILL GET THEM SO
THAT DOES MEAN THOUGH IS FOR
THAT DRIVER THANK ALL CALLED
RIGHT OR WHATEVER. THAT MAKES
THE PROBLEM THAT YOU KNOW FIND
OUT WHO THEY ARE SO THAT YES
YOU MAKE IT WHERE A- TEN DOLLAR
FINE IF YOU DO IT AGAIN. IT
DOUBLES OR WHATEVER SO WITH
THE- PERSON IN THERE YOU GET
THE MEDINA FIGHT YOU KNOW YOU
TELL THEM AND GIVE THEM THE-
SHE WAS A COMPANY. THAT OPTION
OF HATE. YOU HAD FOR PROBLEMS
WHATEVER STE JUST A SUGGESTION
BEST PRACTICES YOU NEED TO FIND
BUT A DINNER FINE WE'RE AND YOU
ARE PUTTING THESE PLACES ACT. I
WILL OFFER THE ARENA UP THROUGH
THERE. UBER AND LIFT FIND
EVERYWHERE BECAUSE THERE'S NO
DESIGNATED SPOT TO FOR THEM TO
UNLOAD INPUT SO YOU HAVE
PROBLEMS ALL OVER THE PLACE. I
SEE HOW DIRTY IN THE OTHER
THINGS I AGREE WITH WHAT THEY
SAY ABOUT THEY NEED TO BE MAYBE
MONTHLY CHECKED TO BE SURE THAT
WHAT SHOULD BEING PUT OUT IS
CONFIRMED WHAT'S GOING ON.
AGAIN FIND OUT WHAT'S BEST
PRACTICES WHAT WILL WORK I GET
A LEAVE FOR PARA TRANSIT
MEETING SO I'LL LEAVE YOU GUYS
AND WE'LL LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING ABOUT THIS AND SEE WHAT
YOU COME UP WITH LATER THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND IT'S ALWAYS
GOOD TO SEE YOU WE APPRECIATE
YOU TAKING PART AND- GRATEFUL
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY THANKS
FOR HANGING WITH THIS FOR SO
LONG. HEY GOOD EVENING THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE FOR STORAGE
THREE. GOOD AFTER AN AD
CHAIRMAN FRAZIER CHAIRMAN
MCGUIRE MEMBERS. AND YOU MEDI
HERE ON BEHALF OF LIME OUT WE
WILL BE SUBMITTING SOME FORMAL
COMMENTS TO THE COMMITTEE BUT-
I WANTED TO JUST TOUCH ON SOME-
KIND OF MAIN HIGHLIGHTS THAT.
THE COMPANY WANTED TO SHARE
TODAY ALSO AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
FACILITY FACILITATING THIS
CONVERSATION- FOR LYME WE
FACILITATED MORE THAN A HUNDRED
MILLION RIDES AROUND THE GLOBE
IN ONLY TWO YEARS- BUT WE
BELIEVE THAT. SERVING CITIES
RIGHT TO REGULATE SCOOTERS IS
CRITICAL AND WE RECOMMEND THAT.
THE STATE LEGISLATURE AND
AGENCIES CAN HELP IN THE
FOLLOWING WAYS. I'M STATE THE
STATE AND CITIES SHOULD ENGAGE
WITH OPERATORS TO SET BEST
PRACTICES FOR LOCAL POLICY
FRAMEWORKS- AND THE STATE
SHOULD HEAVILY INVEST AND
EXPEDITE FUNDS TO CITIES AND
COUNTIES THAT HELP THEM BUILD
OUT TRANSIT. AND PROTECTED BIKE
IN FOR A BIKE LANE
INFRASTRUCTURE- ADDITIONALLY
LINES WORK WITH FIFTEEN ON
CITIES AROUND THE STATE TO
SHARE RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
SUCCESSFUL POLICY FRAMEWORKS-
THE FIRST. START WITH A
REASONABLE NUMBER OF SCOOTERS
AND GROW BASED ON DEMAND AND
PERFORMANCE THAT MEANS IT'S A
PERFORMANCE BASED CAP- WE THINK
THAT. THIS HELPS INCENTIVIZE
OPERATORS AND- WITH THE FLEET
TO INCREASE YOU KNOW SAFETY
WORKSHOPS AND SO FORTH. I'M
ALSO SUBJECT SCOOTERS TO THE
SAME- RULES AS BIKES. SCOOTERS
SHOULD BE ABLE TO RIDE ANYWHERE
AND ANYTIME THAT A BIKE AND
RIDE AND SUBJECTING SCOOTERS TO
STRICTER RULES CAN CAUSE
CONFUSION AMONG WRITERS. NON
WRITERS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND ALSO MAKE SURE SCOOTERS ARE
RELIABLE CITIES RIGHTFULLY
WORRY ABOUT SCOOTER PARKING
CLATTER. LIME EDUCATES OUR
WRITERS ON PROPER PARKING
ADVOCATE BUT SOME CITIES ARE
MOVING TO MANDATE PARKING IN
DESIGNATED CORRALS. WINDS
WRITER ANALYSIS DATA SHOWS
HOWEVER THAT. WITH EACH STEP
ADDED WITH EACH ADDED STEP THAT
A USER HAS TO WALK TO FIND A
SCOOTER. THE LESS LIKELY
WRITERS WILL CHOOSE THIS
SCOOTER AS AN ALTERNATIVE TO A
CAR. SO THE BEST APPROACH IS TO
HAVE SCOOTERS PART NO MORE THAN
A HUNDRED FIFTY FEET FROM ANY
BUILDING. AVAILABLE THROUGH
EITHER FREE FLOATING PARKING IT.
IN LESS DENSE AREA OR A BUNCH
PARKING SPACES IN DENSE
DOWNTOWNS. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE STATE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO CONTINUE
PROVIDING CALIFORNIANS WITH
COST EFFECTIVE AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS THANK
YOUNG ENGLISHMAN ANYTHING FOR
HANGING WITH US GOOD AFTERNOON
SIR THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
THANKS FOR AND WITH THIS THING
TO OUR TIME THE FLOOR IS YOURS
YOUR THREE MINUTES. OF MY NAME
IS DAVE CAMPBELL FEC DIRECTOR
WITH BIKE EAST BAY WERE WALK
BIKE ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION AND
ALAMEDA CONTRA COSTA. COUNTIES
AND I AM HERE AND SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF MORE MOBILITY
DEVICES ON OUR STREETS- IT'S
REALLY FRUSTRATING I HAVE
THIRTY TWO CITIES IN MY TO
COUNTY TO BAN SCOOTERS. I HAVE
ONE CITY THAT'S BEEN VERY PRO
SCOOTERS AND YET WHEN YOU GET
TO THAT CITY LINE YOU GOT A
PROBLEM- SO ALAMEDA BANDS IN
OAKLAND IT'S PRO. BERKELEY'S
READY TO DO PERMITS BUT THEY'RE
WORRIED ABOUT LIABILITY EVERY
THOSE THINKING ABOUT AT
RICHMOND IS READY TO GO BUT
THEY'RE WORRIED TOO. THIS IS
RIDICULOUS WE DO NEED THE STATE
TO STEP IN AND PROVIDE SOME
CITIES BAD THESE THINGS. SAID
OF FLOOR SET A CEILING AND
LET'S WHAT THESE COMPANIES
INNOVATE WORKING WITH THE
CITY'S ON ALL THESE ISSUES THAT
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT HERE- PLEASE
PUSH TOWARDS MORE INNOVATION IN
OAKLAND WHERE WE DO HAVE OW.
FOR SCOOTER OPERATORS I SEE
INNOVATION EVERY DAY ONE
OPERATORS OUT IN A MEETING THE
OTHER THAT'S. WHAT WE NEED WE
NEED IT STATEWIDE AND WE NEED
ANY CITY. ONE WAY YOU CAN
REALLY HELP US HERE'S BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE SAFETY ISSUES
YOU HAD AN EXPERT HERE SAYING
I'M GIVING YOU A VERY LIMITED
SET OF DATA FROM THREE CITIES.
ON THIS VERY ISSUE THAT YOU.
ASKED ME TO TALK ABOUT THAT'S
BAD DATA WHY DON'T WE HAVE
BETTER DATA SO I THINK THE
STATE CAN STEP IN FUND THIS
RESEARCH. MAKE IT HAPPENS WHEN
SOMEBODY GETS APPEARANCE AS
HERE'S THE SAFETY CONCERN I
HAVE WE HAVE REAL DATA THAT
BACK TO THE- ON LIABILITY IN
INSURANCE I THINK THE STATE
DOES HAVE A ROLE TO PLAY. I
THINK THE STATE HAS A ROLE TO
PLAY ON MAXIMUM. LIABILITY
ISSUES OAKLAND HAS A PROVISION
WHERE THEY REQUIRE THE MOBILITY
OPERATORS TO INDEMNIFY THE CITY
OF OAKLAND FOR THE CITY'S OWN
DESIGN AND TO ME THAT'S WHAT IF
THAT'S OFFENSIVE AS A BIKE
ADVOCATE THAT. ANY CITY CAN GET
AWAY WITH THAT. THE STATE
SHOULD NOT ALLOW CITIES TO DO
THAT- FINALLY. WHAT MORE
CONSISTENCIES BETWEEN THE
CITIES WE NEED THAT WE ALSO
NEED MORE CONSISTENCY BETWEEN
THE MODES I THINK A LOT OF
PEOPLE LOOK AT. MIKE WILL BUILT
E. AS HOLDING IT TO A HIGHER
STANDARD. AND SO AS YOU DID. AS
YOU DISCUSS HOW TO REGULATE
MIKE MOBILITY. ASK HOW'RE WE'D
REGULATING SIMILAR OTHER MODES
OF TRANSPORTATION DO WE
REGULATE CARS THIS WAY DO WE
REGULATE PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
THIS WAY. DO WE REGULATE
RAILROADS AND AIRLINES THIS
WAY. SO LET'S HOLD ALL OF THESE
MOBILITY OPTIONS TO THE SAME
STANDARD IF WE CAN THANKS I
THANK YOU SO MUCH TO RETURN
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US
THIS ENTIRE TIME IT'S GOOD TO
SEE YOU THANK YOU. A GOOD
EVENING MA'AM GOOD EVENING-
BLANCA CASTRO ON ADVOCACY
MANAGER WITH A RP CALIFORNIA WE
REPRESENT ABOUT THREE POINT
THREE MILLION MEMBERS AND I'M
HERE TO. JUST REMIND THE
COMMITTEE THAT- OLDER ADULTS
ARE NOT A HOMOGENEOUS
POPULATION- THERE ARE MANY
TYPES OF MOBILITY IS THAT
PEOPLE OF ON. FIFTEEN OVER ARE
LOOKING FOR. THE SCOOTERS IS
ONE OF THEM E. BIKES IS ONE OF
THEM YES BUT WALKING IS
ANOTHER. AND SO THESE ARE. A
FEW OF OUR CONCERNS FIRST OF
ALL. WE DO SUPPORT SHARE DATA
WITH LOCALITIES. AND THE SHARED
MOBILITY- COMPANIES RECOGNIZING
THAT THERE HAS TO BE PERSONAL
PRIVATE INFORMATION THAT IS
PROTECTED. BY THE SAME TOKEN
THE INFRASTRUCTURE. AND THEN
THE OPTION OF PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION NEED TO COME
INTO PLAY AND WITHOUT THE DATA.
AND THIS IS WHERE WE THINK THE
STATE CAN COMMAND. IS SETTING
THAT STANDARD EVEN IF ITS
MINIMUM STANDARD. AND WHAT WE
REALLY WERE FRUSTRATED WITH
THIS JUSTICE HERE WITH THE
CONFUSION OF THE BILL AND THE
LANGUAGE SO REALLY JUST MAKING
IT VERY SIMPLE BUT THEY JUST
NEED THE DATA TO BE ABLE TO
PREPARE FOR THE FUTURE. AND FOR
PEOPLE OF ALL AGES AND
ABILITIES AND THEN WE WOULD
LIKE TO ALSO JUST POINT OUT.
THAT OLDER ADULTS REGARDLESS OF
WHERE YOU LIVE YOU WANT TO AGE
IN YOUR COMMUNITY BUT YOU WANT
TO HAVE OPTIONS SO IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT. THE SAFETY OF
THESE MOBILITY OPTIONS ARM AND
ALSO THE ACCESSIBILITY OF THEM
ARE IN LOWER INCOME COMMUNITIES
AS WELL AS THE HIGH INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND LASTLY IWOULD
LIKE TO SAY WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- AND WITH MANY OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS WHO WERE AROUND
DURING THE ELEVEN TWELVE
CONVERSATION BUT MAKING IT MUCH
MORE VISIBLE THAT WHAT'S THE
BENEFIT TO THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE
IN THESECOMMUNITIES. SO I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS WAS
EXTREMELY USEFUL AND
INFORMATIVE CONVERSATION AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO THE FEBRUARY
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE DATA
SHARING. THANK YOU SO MUCH IT'S
GOT TO REVIEW YOUR HERE AND I
APOLOGIZE I'M A DISTRACTION
DISTANTLY T. ON ME. GIVEN THEIR
LASSIE AND YOUR COLLEAGUES
HELPS YOU YEAH EXACTLY GOOD
STUFF I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT. MY
GOODNESS ALL RIGHT- WELCOME
MA'AM GOOD EVENING YOU HAVE
THREE MINUTES TO FOR SHORT HI
LINDA COMMISSION WITH A
CALIFORNIA BICYCLE COALITION. I
THANK YOU FOR CONVENING THIS
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION I THINK
WE'VE BEEN DEALING WITH ACROSS
THE STATE AND ECHOING MY
COLLEAGUES AT A BIKE YOU SPAY
AS WELL THEY ARE P. THE NUMBER
OF CHALLENGES THAT. BOTH TIMES
AND OPPORTUNITIES THAT COME
ABOUT I WITH THIS I COULDN'T
PUT NEW MOBILITY IN AND LIKE TO
ECHO WHAT WAS SAID BY MISTER
ADEL AND THAT. THIS ISN'T NEW
WE HAVE HAD- MICHAEL MOBILITY
BIKING WALKING. GETTING TO
TRANSIT- AND. NOW WHAT'S THE
DIFFERENCE IS THAT WE HAVE. THE
ABILITY TO MANUFACTURE AT A
VERY LOW COST MILLIONS OF
SCOOTERS AND THESE EVE BIKES
NOW. AND ALSO A NUMBER OF A YOU
KNOW A LOT OF FUNDING BEHIND IT
AS WELL A VENTURE VENTURE
CAPITAL FUNDING THAT'S A LOT
FOR THE DEPLOYMENT. OF THESE
SHARED SYSTEMS AND SO WHAT WE
SAW IN THE PAST FEW YEARS IS
WHAT HAS BEEN CALLED SORT OF A
DISRUPTION I INTO OUR
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM AND
WHAT'S THAT'S REALLY BEEN IT'S
LIKE IT'S A VOLUME ISSUE THAT.
HAPPENED AND IT WOULD
HIGHLIGHTED WAS ALSO THE
CHALLENGES IN OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE SO WE DID
DISCUSS THAT A LOT HERE THERE
WAS COMMENTARY ON. WHAT SAFETY
REALLY LOOKS LIKE IT'S SUDDENLY
PEOPLE FINALLY UNDERSTOOD
BETTER SIDEWALKS WERE NOT UP TO
PAR OR THAT THERE AREN'T SPACE
THERE ISN'T SPACE IN OUR
STREETS FOR- ALL THESE-
DIFFERENT MODES AND SO. THAT'S
SOMETHING TO REALLY COME INTO
THIS CONVERSATION TOGETHER AS
WELL IN ADDITION TO ANY KIND OF
REGULATION AS TO HOW WE- REALLY
GOING TO IMPROVE THE SAFETY
IT'S IT ISN'T IN THE TERMS OF
THE DEVICES AS FROM A CONSUMER
PERSPECTIVE WHAT YOU'RE REALLY
LOOKING AT WHERE. CAN PEOPLE BE
IN THE STREETS- AND HOW WE MAKE
SPACE FOR EVERYONE- YOU KNOW
THIS CONVERSATION IS CALLED
STAY IN YOUR LANE BUT- THERE
AREN'T REALLY MANY LANES FOR
PEOPLE THE VAN AND SO- IT WE
HAVE TO THINK ABOUT THAT ASPECT
AND THE OTHER IS THAT WE'VE YOU
KNOW WE'VE HEARD. OF SOME
CITIES ARE BANNING THESE
ENTIRELY OR NOT ALLOWING FOR
THE INNOVATION TO COME INTO
THEIR CITIES OTHERS HAVE A
REALLY HARD TIME ACTUALLY
ATTRACTING THE INDUSTRY TO COME
TO. THE COMMUNITY BECAUSE- THEY
MIGHT BE LOWER DENSITY OR AT
LOWER INCOME AND THAT'S NOT.
SOMETHING NECESSARILY THAT'S
GOING TO BE PROFITABLE SO THEY
ARE WHILE YOU KNOW WORKING WITH
THE COMMUNITY HAVE TO LOOK AT
OPTIONS FOR MAKING IT MORE
ACCESSIBLE. TO EVERYONE AND
ACROSS- AND THEN ALSO THE
SUSTAINABILITY ASPECT YOU KNOW
WE- THIS IS IT HOW CAN WE MAKE
THIS A SUSTAINABLE
TRANSPORTATION OPTION- INSTEAD
OF JUST SOMETHING THAT WILL BE
PROFITABLE SO. THANKS FOR
BRINGING THIS AND I'D ALSO
OFFERED THAT I'M ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I DIDN'T HEAR
ALTHOUGH THERE WAS A LOT OF
STAKEHOLDERS WORK THE ACTUAL
USERS THEMSELVES AND. AND HOW
THIS COULD BE WE CAN BRING
FORTH THE OUR ORGANIZATION AS
WELL AS OTHERS WHO ARE WORKING
AS STAKEHOLDERS IN THIS
PROCESS. NO THANK YOU SO MUCH I
KNOW I SPEAK FOR. THE TWO OTHER
CHAIR. CHAIRMAN OF AND DIES
HERE THAT WE LOOK FOR TO WORK
WITH YOU HERE. IN THE MONTHS TO
COME SO THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU FOR HANGING WITH US AS
WELL. ALL RIGHT PLACE GENERALLY
TO BE TO TURN IT OVER TO
CHAIRMAN FRAZIER THAN DETERMINE
VAL HUMAN FRAZIER- IT HAS BEEN.
AN AMAZING PARTNER THROUGHOUT
THIS. TO TWENTY SIX THANK YOU
SIR- INTO TEAM AS WELL. FOR
YOUR WORK ON THIS. IF YOU'RE
WILLING TO BE A PARTNER AND I
THINK IT'S ALWAYS GOOD RIGHT WE
CAN TRY TO WORK WITH ONE VOICE
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE AND- IT'S.
IT'S BEEN A PLEASURE TO WORK
WITH YOU SIR ALL FROM THE
FLOOR. THANK CHAIRMAN. SO
ESSENTIALLY YOU KNOW WHAT I'VE
COME OUT OF. THIS THIS HEARING
IS AND HEARING FROM THESE.
WONDERFUL PANELISTS IS THAT- WE
HAVE AN ISSUE THAT WE WANT TO
GET A HANDLE ON EARLIER THAN WE
DO LATER AND. WHAT I'D LIKE TO
SEE IS THE STAKEHOLDERS COME
TOGETHER- PRIOR TO THE NEXT
LEGISLATIVE SESSION. AND
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE CONCERNS
HAVE BEEN BROUGHT FORWARD. AND
REMOVE AN ADVERSARIAL HELLO
KIND OF. BACK AND FORTH GOING
FORWARD WE'VE HEARD THE ISSUES
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE'S SAFETY IS OF UTMOST
CONCERN- BUT ALSO- COMING FROM
LOCAL GOVERNMENT I ALSO WANT
LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO HAVE A
VOICE I WANT THEM TO BE ABLE TO
WEIGH IN THAT WHAT WORKS AND
WHAT WILL NOT WORK IN THEIR
COMMUNITY. HI AND I DON'T LIKE
A HEAVY HANDED APPROACH GOING
FORWARD A BY THE SEE I CAN SEE
OF A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF A
BASELINE TO GO FORWARD- BUT I
I'M LOOKING FOR INPUT FROM THE
CITIES ON HOW. THEY CAN BE MORE
EFFECTIVE WITH A. THERE NEEDS
BEING ADDRESSED BY THEMSELVES-
I ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT-
THE WE GIVE EVERY OPPORTUNITY.
FOR ANY ENTITY IN CALIFORNIA TO
BE ABLE TO MAKE. A BUSINESS
SUCCESSFUL AND I WANT THE. ANY
CONSTRAINTS BE BROUGHT FORWARD
TO MISTER BELLER MYSELF OR MR
ROOM ON MCGUIRE THAT. DID THERE
IS SOME KIND OF HEAVY HANDED A
REGULATORY APPROACH IT WOULD
AFFECT THEM IN PRECLUDE THEM
FROM BEING A PART OF AN
EQUATION. OF SUCCESS. SO I WANT
TO THANK THE CHAIR FOR HIS
CONSIDERATION AND INCLUDING THE
ALSO- BUT ALSO THESE WONDERFUL
PANELISTS WHO BROUGHT THIS
INFORMATION ENLIGHTEN ME-
IMMENSELY TODAY ON THIS
EMERGING TECHNOLOGY AND HERO
NOW I MIGHT NOT. HAVE BEEN
INCLINED TO USE IT. BECAUSE OF
LIKE MISTER WELCOME PROBABLY
EXCEED THE CAPACITY OF THE
SCOOTER. BUT I WANT PEOPLE THAT
OR- LESS HEAVY BE ABLE TO
UTILIZE ANYTHING THEY CAN FROM
ABILITY AND- BUT ONE THING I
WILL STATE IS THAT I DO NOT HEY
WE WILL NOT ALLOW THE PEOPLE
DISABILITIES COULD BE- IGNORED
I THINK THAT IS TECHNOLOGY
ADVANCES WE HAVE TO BRING THE
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES WITH
US AND MAKE SURE THAT THEIR
NEEDS ARE ADDRESSED AND AGAIN
HER ANYTHING THAT HAS BEEN
IGNORED THE PAST NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED AND BROUGHT FORTH
BEFORE ANYTHING ELSE GOES
FORWARD. WITH THAT THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS CHAIRMAN
THE FOR TO WORK WITH YOU IR
THANK TURN OVER TO CHAIRMAN
BALLOT WILL TURN OVER THE VICE
CHAIR FOR CLOSING COMMENTS
CHAIRMAN BILL THE STORM I'M
GOING TO ENJOY THE NEXT FEW
MONTHS WORKING ON THIS- AND
HAVE THE HEARING- WE'RE TRYING
TO SCHEDULE OF FEBRUARY. YEAH
FROM THERE SOMETIME BUT. I LOOK
LIKE I SAID EARLIER I WAS.
ATTENDING AM NATIONAL
CONFERENCE IN NON TRANSIT AND-
GOT A LITTLE TASTE GOT
MATERIALS ON. THE KINDS OF
THINGS THAT ARE GOING TO COME
IN THE FUTURE IN TERMS OF
TRANSPORTATION IT'S REALLY
GOING TO BE- A VERY- DYNAMIC.
KIND OF ENVIRONMENT REAL SOON
IN THE FUTURE AND OUR COUNTRY I
THINK WE'RE GONNA HAVE TRANSIT
VILLAGE AYE I- I'M EXCITED
ABOUT OR- OR- HIGHSPEED RAIL
STATION. MULTI MODAL STATION
SAN JOSE WHICH WILL BE THE-
LARGEST- TRANSIT STATION TURNS
A RIDERSHIP IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AND WILL HAVE-
TRANSIT VILLAGES THAT WE'RE
DEVELOPING AROUND- THE BART
STATIONS THAT WERE BUILDING WE-
WERE BUILDING- FOUR MILLION
BILLION FIVE BILLION DOLLAR.
BART EXTENSION. AND IN SAN JOSE
SO AND GIVE IT AND A LOT OF
OTHER COMMUNITIES ARE DOING THE
SAME THING THAT THE HIGH
DENSITY VILLAGES THAT ARE
TALKED ABOUT IN LOS ANGELES
AROUND- THE TRANSIT STOPS IN
LOS ANGELES IS A SIMILAR KIND
OF THING. SO I THINK I THINK
WE'RE GOING TO SEE A LOT OF
THIS. THIS KIND OF. DIFFERENT
KIND OF TRANSPORTATION SYSTEMS
THAT. ARE GOING TO BE USE MORE
AND MORE AND BECOME MORE
PREVALENT- AND I'M VERY EXCITED
ABOUT HOW WE CAN ENCOURAGE- AND
UC'S. MOBILITY DEVICES TO
ENCOURAGE THE USE OF TRANSIT
AND CLEANER AND GET PEOPLE TO
STOP USING AUTOMOBILES. LOOK AT
OTHER OTHER METHODS OF-
CREATING A BETTER ENVIRONMENT
IN A BETTER LIFESTYLE IF YOU
WANT TO SET THAT WE FOR A LOT
OF PEOPLE SO. SO I WILL WORK
HARD HARD ON THAT AND- SEE IT
AS A PIECE TO THE PUZZLE AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR. FIND WORK
AND SPECIALLY BEING HERE AFTER
ALL THE HARDSHIPS SUFFERED
MISTER GERMAN THINK OF OVER THE
LAST- STE FEW WEEKS AND. IT'S
NICE OF YOU TO BE HERE TO SEE
YOU KNOW I THINK IT IS I WAS
KIND OF WORRIED THAT WHETHER OR
NOT YOU BE HER OR NOT I KNOW
YOU SHOWED UP YOU NEED TO ENTER
THE WHOLE HEARING NOTHING
THANKS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SAID ABOUT ONCE TAKE ONCE HE
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR SUPPORT
ALL THROUGHOUT- IN YOU KNOW
THAT MEANS A LOT TO ME AND
THINK THE WORLD IS SIR SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.THE GENTLEMAN
WOULD LIKE TO TURN OVER TO OUR
VICE CHAIRS SERVE FOR CLOSING
COMMENTS AND HAVE SOME QUICK
CLOSING. COMMENTS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. ONE OF THE THINGS
SAID. WHAT WAS BEEN FRUSTRATING
ME. IS THAT- SACRAMENTO TENDS
TO BE MORE REACTIVE THAN
PROACTIVE. AND SO WE'RE NOW
REACTING TO THE- SITUATION OF
THE FIRES STARTED BY UTILITY.
LINES PERHAPS IN IN SO SOME
SOME USERS WE'VE GOT TO GET IN
FRONT OF AND SO. I FIND THIS
TOPIC VERY FACETING WITH A. THE
ABILITY OF THE SHARED ECONOMY
AND NEW MOBILITY OPTIONS IN
THERE'S A LOT MORE COMMON. DOWN
THE LINE IN IN AND WE'VE GOT TO
START GETTING PROACTIVE- WE
HAVE SELF DRIVING VEHICLES. WE
HAVE A YOU KNOW AND I
INCREDIBLE WAY OF PERSONAL
RAPID TRANSIT I DON'T SEE HIGH
SPEED RAIL PERHAPS. IN THE SAME
WAY YOU DO CENTER BELL BUT-
WE'VE WE'VE GOT TO START
THINKING ABOUT WHAT ARE WE
DOING WITH OUR VEHICLES AND HOW
ARE MOVING INDIVIDUALS AND HOW
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE WILL
PLAY INTO THAT. IN THE YEARS TO
COME. IT'S WHY I THOUGHT THE
TITLE WAS WAS SORT OF
INTERESTING YOU KNOW HOW DO WE
REGULATE NEW MOBILITY AND I AND
I JUST WONDER SOMETIMES MISTER
CHAIR IF WE SHOULD SAY HOW DO
WE INCENTIVIZE. AS OPPOSED TO
HOW WE REGULATE HOW DO WE
INCENTIVIZE THE FREE MARKET.
AND PROVIDED TEMPLATE FOR
SUCCESS BECAUSE THIS IS
CALIFORNIA AND THIS IS WHERE
ALL THESE GREAT IDEAS ARE
COMING FROM. IN A AND HOW DO
WE- GIVE THE RIGHT- BORDERS AND
PARAMETERS FOR. SOME CREATIVITY
AND INGENUITY- MOVING FORWARD
AND HOW DO WE AS A GOVERNMENT
REALLY GET IN FRONT OF THAT TO
PROVIDE THE PLATFORM. SO THAT'S
WHAT I'D LIKE TO SEE GOING
FORWARD SO THANK YOU FOR
LETTING ME. SHARE SOME OF THE
STOCK THANK YOU SO MUCH YOU TOO
BYE CHAIRED BY SHARES ALWAYS SO
GOOD IN IS ALL OVER. ALL
COMMITTEE HEARINGS WERE VERY
GRATEFUL SIR LOVE WORKING WITH
YOU. SO BOTTOM LINE IS THIS AND
I'M JUST GONNA STOP YOU HAPPEN
IN TURN. OVER ALL YEAR IN IN
MORE DURING HERE. EVERYONE WHEN
WE TAKE A LOOK AT BOTH BILLS OR
TAKE MOM TO SAY THANK YOU TO
BOTH OFF AUTHORS TO RESEARCHING
THIS FRIEDMAN. UP FOR THEIR
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH THIS
THIS YEAR- BOTH HAD BILL'S
GOING ONE FOCUSING LOCAL
REGULATION THE OTHER AND DATA
SHARING. BOTH WANTED TO
CONTINUE TO MOVE THEIR BILLS
AND THEY'RE WILLING TO BE ABLE
TO WORK WITH THE COMMITTEES. IN
THE SENATE TO BE ABLE TO TAKE
AN OVER ARCHING APPROACH THE
REASON WHY WE WANTED TO TAKE A
THIRTY THOUSAND FOOT APPROACHES
IT'S BEEN VERY HONEST ABOUT IT.
WE TAKE A LOOK AT ISSUES OF
LIKE THE SHARING ECONOMY IT
COULD BE TEEN SEES OR COULD BE-
ROOM SHERRY. OUR HOME SHARING-
WE ALLOW THIS TO GET GOING. AND
THEN WE SAW CHALLENGES AND WE
TRY TO BRING IT BACK. WHAT WE
WANTED TO BE REDUCES TO THIS
RIGHT. PRIOR TO A INDUSTRY
THAT'S GOING TO BE LARGE TAKEN
OFF. HOW CAN WE COME TOGETHER
AS ONE TO TRY TO PUT. SOME
PARAMETERS TO THIS. AND THAT'S
WHY WE ENDED UP HERE TODAY I
THINK THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS
IS GOING TO TAKE A COMPROMISE
AS WE MOVE FORWARD. IT'S GONNA
MEAN COMPROMISE BETWEEN.
CORPORATIONS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IS EVERYONE GOING TO
GET WHAT THEY WANT. PROBABLY
NOT BUT I THINK THAT'S WHAT A
STRONG COMPROMISE IS ALL ABOUT-
SO HERE ARE NEXT STEPS. WE LOOK
AT A JOINT COMMITTEE HEARING.
COMING UP IN FEBRUARY JUDICIARY
WILL ALSO BE INVOLVED
ESPECIALLY IN THE DATA SHARING
SIDE. AND THAT'S WITH CHAIRMAN
JACKSON WE'RE NOT GOING TO GET
INTO HER LANE ON THAT. SHOULD
BE TAKEN LEAD ON ALL ISSUES OF
DATA SHARING- BOTH BILLS WILL
END UP COMING TO GOVERNMENT
FINANCE HERE IN TWENTY TWENTY.
AND OUR COMMITMENT WHETHER IT
IS TO- TO LINE ORDER BIRD OR
THE CONSUMER TOURNEY'S OR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WE'RE GOING TO
WORKING TOGETHER
COLLABORATIVELY. WITH ALL SIDES
TRY TO MAKE THIS WORK. FROM
HERE FROM TO DAY- AND TRYING TO
BE ABLE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHORS- HERE TO BE A START. A
MASSAGE IN THESE BILLS TO MAKE
IT WORK FOR EACH AND EVERYONE.
THEN OBVIOUSLY WE'LL HAVE THAT
DATA SHARING PRIVACY HEARING.
COMING UP IN FEBRUARY WHICH
WILL BE JOINT. WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO OUR PANELISTS WHO
DID A FABULOUS JOB TODAY THANK
YOU. WE WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
SO MUCH OF THE COMMITTEE. FOR
SHOWN UP- AND FOR DOING YOUR
JOB SO WELL. I WANT TO THANK
YOU TO THE STAFF TEAMS. UP FROM
BOTH ASSEMBLY TRANS IS WELLS
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE. ARE
FANTASTIC. I AM VERY VERY
GRATEFUL TO WORK WITH YOU. ALL
RIGHT HOPE EVERYONE HAS A
WONDERFUL HOLIDAY I CAN'T
BELIEVE WE'RE ALMOST AT
THANKSGIVING I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
YOU BUT WHERE THEY HELD THIS
YEAR AGO. I THINK YOU SO MUCH
WE'RE JOURNEY WILL SEE AND HAVE